thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
life is full of exciting events but it
is our first impressions that we
remember best your first diploma
[Applause]
your first job in a big company
portable emotions from the first date
the first expensive things you bought
when you got your first paycheck and
your first Investments with freedom
broker Freedom broker look at your
favorite brands from A New Perspective
hello everybody and welcome to day two
of the feed a world rapid chess
championships this is the rapid portion
the blitz will soon follow in a couple
of days I'm International Martial
Lawrence Trent and I'm absolutely
delighted to be here on chess.com
calling all the action with you today
we're going to give you uh of course an
update of what happened on day one but
first let me introduce my fantastic uh
partner in crime
my good friend and super Grandmaster in
his own right
that is the one and only David Howe
David good morning uh it is morning for
us afternoon for some very early morning
for some lovely to be here with you
yeah thank you Lawrence and hello
everyone uh for those who are with us
yesterday it was a great start to the
world rapid championship in both the
open and the women's section we saw a
few players Sprint to the front after
five rounds uh yeah we saw some great
chess as well some miracle saves some
big blunders some time scrambles we saw
everything and I'm hoping for more of
the same today it's going to be dramatic
as the players Rocky for position just
to try and position themselves perfectly
uh just heading into that final day
tomorrow uh heading into the medal
rounds and yeah Lawrence what are you
looking forward to the most today
well I'm looking forward to a lot of the
pairings we're gonna we're gonna come on
to that but before we do I just want to
give everybody a quick reminder really
of what's at stake because
um
they're not playing for peanuts over
there that's for sure of course the
Pride and Glory of becoming a world
champion is huge uh and a lot of these
players who adore Blitz and Rapid really
hold this in very high esteem so this is
not just a random tournament this is a
legitimate World Championship that
they're playing for however they're also
playing for some big bucks if we look at
the prize breakdown now you'll see
that some of the prizes are well huge uh
if you we look at the rapid uh for the
women's tournament for example remember
there's an open and a women's first
prize is forty thousand dollars
huge amount second is thirty third is 20
and so on and so forth as you can see
for a lot of these players that kind of
money is a deal breaker for their year
um especially perhaps not the absolute
Elite of uh of their respective fields
and in the open section we have a
slightly bigger prize fund sixty
thousand for first fifty for second 40
for third
and so on and so forth still huge
amounts of money at stake
um and they'll be fighting tooth and
nail to get those prizes
um what we need to do now David of
course and perhaps you can take us
through the next part is uh actually see
what happened after day one who is
leading and who is doing well uh from
day one
that's right Lawrence and uh let's start
with the women's section they had four
rounds yesterday a slightly shorter
event in the women's section uh and
after those four rounds of Valentina
gunina has uh left to the front with
four wins out of four winning all her
games actually in great style in
tactical style uh she is followed by
five players including tanzong Yi a
finalist in the women's candidates
tournament including Leia Gary Felina
who's a very young uh star Prodigy uh on
B Connor Elena daniellian Mahmoud Zada
as well some very experienced players
there some of the real creme de La Creme
of the women's chess scene
and uh if we see some of the match-ups
today we do see that Valentina gunina
the leader is up against tanzong Yi a
huge pairing there two of the highest
seeds and uh we do see on the top 10
boards all titled players a couple of
youngsters creeping up and uh yeah some
big big games that we will follow
throughout the day meanwhile if we go to
the rapid section Lawrence there are not
just one leaders there are four leaders
right now including Magnus Carlson who
will want to win a title of course he's
about to let his uh classical title go
he is joined by Vladimir fedes Arjun
aragaisi and Jordan van Forrest who was
maybe one of the most impressive players
of yesterday
yep some uh some big names at the top
and of course Magnus being up there
shouldn't surprise anyone as David said
even though he is relinquishing his
classical title he still uh believes
that this tournament is one of the most
important of the year he adores winning
uh these kinds of tournaments wrapped
and Blitz and so he is fully focused to
do that
um Jordan had a great day as you said uh
David Arjun also had a pretty good day
um and we can see a few other Superstar
names notably the likes Gary Duda sarin
the young Indian and how about Adra
satorov last year's winner keeping Pace
with the leaders do not rule him out he
can make a late run for it not even a
late run but you know as long as you are
half a point of Point behind the leader
you always have a chance you'll see no
Hikaru Nakamura on that leaderboard
um not uh keeping the pace just yet but
with two full days to go plenty of time
to make up ground you can't afford to
lose too many more points some other big
names on that board yeah the promisee
we've got Fabiana caruana of course
Daniel dubov also on their mama jar
about timia and see volodar Moore's in
as well I mentioned him on the first day
young Russian Talent uh might make a run
for it maybe he'll be an interesting
quantity for the remainder of this
tournament plenty of action however and
the match-ups today David well well
I mean one clear
stand out for me board one Carlson
against
bang Forest what are your expectations
for this game
I mean that is huge for many reasons not
only are they both on fire right now but
uh Jordan van Forest has helped Magnus
Carlson in the past he was one of his
seconds uh in the successful 2021 World
Championship campaign so uh they're
great friends they're great Rivals we're
gonna follow that one very very closely
I'm looking as well at the other leaders
of course for the save and Arjun
aragaisy who I see already is a big
favorite in the future chat but uh also
abdusator if you mentioned he lost the
Magnus yesterday but he is well in the
mix up against Duda and despite Nakamura
fashion legrath two Titans of the game
not being in the top 20 uh as we saw in
the standings they are still however on
the top 10 boards they will be fighting
to try and get on a streak today they
need to do that as you mentioned in
order to keep pace so huge games if we
look down on board 9 or 10 Nakamura by
Sheila Graf who are the favorites
wanting to win at all costs
yep and uh just to remind everybody the
open section is a 13 round Swiss so
today is round six and the women's
section it is an 11 ounce Swiss today is
round five
uh 15 minutes plus 10 seconds per player
each round lasts in the region of an
hour hour and 15 minutes sometimes the
games go a bit longer we saw for example
yesterday a couple of rook and Bishops
Rook endings
um so sometimes we have to wait for
those to play out uh and of course as
for any Swiss tournament it is the
winner with the most amount of points
wins tournament there is a tie there
will be some Blitz playoffs if we get to
that point we will take you through all
the action of course we're going to take
a shot a like take a look now at a live
shot from the playing or Yankee stuff
Duda settling in uh to his chair playing
black today
um yeah keeping pace of course with the
leaders on four playing against reigning
rapid world champion Abdul satorov Abdul
sansourov you know
years ago David
um
before he even won the world rapid
before he even won uh the Olympiad
titles with Uzbekistan I remember
talking to my dear friend rustam kazir
majanov I asked for a stamp I said
who are the biggest talents coming up at
the moment
and he said keep your eye out for this
kid episode 12 and
when somebody like rustam says that you
take note because he doesn't say it
lightly in terms of Mega talents and
this was probably in the region of three
years ago three or four years ago
um and his prophecy has very much come
to fruition Abdullah it's not often at
the age of 18.
maybe he's 19 now not even sure maybe
he's uh I'll double check that but
you become
old rapid champion and Olympic champion
in the same year effectively
yeah I think he was 17 when he won the
title last year he was 18 when he won
the Olympiad gold some incredible
achievements at such a young age we
still have just sort of a right of do
sator of arrive now we see Jordan
vanfurst get ready to Green Magnus
Carlson at the board and we also talked
about the prizes earlier Lawrence and
those prices up prices are potentially
life-changing for these youngsters
especially for Abdul sotorov he was uh
greeted as a national hero when he
returned to Uzbekistan after winning the
gold last year not only did he win first
prize in this event which can help fund
his coaching his tournaments his
expenses he was also gifted an apartment
and uh more money by the uzbekist stunt
president so this tournament has that
unique ability to launch players out
there into the Limelight and these names
now that as you mentioned were becoming
accustomed to like Abdul sator of like
van forest and they did actually make
some big breakthroughs in events like
this in previous years I remember Daniel
duboff for example winning in 2018 and
that was a launch pad for his career
Nihao sarri now walking in the
background did so well in the global
Chess Championship this could be a huge
milestone for him if he can keep Pace
with those leaders but meanwhile where
is Magnus Carlson
great Keeps Us waiting as per usual yeah
he doesn't I mean actually he has come
early before I I I don't think he has a
set Rhythm whether he comes late or
early but this time he's coming a bit
later there he is Magnus Carlson shaking
hands with his good friend Yoda van for
us of course these guys having worked
together in training camps for magnus's
World title uh attempt well World title
defense I should say against Yan the
problem she
they may have even worked together prior
to that right David it wasn't just the
promise you were titled I think even
though Jordan a couple years earlier
wasn't as strong as he is now he's
always been full of fantastic ideas
um and uh Magnus with white today
um you know he's going to be looking to
win they are of course good friends but
that doesn't factor into this game
they're not going to play soft against
each other
uh Magnus for sure is looking to put the
pressure on with the white pieces be
really curious to see what kind of
strategy Jordan employs
um he knows Magnus very well
and as we said we see from velvet Canyon
19 Battle of the finest here in chess
that might be true although Yan the
problem she has got a good claim to that
with his fresh cut
did you see yandupona she's dance in the
background there Lawrence it looks like
the players are in great spirits as they
start the first round of the day I don't
think they were applauding themselves I
think they were uploading some uh local
dignitaries maybe some fide officials
who are going to come in and make the
first move the ceremonial first move but
uh yeah often the players they're
itching to get going it's nice to see
them though in such relaxed uh in such a
relaxed mood uh in the foreground we
also see board one of the women's
section
it is indeed yes and
uh we see as you said women's nice and
spacious that's what I like most about
this particular
particular venue very very cool to see
uh great conditions for the players I've
heard absolutely no complaints
whatsoever about the playing conditions
thus far so uh that's really good news
really nice to hear you can also see
that most players are also abiding by
the official dress code you can see
players in formal attire
um suits and shirts and uh sort of
business attire for the ladies I like
that makes it feel more professional
um I'm actually a fan of the dress code
as it turns out for official free day
events
yeah
sorry I was going to say there has been
controversial in the past Lawrence but
uh yeah this this tournament so far has
been well it's been refreshing it's just
been purely focused on the chassis there
is a delay meanwhile
um we did see Hans Neiman stride in in
the background there looks like the
final few players are just entering the
tournament Hall maybe some last minute
Security checks holding up the start of
this round any predictions on the top
boards for example the board we're
seeing right now Lawrence
um
I have to go with Magnus purely because
even though Jordan had a good day
yesterday
um I think Magnus with white is and of
course he's a an incredibly tough
customer regardless uh but for Jordan
especially I feel as though
Magnus is probably an unpleasant
opponent
um you've got all the dynamic of working
together and analyzing together and him
knowing more or less how you think and
how you play and what you've looked at
[Music]
um
I for example I think Jordan will do a
lot better against
you know other super super super top
players
uh compared to making you know if Jordan
were to play nepo and Hikaru and I feel
like his win rate is much greater there
of course you can claim that Magnus is
just the number one anyway so this this
analogy isn't quite relevant but there's
something special about playing
something you've worked with for months
on end and I don't think Jordan's record
against Magnus is
that great in the first place
um yeah
it's not great Lawrence but it's not bad
either maybe there's many drawers
actually
um I was surprised to see for such for
such programming players as you say for
such uncompromising players
um okay we saw the handshake
yeah and they are off I was going to say
opening predictions as well
um it starts with the English opening
Magnus he plays the move G3 on the
second move we saw him pushing a pawn
there and he does this all the time
against Jordan every time he has white
he fear and keto is the white bishop and
uh yeah maybe it's just a certain
strategy
designated against this specific
opponent but it is interesting that
Magnus really respects Jordan isn't
maybe brave enough to pick up the King's
Pawn on move one to play D4 and move one
to enter what we call the open games uh
instead it's more of a flank opening uh
Madness though allowing black to push
forward in the center and it's early
days Lawrence but this is quite a rare
position uh as far as I know what are
your thoughts on this uh this decision
especially by Magnus
I like it I mean Magnus knows how well
prepared your audience and Magnus knows
you know just how uh
creative Jordan is
um
he's got tons of ideas in classical
Orthodox positions so I like what Magnus
is doing and what have they got they've
got a kind of reverse benoni Jordan is
deciding whether to push this Pawn to uh
to C5 or not or whether just to develop
the night out to C6 and play E5 so it's
just kind of a kind of toss-up right now
for for Jordan he does go with C5 which
is of course completely reasonable and
we do we are going to get a benoni now
David uh where uh you know Magnus has
theoretically got a few extra Tempe
compared to normal because of course
he's got you know not for a start he's
got the white pieces so he's got an
extra Tempo because of the reverse
situation but he's also the audience
already committed to E7 E6
um and a lot of the time you want to
push this Pawn to E5
so as it turns out
um this is actually quite a
quite a favorable
a little uh very sort of
I think Magnus can be very happy to have
this uh against the ordinance it's
basically a but only two Tempe up
which is yeah which is very nice
yeah you say that Lawrence but Noni is
still a benoni uh even if you're too
tempy up and it's not necessarily an
opening with the greatest reputation at
the top level still white has a
long-term weakness on the D3 Square
um as you mentioned white will get some
activity Magnus perhaps more experienced
than his younger colleague in these
types of Pawn structures but uh trust me
I've played plenty of reverse but only
so having it from the white side and
I get 10 moves down the line and I'm
thinking where did my extra two Tempe go
like it still has a very uh simple
development Black's Knight can come out
to C6 black Bishop will just sit happily
on either C5 or E7 and
um you know still some work to be done
later I'm just thinking as well you
mentioned Jordan being so creative in
the opening I've never met with someone
uh with so much kind of enthusiasm for
chess on enthusiasm for studying the
opening phase maybe Magnus has looked at
Jordan with both colors and Jordan with
white very rarely faces the benoni or
I've never seen him really face the
benoni so it's just a again a very
specific opening choice I don't think
Magnus would be brave enough to play
this against the likes of Hikaru
Nakamura Yanda ponyshi but uh maybe just
spotting a small [ __ ] in uh Jordan's
armor I mean while white brings his
Bishop out and this is a very nice move
uh usually that white dark Square Bishop
that's landed on G5 is the problem child
in this opening it often lacks a good
home a good Square so he just wants to
trade it off for a night it's the white
G2 Bishop the light Square Bishop that
will be the star player the MVP a bit
later on and uh yeah I mean I think it's
still early too early to say whether
this has been a good opening choice for
Magnus but uh Jordan yeah it's
definitely up to him to prove that he
understands these positions because
Magnus for sure if he can he's versatile
enough to uh kind of freestyle this type
of opening with white
totally agreed and remember we are going
to be keeping a guy on all the other
games as they develop nothing too crazy
that I can see just yet uh it seems on
the other boards I am keeping an eye and
of course in the women's section as well
uh big game on board one in my opinion
with gunina playing against uh tanjonggi
massive massive game I think if gunina
actually manages to win that uh that's
huge for her because she's a momentum
player purely a momentum player uh
Valentina when she's on a winning streak
she can put together 10 wins and when
she's on a losing streak she can lose
six in a row uh she is she is one of
those players which is obviously
fantastic for us because it's it's fun
to commentate on she's not just going to
be making draws and
um you know settling so I will keep an
eye on on that particular game as well
of course we want to hear from you in
the chat well do do make us uh you know
aware of your thoughts don't fear please
keep it of course clean no politics no
religion as per usual we're just talking
about the chess today so chess content
only
all righty yeah no and Lawrence uh
talking at the chess we saw a great
feature chat there a moment ago I think
it was by Rex Matthew and he was saying
the benoni is it one of those strategic
openings those strategically complex
openings that kind of went out of
fashion in the computer era and I would
say yes and no to that it kind of went
out of fashion well it comes in and out
of fashion I would say but it's mainly
because it's so uh kind of complex to
handle especially for the side with the
pawn structure that Magnus has right now
this is a reverse bernoni as we say and
this D3 Pawn is a long-term weakness end
games can often be very difficult and if
you don't get activity if you can't
fight against the opponent's Center
which uh Jordan has just kind of
fortified by pushing his Pawn to E5 if
you can't fight against the center can't
undermine it then you're just simply
struggling long term so I think it's
just as much the Practical uh kind of
difficulties of the position as the
computer evaluations of course computer
evaluations often do favor the side with
the extra Central Pawn in this case it's
black but uh yeah it is as you mentioned
as well very complex and that's what
Magnus is aiming for it just suits the
tournament situation remember because it
is a big Swiss you need as many wins as
possible you can't just Coast your way
to the Finishing Line with a bunch of
drawers you will get overtaken so Magnus
uh especially with the white pieces he
doesn't want kind of a flat drier
position
um which actually is my Approach often
when I play Jordan but uh Magnus these
days uh Magnus 2.0 as I call him he has
evolved into a very uh very kind of
ambitious
player who's willing to play All Sorts
positions he's played everything under
the sun right Lawrence uh all sorts of
Four structures openings
he certainly has but I'm not a
fan of what he's done with his Knight on
uh on E2 today I have to say I mean if
we just go back around here in this
opening I was very surprised that even
around here that he didn't just find a
way to just go I don't know Knight F3
for example and put the Knight on a more
standard Square the Knight on E2 does
not make a really uh sort of good
impression into my eyes it's it's it's
it's it's it's out of the game it's uh
it's it's it's being dominated by black
Central pawns and I'm just wondering how
he plans to get it into the game is he
really going to play F4 this looks
incredibly risky to play like this to
weaken all your dark squares
um and what are you supposed to do for
example if you jump in with a typical
move like 94 I go back to E7 black is
ready to play F5 and it doesn't feel
like I've got what I would term as
typical benoni play this Knight on E2 is
really causing me huge grief David I
don't know what you think about that
I completely agree I love the fact that
Jordan as soon as he saw the night land
on E2 he planted his Pawn on E5 and that
E5 Pawn does dominate the uh Knight on
E2 and this is something that I learned
a lot when I started kind of
experimenting with Fisher random chess
and Knight is only as good as the
squares it can jump to and often Knights
on the second rank are dominated by
pawns on the fifth rank likewise the
knights on the third rank dominated by
pawns on the sixth rank
um uh yeah Magnus he's got one bad piece
that piece you highlighted on E2 and
therefore his position does look a bit
dodgy and maybe he does need to take
direct action F4 as you say pushing
forward breaking up in the center when
black has Bishops
it doesn't feel right somehow but then
again what else I mean it looks just as
wrong to play a move like H3 G4 plant
the White Knight on G3 because you're
giving up dark squares yes white to
light squared Bishop is great but you
can't give up the hosing color complex
really and uh therefore we see Magnus
deep in thought he's already already
significantly behind on the clock which
is never a good sign
um I do see in the feature chat a lot of
Magnus fans including uh enote 53 saying
the Magnus effect will come into play at
any time it often does but maybe this
isn't the position uh where the Magnus
effect is so relevant okay he plays Rook
move it looks like from his hand
movements there we will see rookie one
on the board but again where's that root
going it's blocked by this
Troublesome Knight on E2 this lost piece
which hasn't found yet its ideal squares
I think Magnus
hey wow you wouldn't really go for it
with H5 I was going to say I think
Magnus just has a slope in mind maybe
moving that Knight out of the way but
Jordan is not going to give him that
time going on the attack already this is
often a signal that black wants to put
this Pawn clamp down on the king side
put it on H3 ideally and Magnus loves
this strategy himself
what do you think of this Loris it's
looking good for you already as far as I
can tell I can't stand magnus's position
here and he uh he will also understand
that this this has gone actually
horribly wrong
for Magnus Carlsen uh the position is
just bad
you can't and he goes C5 now which you
know uh uh you know a typical way to try
and get some space
uh for his pieces
but
um
wow he must be really upset with with
just how things have gone here I mean
ultimately let's have a look at what's
going on black has got the two Bishops
uh he's got space in the center space on
the king's side
and
okay this move C5 he's he's trying to
get some but it's again I can't help but
look at this Knight on E2 this is the
problem piece were this Knight on F3
the whole position would be different
because there'd be pressure against the
E5 Pawn uh you could maneuver both
Knights to these C4 and E4 squares you
could actually sort of put together some
some play
but the fact that they are both
unable to get there at the moment
because of this night I I'm very
skeptical
I won't say that Magnus is lost here but
he must be a lot worse surely I don't
see any
really seriously positive
elements to his position okay Rook C1
and now Lawrence say I've got to say I
completely agree there is a lot of
messages in the future chat though
saying yes it's a benoni so it will look
bad but maybe long-term activity there's
also a message saying Magnus might have
lost the opening battle but it's still
the middle game ahead you've got to beat
him in the middle game and end game two
and uh I agree I detest magnus's
position I would love to have the black
pieces here and so much flexibility
Black's Pawn is flying forward to H4
maybe a pawn coming to F5 but what next
and uh
would you still back Jordan here
um in a position where
okay he's playing on the other side of
the board now pushes his Pawn forward to
A4 I was gonna say you've got to be
consistent you've got to be direct uh It
Feels Like Jordan with his last move
putting points on H5 and A4 he's playing
on both flanks is black ready for that
one
nicely
yeah I didn't think A4 was was too
necessary actually
um I guess
in this position here I guess the
question is
do you ever want to give up this light
squared Bishop for this night probably
not maybe you should just keep on going
with H4 I I didn't see a problem just
playing H4 here I don't see a big
benefit in inserting A4
and now at C4 and it's these little
moments when you play against Magnus
it's these little just these little
moves where suddenly
uh you know when Magnus gets a bit of
momentum starting it becomes
it becomes very very tricky uh and very
very awkward
so this is I I'm not
a huge fan let's put it like that of
what Jordan has done here with A4 and H5
I think he should have just gone Pawn to
H4 tried to create some chances on the
king side and now he's got a difficulty
because of course the point is Bishop
takes C5 runs into at least Knight takes
E5 and there might be something even
better for example taking on C6 and now
Knight takes E5 where white winds are
pulling back and more because C6 is
hanging and
you know with this Pawn on H5 again your
position could just collapse here as as
black so you can't really play like this
so Jordan goes for Bush B6
and now Bishop takes C6
news mental decision
but but probably uh probably a decent
one right because if B takes C6 Knight
takes E5 I say of one upon let's say and
the point is Queen D5 doesn't work
because of Knight F4
and all of a sudden suddenly that piece
becomes that piece on E2 which was uh
dead a moment ago it becomes the killer
piece oh precisely
so this is this is a Troublesome spot
now for Jordan
and is he really thinking about playing
Bishop takes C4 here I guess he is
I guess he is because if Bishop takes B7
you've got the Intermezzo Bishop B3
Queen D2 but even this looks scary I
mean C6 is coming next I've given up a
pawn
yeah it looks like uh okay Jordan didn't
go for this in the end he would have
just been a pawn down as you mentioned
that c Pawn would have been a monster
past pawn and uh okay he's chosen to go
upon down in this manner Instead at
least he has the bishop pair here some
holes around the white king that he can
hope to take advantage of that white uh
that white knight is coming forward to
F4 now it's all about whether black can
keep his light squared Bishop intact
because he needs that one to deliver
checkmate
yeah suddenly you're right uh Lawrence
just kind of this specific scenario it
feels like LAX Bishops can't get active
in time Jordan decides to attack on a
white Rooks there's Bishop G5 that Rook
on C1 now hanging but do you protect it
that's the first question you can block
this attack with a pawn do you throw
pawns forward weaken the white king
further
yeah I mean I'm not sure about F4 I mean
it might be okay though because if for
example Bishop F6 Knight takes C6
you might just say so what I've won a
bunch of Pawns Queen D5 you've even got
Knight B4 for example then I could just
come back this way and
unless you've got mate quickly
uh you know you are you are in trouble
here so
I'm not
and and actually we we get Bishop G5
Knight takes C6 and look at this David
Magnus has decided to go for the
pragmatic solution which is to give up
the exchange I think for example after
Queen D7 I think his main idea is
actually just to take on D4 like this
and after Bishop takes C1 to play Queen
take C1 and say uh thank you very much
I've got how many ports
three three
Exchange
[Music]
oh too much yeah
yeah I was going to say as well maybe
black has a problem in terms of which
Square to choose with the queen because
uh if you go to D7 Magnus doesn't even
have to give up the exchange white can
drop the Knight back to E5 oh yeah next
move F4 comes you've pocketed two Pawns
in this process uh if Black's Queen goes
to for example D5 then Knight E takes D4
and uh sorry in a couple of moves ago
yeah in this position if Queen D5 Knight
E takes D4 and you can't even take on C1
now oh my God Knight E7 check ideas
yeah there's there's tactical ideas
everywhere no matter where you go with
the queen you will get hit by one of the
white Knights I think in every variation
so incredible just the fact that White's
getting three pawns it's uh again
specific tactics it's uh Magnus sensing
the moment and calculating so well and
we were praising Jordan's position
praising the opening but I think it was
just that one moment when he played H5 a
couple of moves later he played A4 push
him on both flanks you've got to be
consistent uh you've got to stick to one
plan for better or worse and yeah it was
just that moment of kind of indecision
uh maybe
uh yeah I don't want to say uh being too
ambitious but yeah I was Jordan maybe
just taking his eye off the ball for one
second and Magnus has jumped on the
trance as all the top players do
very very disappointing stuff
for
uh for Jordan uh after such a promising
opening
um you know it's quite remarkable
actually that Magnus was able to even
get this position
you know uh it is remarkable uh that
this has happened in just four moves
other games perhaps uh we we should have
a look at and I can see well well go on
but
yeah yeah let's go there
wow this is this game looks
I mean it's just exploded in one move
we'll just have a we'll just go back
literally one move here we can see in
this position
uh this is a standard looking Queen's
Gambit Klein structure all major pieces
on the board all minor pieces on the
board nothing really to write home about
and yet
after the next move Rook fd8 bang nihal
sarin Knight takes E6 absolutely
fantastic classic sacrifice here now the
bar isn't going insane which is uh of
course a an indication to me that this
isn't a winning sacrifice nonetheless
it's a very very uh sort of classic way
and Rook takes C4 the counter sacrifice
here
brilliant stuff by Jan napomnushy giving
back material to avoid disaster along
this diagonal here I absolutely love
this I think this is brilliant by yeah
napometri now there's a bunch of
calculation that's required
maybe we could have also shown what
would have happened if black had taken
the bait if black had taken the
sacrifice
um it did look like they could take the
Knight and not immediately suffer any
consequences but
um yeah Lawrence I guess the initiative
Burns bright after Bishop takes E6 check
and the King moves some white tonight
jumping forward to G5 a bit similar to
uh the attack that Magnus Carlson had
yesterday against Abdul sotorov
um yeah King f8 for example or or h8
even
even scarier but yeah Knight G5 coming
forward Knight takes H7 might be on top
just bring the White Queen to H5 later
um maybe it's just too strong long term
even if there's no immediate knockout
blow
um so yeah it looks like Napoleon
actually had to find this uh cunning
resource just giving up some material
and this is the current position after
that rotate C4 and the Knight eventually
fell and it's now a rook for two nights
uh White has a pawn an extra Pawn as
well does feel like black king is a bit
Airy a bit vulnerable
what do you think Lawrence can white
take advantage or
has black got everything covered maybe
black will drop back with a knight to f8
next move and they do say a knight on f8
there's no mate uh it looks like
napoleonishi is defending
yeah I think Jan is is just about okay
here uh just looking at the position to
be honest uh the Night Comes and he's a
very sort of uh a very
um
resilient Defender actually full of
resources both on the attack and in
defense think people underestimate just
how much of a good Defender he really is
uh because he can put up resistance
um and this position just looks totally
unclear to me David I don't know about
you I I don't know who I would choose
any I would probably choose white
because I'm a sucker for open files and
ropes and a bit of activity and a bit of
initiative but I think objectively black
is probably doing all right
yep I completely agree uh long term the
black pieces will combine after all you
have more pieces than white does so
uh long time you're doing well but still
in Rapid chess I would be a bit scared
especially facing someone as dangerous
as nihal sarin um like you said with
black slightly weakening with blacks
kind of slightly clumsy setup right now
but uh it's looking in the balance let's
check back in on this one a bit later
um several other several other
candidates we could jump to right now
Lawrence which games catcher right
actually I want to point out donchenko
against Rapport just briefly yeah for
the pawn structure just because uh I've
never seen this Pawn structure in my
life before I've played chess a long
time but uh this one looks pretty unique
and wow if you think of this Lawrence
well the computer hates rapport's
position and that's probably because
this Pawn on C6 is just not available at
the moment uh which is you know clearly
a problem for Rapport and but if you
look at the time situation here we can
see that vonchenko only has a minute 48
report has got uh all the time in the
world 12 minutes so denchenko really
really struggling on the clock he now
plays the move Queen H2 and maybe he's
going for it now maybe he's going to go
G5 and H5 and try and exert some
pressure the position you know
objectively looks horrible for Rapport
he's got no entry squares on the queen
side
I mean you've got this Pawn on C6 if you
manage to consolidate this Pawn I don't
see how you would ever be happy here
basically as
um as as Rapport it looks horrific to me
but then again what do I know
I I mean I I completely agree Lawrence
and there's a lot of uh kind of love and
hate for the pawn structure in the
feature chat uh but this is the type of
position yes I agree it's good for white
objectively but your Pawn structure does
look like a pack of cards uh you know if
one of them Falls over if you lose one
Pawn if black can strike break out
somehow then it might all just collapse
for like you have extended very far
forward especially on the king side
White's King could be a Target later
Rapport blocks up the center now I am
wondering where the black Knight's going
there we go it retreats
at least the C6 Pawn now is vulnerable
at least the connection between White's
bishop and that pawn has been broken
also the clock time donchenko down to
one minute against 12 foot report one of
the pre-tournament favorites
um so yeah I'm not writing this one off
I just wanted to point it out because
it's it's typical kind of chaotic fun
from reports uh and we love to see it we
love to see these really weird
unorthodox uh positions that he seems to
get every single time
yeah uh he does he I mean he did calm
down in recent years I think people
forget that ricardi you know you got to
27 60 70-ish uh for a reason he he kind
of played a bit more I mean I remember
years and years ago when I was even
playing in the same tournaments as him
in Gibraltar and whatnot before he
became super super Elite how uh you know
he was playing aptly wild and wacky
stuff but he grounded himself and he
started playing more mainstream uh stuff
for sure and that obviously contributed
to his ascent uh but in Rapid and Blitz
I think he certainly feels the
propensity towards uh you know going a
bit more crazy that he feels like he can
go a bit more crazy
uh but we'll see we'll keep an eye on
this position
in the meantime Lawrence maybe we can go
back to Magnus against the ordinance
let's do some developments in that game
uh the key game of the round after all
and uh upon structure in this one very
very far from standard as well white has
two extra pawns if I'm counting
correctly but black does have a clamp
Black's Bishop now locking down that
Queen side Black's Queen trying to sneak
in towards the white king
to be honest I would take the pawns the
evaluation bar seems to agree it thinks
that white is perfectly safe why it's
two extra one should win the day but
work to be done do you think
oh absolutely I mean this is I mean
it looks bad for Jordan though I mean we
have to we have to be honest this
position does look atrocious
uh you know the D4 Pawn is weak the
Knight on F4 is nicely Consolidated here
H5 is hanging in all variations if you
manage to uh to mop these these pawns up
I think you're going to be in instead so
I'm not exactly very bullish let's say
towards uh Jordan's chances here and the
the bar obviously agrees because the bar
has gone crazy here
um yeah and Magnus is up on the clock as
well I don't really see many redeeming
features here actually for Jordan I
think this is just a case of how does
Magnus want to
to convert
Yeah the more I look at it the more I
agree uh Queen F2 you can maybe just
take on H5 as you mentioned but Queen F2
uh it's just a mopping up job now going
for those weak black pawns and uh as was
seen in the feature chat there it does
look almost resignable
um so yeah difficult times we could see
an early win a great start to the day
for Magnus and Magnus did actually say
it yesterday because he had three hours
of press conferences then five six hours
of playing chess he said he was feeling
exhausted but uh he is a Terminator as
uh he and says there he's when he's on
fire he's just a tough man to stop
Jordan one or two kind of substandard
moves subpar moves and he was punished
immediately that's Chess at the top
level unfortunately it's brutal and
maybe let's see the next move from
Magnus but I would also love to see the
top Board of the women's section because
that's absolutely fire right now
yeah Queen F2 was played no real
surprise uh to to see this move just
targeting targeting B4 and now I expect
he's just gonna win a pawn here uh which
uh looks looks reasonable
um and
uh yeah I think that uh we're going to
get a pretty straightforward Magnus
Victory and I'm happy to go to that top
board as you said uh David in the wins
section because it's an important one
it's good enough against tanjongi and
we've got fire on the board but it looks
ropey for Valentina it looks like a
fantastic position for black here the
computer agrees White's piece is all
over the place black lovely and
centralized
um David
and Knight takes E3 just played hold on
isn't that just the end of the queen
takes d8 wow look at this and you can't
take back because of the back rank mate
this is fantastic so you have to go
Knight take C2
okay but now black has got an extra one
extra piece
yeah those pieces are a bit clumsy
though that Black Knight on C2 offside
could get trapped that black Bishop 183
could get trapped I mean you would take
black with the extra piece I don't see
any immediate knockout blow uh it's
unclear whether black is even
threatening to take the White Queen
maybe that would result in some
exchanges which would be favorable for
black
um so maybe that's a small threat now
maybe the White Queen has to move uh in
which case where two but
she is extremely precise with her
calculations
um yeah Lawrence I'm struggling to come
up with a move for white
absolutely I I I I don't like this at
all and a piece is a piece I'm sorry you
know the pieces are slightly clumsy but
it's you know let's say after Queen D2
the Knight comes back to P4 can be
recycled always to C6
um there's even ideas of going E3
ruining the structure and opening up
this bishop I think I'll you know
objectively speaking this has to be just
absolutely horrific
for
um for Valentina I don't see many
practical chances that said she is a
fighter she is Warrior and as Anita
drink said in the Super Chat she is
Valentina the Destroyer so she's they
don't give up ever they do not give up
so I'm very maybe in that final position
that final position Lawrence after Queen
D2 the night before at least you can try
Knight F5 maybe and there are some
threats uh in the uh if the like night
lands on D6
um that will be a family Fork hitting
the queen Rook uh Queen rook and Bishop
if the Knight lands there so that is
true some hope Black's King is still a
bit uh uncomfortable on the back rank
I'm not writing it off yet but as you
say the clock situation is against her
um yeah obviously the material counters
against her she plays Queen D6 instead
and that should give black the time now
to start consolidating no threats for
whites that I can see and pieces of
piece yeah looking good
looks very very dodgy indeed for
gunina uh just very quickly in other
news in the women's section we're
obviously looking at board one there
looks as our garafulina you mentioned
her earlier David has got a great
position against murder uh we can uh
quickly I guess look at that
um she's got a crushing attack actually
here looks like with white black king in
big big trouble a lot of the other games
apparently at the moment look a bit
level so of course we're going to keep
an eye on all of this uh but looks
pretty okay so far yeah this is
yep all right yeah this is the dream I
was going to say Lawrence uh attacking
and you haven't even sacrificed anything
this is a dream yeah for white I mean
the white king is is nicely protected
this bishop is pinned just looks very
bad for black not really much more to
say it doesn't even look like you've got
to move your pinned in two ways here
which which is very very nasty indeed
and I will say garafolina she's a very
young player with the white pieces here
winning this game we think but I did
have a chat with Vladimir kramnik a few
years ago and he mentioned her as one of
the big talents to watch out for uh in
years to come so as you mentioned with
Abdul satorov high hopes were predicted
for him many years ago and same now for
garethalina and uh yeah it looks like
she's doing very well in this tournament
so far and black will be lucky to
survive this big attack meanwhile should
we check back in on the latest
developments it looks like Magnus is
about to uh win that game it might be
entering the final few moves now he is
still three pawns up
and everything else has disappeared it's
just a uh matter of technique as they
say how will Magnus finish this game off
well I think you can just take another
Pawn here if you want I mean just just
take a three Pawn Yeah it's greedy but
it is what it is this is just one check
Quincy one you can just go King G2
um you can't even take here because
after Rook A8 King H7 Queen F5 you're
either getting mated or you're winning a
rook it's probably just mating one isn't
it actually G6 Queen takes F7 is just
mate
yep uh Magnus decides to go for another
route which is more than fine he just
wins the sport I actually don't uh
expect
uh Jordan to
to really waste too much energy here is
a lot of Pawns down King H2 will be
played by Magnus here after Queen F3
windy five now he's going to slowly
encroach with his Queen he can even play
21 here trying one out and that's what
he does of course just trying to win
this A4 pawn and now if the queen has to
move you can go D5 Queen B5 you can even
just go D5 here give up the B2 Pawn it's
no big deal something like this King H3
Queen A3 D6 and the queen just does not
make it back in time and you can resign
um
yeah fairly fairly standard stuff
I love it Lawrence you're just
spitballing these incredible variations
just kind of off the top of your head
and I mean I love D5 you've got to
calculate that one uh correctly but
you're right it's just uh I mean magnets
will play it I think yeah not too much
to calculate right the King has got a
lovely safe Square on on H3 and I just
don't see it being a big deal basically
so
I fully expect yes I fully expect uh
Magnus to just play D5 he's got plenty
of time three minutes just making sure
that Jordan doesn't have any
resources but Jordan's body language
also if you look at him in the chair
there he's basically he understands that
this is just
um a very unpleasant position and
Magnus will play D5 it's the principled
move he's enjoying he's enjoying it as
well
um maybe he's just no I mean there's not
really much to talk about no there's
there's been a little repetition here
of moves
the insta Channel his inner Lawrence
Trent he needs to channel you and do
some calculation
for the most direct approach no he's not
I am surprised I am surprised because
that looked very straightforward to me
that looked like that didn't require
almost any calculation at all uh so I am
I am surprised
um
at least we'll be treated to a few
minutes more of this game a bit more
action from Magnus uh rather than
finishing it off he's just going to sit
there and show us how to win Queen end
games
yeah and uh meanwhile yeah meanwhile
some other action elsewhere it looks
like many many balanced games some cage
has done all the other top boards
um yeah I'm just looking through right
now Lawrence it looks like the Nihao
Saron against the punishy game has
evolved quite significantly oh wow okay
goodness I mean the Queens are off the
board
what's that night doing on A6 for black
well that could always come in right or
something like that uh it could even
come in straight away
uh but this is
this is a
very very uh sort of
uh unclear end game very unusual in-game
this this piece
um Dynamic and peace imbalance who would
you take here David actually
oh I would probably take white just
because I think that uh in Rooks versus
minor piece positions if black if the
side with minor pieces has no Rooks then
they struggle to contain all the files
also I like the fact that white can
create a passport on the king's side but
uh yeah I mean you could kind of toss a
coin here it looks very balanced
objectively and this is a very important
move dropping whites Rook back meanwhile
let's go back to the Magnus against
Jordan game because I think we're about
to see a handshake in that one you
mentioned it Lawrence pushing the Deep
one would signal the end of the game and
um yeah the material and balance in the
other one is fascinating we'll come back
to that one later it's sure to go on for
a while
um let's see the big result uh what
Again by Magnus this has been what a
performance and it was like someone said
in the feature chat earlier black has
not made any clear blunders no clear
mistakes just one or two small
inaccuracies and game over and we get
the results Jordan gives one check the
white king hides no more checks and game
over
yeah absolutely uh you know a very
disappointing result for Jordan van
Forest who had an exceptional opening
and he just went a bit Wayward basically
he just went a bit wrong if we go back
to uh you know if we look at what
happened in this opening here something
along these lines if we look uh after E5
especially I was looking at this
position David with you after 11 moves
saying wow what a what a fantastic spot
this is for Jordan better with black
after 11 moves uh even around here H5 I
liked trying to go H4 gaining some space
on the king side trying to weaken uh
this structure but then after C5 he went
Bishop E7 which is all right Rook C1 and
now I really disliked as did you this
move A4 I didn't think he needed to put
the pawn there I don't actually get the
move particularly
um and uh yeah after this
uh Knight C4 suddenly the tables
turned because our there might be six of
ideas are there suddenly pressure
against E5 is there and so on and uh
uh yeah and all of a sudden uh after
this it just went completely downhill
for
for Jordan van Forest Bishop E6 and now
Magnus just took the Knight and took a
pawn and said what's the big deal I'll
take a night take
nothing
yeah once you say a interest you've got
to say b as well and uh Jordan didn't do
that was duly punished meanwhile maybe
Lawrence we can keep up with game two
because we do have a couple of other
leaders who are battling it out uh on uh
board two
for the save against Eric icy we saw a
moment ago and uh that one fedisev is
the only player with winning chances
he's a pawn up as he aims to join Magnus
in the lead
do you feel he can convert this Knight
C6 does that not allow Knight C1 winning
the pawn back oh wow
maybe he wants to get active with rugby
stuff go active yeah
wow and uh every guys he doesn't allow
white to go after the F7 Pawn he just
attacks the White Knight on C6 does feel
like somehow the white B Pawn can't act
as a kind of distraction especially with
black Snipes So Far offside maybe Knight
back to E5 now feather save has just
moved his Knight is on that square and
Rook D7 monster threat would be a
winning threat if he can play it Flex
King in some trouble
oh this one yeah such high stakes now
Eric icy needs to hold this game a loss
and he's going to be thrown right back
into the pack
so feather save he's also got great end
game technique I've got to say I've been
ground down by him in many a Blitz game
can he finish this one off Knight C3 oh
what is the idea if yeah
and then just King F3 right
yeah and I don't see it maybe we can put
that variation or at least draw those
arrows on the board 77
three
but you're right I don't see
I don't see
okay this is on the okay it's not on the
board I was gonna say maybe black can
just play Knight takes F2 here and hope
that he's uh surviving uh but let's
catch up with the
yeah
horrible transition for black now the
king is open of what the white pieces
and Rook F6 this is a beautiful move now
you just mop up this is just a mop-up
job now for
um
for whites surely this is curtains for
irrigation
yeah if the Rooks ever come off the
board then White's b-pawn is going to
decide the game and I don't think you
can even get to that stage uh for Eric I
see you're dropping at least another
Pawn H6 is falling E6 is falling your
whole house is falling and uh Black's
Knight and Rook can't team up to form a
mating that's around the white king I
think that's what Eric is he was banking
on
okay he's grabbed the H pour now but
Black's Knight is really offside White's
King can jump into the center at some
point
I would be actually scared for the black
king maybe white gives a check I think
you were going to say uh suggest that
Lawrence and
rookie seven check suddenly stopped
marching the white king forward why not
rookie seven blacks King Retreats
White's King can come forward to E4 F5
G6
the uh the easiest path to Victory
instead of had to save pushes his b-pawn
also very logical
but uh can that black knight get back
into the game in time
looks like feather said is going to take
it we'll have two Leaders Lawrence if
that does happen
now I see absolutely zero chances here
for Eric AC zero practical chances the B
pawns to strong the king walks in for to
say of too good and feather save another
player I've mentioned this a few times
before where I I've commentated on his
games for years David and he's just one
guy I can't I can't guess his moves
hardly ever not at this point this is a
bit more straightforward but in general
a very very tough player to predict but
very very
um sort of uh underestimated quantity
when it comes to tolerance he can cause
upsets he can beat anybody on his day so
doesn't surprise me at all that he's
winning this particular game
um and
he will convert this no doubt about it
I'm just a tour of by the way
potentially doing very good also
against Manchester should we quickly go
there because I think this one is dead
in the water yeah I'll be brutally
honest
let's jump over to board three uh in the
background on the background of that
picture we did see napoleonishi and
Nihao sarin leave their table sarin
staying to uh pack other pieces we did
see a draw in on board four but uh I'm
just a tour of against Duda uh we see
the position in front of us and
wow the evaluation bar loves white is
there a tactic right now
can white just play C3
I mean that's about as simple as it gets
isn't it this is what we learn uh in our
first few months of playing chess
I don't I don't get it
ah Queensland HD3 c64 Queen takes D3
must be dude his idea and a bit of
instability in the center here so he
might get a few Pawns
but even and it wasn't played
it wasn't played
interesting missed opportunity I guess
it's hard to evaluate when when you give
up your all of your pawns for a piece
but
he normally thrives on those types of
imbalances
um dudo was taking big risks there
provoking his opponents and it should
have backfired on black now it looks
balanced again Lawrence unless I'm
mistake absolutely no Pawn breaks for
either side
looks completely balanced to me here
nightly four would you take
I think I would take white just because
the knights yeah
flexible yeah he can go rookie one or
Queenie one now I like just trying to
maybe put my queen on G3 and my knight
on F5 and pretend that I'm uh
threatening some mating stuff but yeah
the the white structure is such that
it's
it's very solid it does go Rook C1
King H7 by Duda Duda also down to 23
seconds so Judo struggling here for sure
uh what is abductor of Knight H4 that's
another thing I mean I've just said sort
of he's very carlson-like stylistically
in my opinion he he doesn't overly
complicate positions unnecessarily likes
to keep control
um
due to Hanging On
you're right and maybe that was a
practical decision earlier that kind of
simple fork with the pawn could have won
the Black Knight but maybe he had one
eye on the clock and he realized dude
was feeling uncomfortable with the
position so as you mentioned why not
keep control keep the tension your
opponent's likely to make mistakes later
anyway
um at least now there's minimal risk for
Abdul sotorov but oh look at the body
language as well Duda feeling really
uncomfortable he's like an eagle just uh
kind of hanging over his prey here wants
to get moving wants to kind of end the
tension end the drama but
I think he should avoid a night trade
right now
heat pieces on the board if you can
looks like he did move his Knight back
okay wow the board has just changed
completely wow it looks like a few moves
were played in the meantime and Chaos
again ensuing
well I mean why let's run a piece
white has one a piece
but can you keep that Knight on C4
intact it is pinned it is attacked by
Black's Pawn
it's maybe about that white E6 Pawn as
well
in an end game that will be decisive and
we see the players making some quick
moves wow okay the button things change
again white tonight has survived Black's
Queen gobbling up some pawns though with
a check the E6 Pawn drops what's the
count Lawrence it's a night for three
Pawns
that's another two points
now for one point now another one drops
yeah winning for white must be winning
right I mean
you've got an extra piece the king is
secure rookie three ba4 but all looks
rather hopeless here for Jan just off
dude and andu satorov David Hal I said
it at the start
yep I mean he's been there he's done it
he's won it he's young he's hungry
he is forced to be reckoned with and
yeah we're seeing rapid transitions of
this of this particular position uh
rookie one yeah this is classy stuff the
endings with this past a pawn here is
all hopeless
for uh
for uh for black you just put the Rook
behind the pawn and You Usher it you
could you could probably you don't want
to go rookie one here probably you just
find a good Square for this Knight
Knight F2 Knight
got to be careful not before Rook D4 you
might actually hang something because if
you then try and protect the C5 and all
of a sudden if that a pawn goes
the position is
tough
yeah position let's start I think he has
chosen a good safe Square for his Knight
and we will see Duda resign quite
shortly that white apron will be
unstoppable and uh you mentioned it
Lawrence before the show today also
remember Wonder gashimot Memorial which
was wrapping a blitz just last week with
five points ahead of the whole pack uh
he won it with five games to spare he's
a man on fire and that field was full of
giants like Mama jarov uh mamadov
reports shankland and uh yeah who's I
think he might be magnus's biggest
threat despite having already lost to
the Norwegian earlier at this tournament
now all white needs to do keep the
Knight safe protect the Knight and there
we go he plants the night on D1
beautiful beautiful move actually to
play uh to play 91 there
um and the a pawn is coming it's going
to be game over we'll see a handshake
any moment why tonight just needs to
reactivate and kick away that black Rook
the blockader
game over
indeed uh uh a very very uh nice win for
Abdul sirov The Rook passive dude are of
course shaking his hand it's shaking his
head rightly so because it's a gross
position yeah 93 now the night's coming
to C5 it's going to kick the Rook away
The Rook will go the form will come to
A6 you can even defend uh to A7 you can
then put the pawn on A6 Rook B1 Rook B7
then comes this is going to be a fairly
straightforward uh victory for uh
for add to settle off I have no doubt
he's just too good he's way up on the
clock
maybe not way up actually hold on you
can see to the
um maybe he's not not way up actually
yeah it looks like both sides are around
the 30 second Mark which is plenty of
time with a 10 second increment and uh
you're talking of Victories a moment ago
Lawrence fedexv did indeed wrap up that
win against eragisi huge for the
standings that means we have two leaders
after five uh sorry after six rounds
Magnus Carlson and Vladimir fedes those
two will fight off uh fight against each
other uh in round seven uh meanwhile a
few more draws as we go down the
leaderboard fascia de grav has drawn
Nakamura still in action oh no Nakamura
has just drawn as well so dropping easy
further down the table Nakamura failing
to keep interesting Magnus
um so yeah it does look like the leaders
are making themselves known Abdus is
going to be sitting half a point uh
behind Magnus and feder save after this
round
you would expect so I mean I would be
very very surprised to see a save here I
mean fair play to do that he is fighting
he's not he's not letting this one go
he's not he's not letting himself uh
lose easily here for sure
King F2 okay
it because the problem is if you take on
C7 let's say H4 by black the problem is
if you take on C7 King D6 suddenly the
tables have turned and you actually lose
you can't protect both pieces which is
uh nothing short of a disaster
for
for white so actually how do you win
this
it suddenly got very tricky Dave
but you're right I think he could have
uh maybe found a better Square for his
night a bit early I think he could have
landed on C6 with his Knight and put a
Pawn on A7 completely immobilizing that
black rook in the corner but uh despite
Black's passivity with that Rook stuck
blockading the y81 black's King is
active Black's pawns are rolling now F5
by Duda I think a very clever move had
to be played you're right Lawrence is no
longer a trivial matter it's no longer
so straightforward no matter where you
put your Rook now as white Black's King
will get some access to some squares if
the white Acorn Falls remember
blacks drawing chances increase
enormously so right now I'm struggling
to even see a move a productive move for
white G4 check is coming next Black's
pawns will continue rolling if you do
nothing
okay a waiting move from Andrew may be
quite clever maybe a clever waiting move
but uh he needs to do something now
drops back with the Knight but Black's
King just Retreats attacking the white
Rook
maybe his idea is to give up the white a
pawn but to get all of Black's pawns on
the king side he wants to leave himself
with a G Pawn
oh Rook H7 now potentially
can he get away with Pawn hunting
because black cannot take the white Pawn
oh he repeats the position Black's King
can go back now to the center that will
be the second time we've seen this
position Duda doesn't want to repeat he
wants to eliminate as many points as
possible
but now can white king not just sit and
blockade White's Rook is going to go
after this far Advanced black H Pawn
20 seconds what do you think still
winning but the margin for error
very slim now
on one more error uh one more slip up
and doodle will eliminate White's
remaining Pawn that would end in a draw
if White's Pawn drops off Rook at night
versus Rook as we saw uh yesterday is a
drop so I've just a tour of goes to the
pawn with his King
interesting he's within the square as we
say he's within the Box he's going
towards that H3 Pawn
you don't need something now he still
can't get through to that white knight
with his King he can't kick away the
defender of the white a pawn
talk of passive Kings this is the most
passive King you'll ever see on H1 now
but dude are still doing a good job
Lawrence yeah now you can go A7 for
example the bar is shot at exactly A7
now it's a totally different ball game
because all of a sudden uh The Rook is
kind of condemned to the back Rank and
after
what is this why so in the current
position King D6 was and Knight A6
that's the difference
that's the difference suddenly King D6
exists and Knight A6 Goodness Me
absolutely different now
the difference between having a
whiteboard and A7 compared to A6 has
changed the game Duda did not notice
that little nuance and yes that A6
Square as you're pointing out Loris is
now available to White's Knight to
defend its Rook that is a game changer
and now white can will uh at his own
Leisure just mop up those black Pawns
slowly marching the white king towards
the queen side it's a still takes a
while but
no more chances for Duda now all you
need to do shuffle your Rook across to
B7 threaten Rook B8 uh breaking the
black rocks connection with that white
Pawn look at duda's body language he's
looking away from the camera that is
Duda knowing he's losing
and uh he got there eventually Abdus but
um yeah he does take this essential win
uh or he will do in a moment there we go
rugby seven on the board by eight point
no stopping it
like tonight can land on the A6 just go
uh for that black Rook now
yeah still yeah absolutely
yeah winning forward absolutely
just winning
that's all there is to it it's just
winning nothing more to say Roxy so okay
a bit nervous here I've just had to off
no just yeah interestingly just a little
bit nervous can't find
the
the clean way Knight D7
uh King D6 Rook B7 and Rook B8
surely will
be the way here
he could also play Knight B8 if he wants
to make a new Queen block the eighth
rank but that would come at the cost of
White's Rook
um now the big question is what happens
if blackstroke goes back to the corner
and wow Knight B8 what a move Lawrence
stopping the black king from approaching
that is the most aesthetically pleasing
move I've seen all day so far Knight B8
that is totally changing for the Black
Brook
um that black Rook belongs in uh prison
now it's never gonna get out
and with that it's stunning isn't it
yeah I thought we were about to see the
handshake but no one more move from Duda
yeah it's nothing to be done White's
King is just gonna slowly advance
yeah yeah you're just really stuck
huffing and puffing as he does but now
you can just go for example you can just
hide the king king G2 King F I would put
the King on F1 to block the checks and
then you just go Knight C6 and Rook B8
even this of course is is more
insufficient
for uh I like victory
yeah I like that uh that phrase in the
feature chat a moment ago a smothered
rook and there we go dude does resign
important win there for Abdul sotarev
yeah a very very uh upset yeah he
understood that was an important game
actually because he needed to keep
tabs with the
uh with the leaders and he wasn't able
to and Abdul said turov
back to imagine a back-to-back winner
David that would be just exceptional
um I don't quite see it happening but uh
you never know stranger stranger things
have happened
um
he is Young he's obviously feeling good
why not and that pretty much brings us
towards the end of the round
no big matches going on perhaps a very
quick
well we're going to go to a break and
when we come back from the break we will
give you guys a recap of the major
results but it's been a very pleasant
day for the guys with the white pieces
at the top
um we'll be back in just a few minutes
for the second round of today
don't go anywhere
life is full of exciting events but it
is our first impressions that we
remember best your first diploma
your first job in a big company
forgettable emotions from the first date
the first expensive things you bought
when you got your first paycheck and
your first Investments with freedom
broker Freedom broker look at your
favorite brands from a new person
what is this this is duck chess you guys
this is a new variant it's called
Dutchess
how to play duck chest the duck is a
brick pieces cannot move through the
square occupied by the duck take on a
square to place the dog
oh he put the deck to prevent moves with
opponent not yourself
Yeah so basically you do this and this
cannot move I'm gonna go Knight F6 and
I'm gonna put the duck in the most
inconvenient place for my opponent to
move no Bishop no Queen so no londons
can permanently stop the London capture
the pawns King to win oh wow oh there's
no stalemates but still wait there is
still me but the still made the player
wins ooh if only that was real chess I
think I'm getting the hang of this game
I think I think I actually am getting
the hang of it
I think this works oh that's a horrible
blunder oh my God I just blundered I
have to move something else first then
dark and Knight will take my king this
is the best way to lose the dog chest
[Music]
there are some real bullet skills right
there boys this is the fast time winning
duck chest that That's so exciting
oh no no no no no no slip no no no no no
no
ah duck chess champion give me those
points baby
[Music]
all right
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
everybody and welcome back to day two of
the world rapid and Blitz championships
it's the rapid tournament that we're
covering today we will of course update
you on all of the results from previous
round that was round six but before we
do that a quick uh interlude a quick
interjection of course I want to remind
you guys about the chess.com awards for
2022 2022 has seen some incredible chess
and we are celebrating this year's
greatest games moves players at the
chess.com Awards and you can have your
own say by voting in categories like
Game of the Year Player of the Year
creator of the year and more type
exclamation exclamation mark Awards in
the chat to lock in your votes now make
sure you do that uh of course reward the
guys that you want to be rewarded
now of course back with David David we
saw a very interesting round there
especially in the open section it was a
successful round for the guys with the
white Pieces perhaps we can have a quick
recap of what the the major results from
the top boards
yep so uh we followed the open section
quite extensively in that last round we
saw a huge result on board one with
Magnus Carlson defeating uh Jordan van
Forrest on board two feder Sev took down
Arjun aragaisi to keep Pace with Magnus
in the lead and uh this final position
here that we're seeing in front of us
was the game between Abdul sotorov and
yang Kristoff Duda so some big results
big wins for those with the white pieces
as you mentioned Lawrence there were a
bunch of drawers we saw a really
fascinating draw between Newhouse sarin
and Jana ponyeshi but draws remember
don't really help that much in this
Swiss system it's all about winning it's
all about taking your chances you need
some Killer Instincts and yeah Lawrence
a lot of players they weren't able to uh
able to get those desired points we saw
Nakamura for example and vashilograph
two of the pre-tournament favorites
slipping even further behind the delete
yeah absolutely we saw uh you know
Hikaru drop uh even more points uh he's
really off the lead Fabiano caruana also
lost to Vincent Kmart I should point out
Vincent uh with the white pieces rated
only 25.90 according to Rapid ratings
but of course we know he's much stronger
than that as he's an over 2700 rated
player classically but that's a major
blow for Fabian
maybe we can see a game Lords yeah
that's one we weren't able to follow
um we do see in the shot there uh just
below our faces we do see the tournament
Hall what a shot that is what a venue
the players are at out there in almati
Kazakhstan almost 300 players I believe
in the tournament
um two-thirds of that is in the open
section uh 100 players also in the
women's section and this was the final
position Laura it's a very um well-known
technical end game Rook and pawn versus
Bishop it's actually a bit tricky
sometimes to win Rook uh and Paul vs
Bishop if it's a Rooks Pawn but uh
kaimer finished it off maybe we can go
back a little bit just to see how he
managed to break through
yeah perhaps around this moment here
because it's a very long game but uh if
we take the position after move 51 it's
one of those typical positions where
Fabiano looking to make a draw here with
the bishop he's got uh an extra Pawn
trying to set up a fortress but seems as
though kaima was able to to do it and
Fabi actually got him what looks like a
favorable trade here to make the double
H Pawns in this position and the bishop
also restricting this King coming in I
would actually say just optically here
this feels as though this should be a
position that Fabi kind of should hold
David I don't know if I'm being out of
line here am I because this looks like a
really favorable position but we can see
Kmart managed to finally get in maybe
some inaccuracies there by Fabi and H5
we can see the bar go up this looks like
it was a critical moment here maybe Fabi
had to find something slightly different
in this particular position because
after Bishop F2 H5 was a brutal shot the
bishop has got no checks and if you take
the pawn Rook G8 is mate this is
probably the big mistake by Fabi here is
Bishop F2 moving after that Kamer was
able to just win a bunch of Pawns and
once all the pawns come off the board it
really is
a hopeless uh spot for
Fabi so interesting stuff there just
flicking through the rest rest of the
results as well a lot of drawers this
round uh but of course Fair to save
beating Arjun Abdus beating dude a
massive win and Carlson beating van
Forest uh uh were the major ones for
sure
what about the women's section David
yeah I was about to uh about to mention
Lawrence the women's section we saw some
dramatic results again at the top of the
table
um before round five we did know that
there was only one leader Valentina
gunina but she was taken down by tanzong
Yi we followed a bit of that game we saw
the moment this hands on you won a piece
as black and she was able to convert uh
very smoothly
um also Alina Danielle Danielle uh took
down hampi canero one of the top seeds
so uh she's joining the lead we also
have Leila garafolina in the lead after
that important win we saw her have a
huge attack earlier against mamazada and
uh she got the point too so now three
co-leaders after five rounds and we do
see a bunch of players in the chasing
pack
um this is the top 10 on the leaderboard
right now
um some big names still don't rule out
goyatzikina from putting a run together
one of the top seeds one of the best
women players in the world abdomalik a
local fan favorite from Kazakhstan it's
been a while now since she's won one of
these big tournaments could this be a
big breakthrough for her in her home
country
um Lawrence some yeah some really
important results in that last round
yeah massive I'm a huge fan of gen sire
Abdul Malik I managed to uh get to know
her a bit from the Gibraltar tournaments
extremely talented player also has I
think moved into a bit of politics
actually locally in Kazakhstan has got
her own chess Academy there is a massive
figure in the Chess World uh jansaya is
on a four game win streak after losing
the first surprisingly to munzel she has
come back quite considerably winning
four on the bounce and has white against
Leia garafulina and even though Leia is
extremely talented zhansai in this form
you would expect her to actually be huge
favored and
as you also mentioned Elena Danielle and
so experienced
playing Black against tanjong the awful
pairing in my opinion for Elena I think
tan is the sort of play that Elena
doesn't enjoy playing very precise very
good calculator
um so tanjonggi really in in a great
spot as well but of course very very
bunched at the top you've got some other
top players of course Valentino gunin as
we just saw lost the tangible machines
really and let's not forget uh Alexandre
goliachkin objectively the strongest
player in the field
um especially if you think about
classical chess she is there as is Bella
conson Australian Daria void so very
very bunched at the top in the women's
section as well
yeah and I think the reason that uh
round seven has been delayed that there
are no pairings yet is because there's
still one game going on uh in the one
section and wow look at this who have we
got here
um I think we'll try to get the names up
in a moment I'm not familiar I must say
with the young uh player with the white
pieces uh with black I think it's a
Grandmaster from Kosovo but he has just
Blended look at this along the longer oh
wow
skew it the king suddenly white is two
pawns up and
wow this is going to be a winning end
game for white heartbreak for black who
was winning just a few moves ago uh I
believe and wow what a long game this
has been a marathon over 80 minutes now
they've been playing and uh I think
we're going to go quite a lot longer two
pawns up for weight
um the rest of the players in the
tournament will be waiting for this uh
this game to finish wow suddenly there's
a few checks though White Queen is
powerless in the corner uh from
defending her King can white Escape I
ruled this one out I said it was going
to be a win for white but maybe I was
wrong Lawrence we do see that this is a
game between beg moratov and uh sarachi
sarachi from Kosovo and I think a local
local Junior here with the white pieces
yeah it looks well be a miracle safe for
black
yeah it looks like a local local player
Queen D2
might be a draw I don't see a way to
avoid the checks King A3 Queen A5 check
King B1 Queen D3 check does look like a
draw to me David what do you think
yeah I suddenly there's no way to avoid
the checks I think I got over excited
because this was such a dramatic moment
that we joined the game in uh but now in
no way simply for white to avoid the
checks and I'm not sure if it's possible
or to go back to that moment with the
skewer on the long diagonal yeah let's
quickly a few moves before we join the
game because we saw the stare and sir
how many queens are on the board now
black had two queens in the two corners
and
unfortunately just walked into this uh
diagonal look at that move oh look at
this look oh my goodness what a move
one concept yeah he just had to move the
king actually right A Move Like King to
B7 and he was probably still
probably still winning but uh wow he
gave up the queen in order to then be
able to deliver the skewer
and yeah and the game had ended in a
draw wow
what a fight by the youngster there
uh to find that resource a draw
is the result
fantastic stuff
yeah and there we see the arena with
many players loitering around waiting
for their parents to be announced uh
those might still take a few minutes now
we do have the final result
of the round we see some local
Spectators sitting there uh in the
auditorium we see some photographers
Leonard utas in the foreground
um yeah I mean imagine the tension in
that building right now the players it
is the start of the day it's only been
one round but things will only get more
intense as the game stick on
indeed and we're going to be back in
just a couple of minutes for the next
round uh where we'll go over the
pairings and everything else so don't go
anywhere we'll be right back
chess kit is fun Jess is great for the
brain but it's also fun to play and
chess kid makes it easy to have fun
whether your child is a total beginner
or a prodigy they can hop on and find a
well-matched opponent from around the
world at any time chess kid is the safe
parent-approved way for your child to
play chess online
chess kid is educational
to kids it feels just like playing but
chess is a great way to learn patience
strategy and critical thinking chess kit
features a comprehensive training
program that guides kids to level up on
their way to Mastery there are more than
50 000 chest muscles and a whole library
of entertaining videos that teach
strategies tactics openings and end
games specifically for kids
chess kit is easy whether you're a
parent helping your child a coach
managing dozens of kids or a school of
hundreds signing up is free and easy so
what are you waiting for
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
hello everybody and welcome back this is
the coverage here on just a common
feeding World rapid and Village
championships it's the rapid tournament
a two we'll just see the first round of
the day and you can see there also an
overview of the playing or lovely and
spacious just how you like it nothing
worse than having a guy next to you
elbow you in the face mid Blitz or mid
racket so well done on the organizers in
Kazakhstan for finding this wonderful
venue for this very very important
tournament I'm an international Master
launcher and joined by the one and only
gold Olympic gold medalist multi-time
British champion and a good friend like
David Howe David
um it was a good start to the day wasn't
it for a lot of players especially at
the top
yeah especially the players who started
with the white pieces earlier in the
open section in round six and uh yeah I
mean what a start it's been to the rapid
event in general and it's already
heating up we do see many players
lagging behind as you mentioned earlier
Carlson and had to save r at the top of
the leaderboard right now and maybe
Lawrence we can see where some of the
players such as Hikaru Nakamura went
wrong earlier he's now one and a half
points behind the lead I believe and uh
yeah he needs to pick up pace and uh
Hikaru did let another half Point slip
he did allow a draw in the last game but
Lawrence if we can fast forward to
perhaps move
32-33 of that game and then yeah I mean
it is rapid chess we do see mistakes
they are natural but uh Hikaru here will
be furious himself for letting this
chance slip Hikaru had white in this
position and now after pushing his
opponent forward to D7 uh Queen A8 was a
nasty trick
trying to play against the white bishop
and the pin on the second round but I do
believe Queen D5 was where Nakamura let
the point slip just blocking the
diagonal with Rook D5 and I think hikara
would have been a huge favorite to win
this position the white d-pawn almost
Unstoppable long term it will cost black
his Bishop uh White will have ideas such
as Queen C4 Queen C8 at some point and I
think Hikaru would have taken this home
to Victory but yeah just one slip is all
it takes in Rapid chess and instead
Queen D5
getting the Queens off the board wasn't
sufficient for the win because suddenly
after a queen exchange I think Hikaru
had underestimated that uh Queen takes
D5 uh takes and uh Bishop d8 in that
position it would eventually end up in
uh I don't say color Bishop end game
with no winning chances black is simply
playing King f8 King E7 that white
d-pawn nowhere near as powerful as it
previously was and white king also
caught on the side of the board
this one did add in a draw yeah
and Hikaru not even able to really
defend that pawn both pawns hanging and
once that pawn left it was really gonna
be only one result so disappointing
vehicle in akamura obviously a lot of
Hikaru fans
he still wants to win these
championships I believe he has not yet
won a World rapid oblitz you can correct
me if I'm wrong there David but I think
we spoke about that yesterday
um yeah Hikaru surprisingly never won it
uh he hasn't lost yet but dropping four
draws
he's already as you said a point and a
half off the pace where Magnus Carlson
and Vladimir fell to save for the sake
of having a great tournament so far and
Magnus Carlson uh doing what Magnus does
and if Magnus starts to get some
separation from the field it's going to
be really tough because he is
just awesome when he's in flow but let's
not count out the rest of the field
especially in order back Abdu sets are
off impressing me massively yes he did
lose to Magnus yesterday but he's
bounced back in great style beating
sanal who's a great player from Turkey
great uh Turkish Grandmaster and having
just beaten yanchished off dude a
massive win for him so I'm curious what
the pairings are going to be
um we will see them don't also count out
the group on four and a half one point
back is still it you can still very much
make a comeback there are
goodness how many more rounds left
um
seven or eight right exactly yeah not
even at the halfway point yet in the
tournament after this next game we will
pass that point
um so yeah it's all about going on a
streak all about racking up those
victories uh often all you need is one
good day or one good end of the day you
could LeapFrog a whole bunch of players
on Surface four groups and uh here we do
see the rest of the top 20 uh some big
names of ushi we look further down
namajaro Duda or Tamia still uh chasing
still aiming to put those wins together
is just it's such small margins at this
top level
yeah and
um let's take a look at another game
while we do wait for those pairings to
come out
um
I would say that one game that interests
me is is that of Mahmoud of duboff
um these two guys very entertaining
players once again uh sort of position
here where if we take it after move 34
this is white should be okay especially
with this pin uh being able to pin the
road but after Rook C2 perhaps mamanov
forgot that now not only are you
attacking the bishop but now the move
Knight takes before next we'll be able
to unpin yourself but is the bishop
actually hanging good question
well after kimchi won there was a
repetition and finally Knight takes
before
white is able to win the pawn back with
rugby eight but is he because Knight D3
actually hits the bishop and no you're
not because black is able to save the
pawn and once you save that pawn
it really is the end of the game that
pawn is way too strong
um you just literally March it
down the board
sometimes chess is not too complex you
just find a way to March your horns down
the board
Daniel safeguarding his King
finally bringing it in H4 check and
actually using his King this is a great
demonstration of the importance of an
active King in an end game now King to
F4 beautiful stuff Rook takes F6 and
King E3 and the King can be used Shield
use uses the white pawns The Shield
itself now the threat is just to go King
F1
and that's what happened in Roots HD2
check and Knight F2 will be made
great stuff by Daniel duboff who also
can't be ruled out
and it does look like we finally have
the parents Lawrence uh around uh six uh
is round seven how's my counting around
seven I believe about to come up uh
feather save on board one gets the white
pieces against Magnus Carlson so that's
two whites in a row for feathersev he
really needs to pounce on that
opportunity uh this is going to be
potentially a tournament deciding game
for both of them on board two you end up
only actually gets an up float uh he's
on four and a half points he plays Abdul
sotorov on five so he will also want to
make use of those white pieces to take
down his younger rival remember last
year in the world rapid Championship
Abdul sotorov beating upon Nishi in the
playoff for the title so revenge on his
mind as well meanwhile followed on
mertzin the youngster the teenager up
against manager of on board three some
other big big parents you Yang Yi
against Vincent kaimer if we look
slightly further down Eric icy against
Gary huge match there there's some
history between those two as well and
also notice sneaking into the top 10
boards for the first time Hans Neiman
he's playing Black against Richard
Rapport huge game there Neiman now
putting together a bit of a winning
streak and on board 10. Nakamura needs
to start winning he's black against the
Boris savchenko
indeed and just a quick one about the
women's as well tanjongji playing
against Elena Daniella and that was
obvious that those two had to play Abdul
Malik White against garifalina we also
spoke about that uh big big spot there
for Abdul Malik Butch really needs to
hold against
a win and suddenly she could start
making a move so we will of course keep
an eye on those top boards as well
the games will be kicking off in just a
moment I guess well we have to do
predictions don't we uh David what do we
think of this next round let's start
with ball one feather save Carlson
what do you think
well that one uh is gonna be close
Magnus did not fed us air out of the
World Cup last year he has a very good
score against felicev in general doing
also well against him in the world
Fisher random Championship so Magnus
will start as the favorite often uh if
you have kind of faced an opponent if
they do prove to be a nemesis for you it
will be hard to fight back so I do
believe Magnus is going to take that
despite the fact he's got the black
pieces the stakes are high and who's
better in those situations than Magnus
Carlson I'm going to say bought two
Lawrence I have a feeling upon me
actually has a score to settle how about
you do you think you'll get revenge for
last year's playoffs
yeah I I I I feel like it's going to be
a decisive result that's for sure I I
remember seeing after sator of also do
quite well against the punishi in the uh
in the online events
um so nepo definitely likes to push it
when playing against Abdul satorov
it's going to be a very interesting
match regardless uh I do like napometry
here though today I do I think he can
smell that he can get really in touch
with the leaders I have to also say this
I think uh fedesave is not going to lose
against Magnus Carlsen this round I've
got a sneaky suspicion I feel as I've
had a save as an awkward opponent for
maintenance I actually remember talking
to Magnus at the Warsaw uh World rapid
and Blitz last year and we were speaking
about feder save and he also told me
that he finds him to be a very tricky
very difficult player to play massively
underrated but ward 3 is a very
interesting pairing to me volodar merzin
the young Russian
Superstar I mean he's basically been
pegged as you know you know somebody who
could make it he's he's he's only 16 or
17 I believe
um he's rated about 25.50 which isn't
the sort of Superstar level that we've
been uh used to uh from the Russian
system you know we've when we've when
we've seen the top 15 or 16 year olds
they've often been already 26 50 2700
plus but there's something about this
guy that has impressed me I remember
seeing him for the first time years and
years ago at the Gibraltar open when he
was only rated about 2200 but he was
dusting and beating up on IMS and GM's
then and it was clear that he had
something special doesn't surprise me at
all that in this format he's doing very
well I think he's got a good opponent
Mama jar of course a uh fantastic
seasoned Pro
but Mamet is gonna risk it and this
could be a spot for mersin actually this
could be a moment where we see like we
saw Abdu satorov last year are we going
to see volodar merzin make an incredible
Dark Horse Run we'll find out after this
game yuyangi kaima is going to be a
relatively chilled Affair I think
dubov's sarin is an interesting game as
is Eric acquiri uh by the way so and
Rapport Neiman
um could also get excite lots of
interesting parents this round as we see
the players slowly enter playing Hall
getting ready
to do business you can see there Vincent
Kmart
always looking professional so mature
David mature Beyond his years I remember
seeing him at the grenka tournament when
he had his breakout win
um about four years ago now when he won
the open section to be able to then play
the master section which has Carlson
carawana and the like
um
does he
have the goods to
go beyond where he's at in your opinion
David is he or is he just
where do you think he is in in terms of
his
uh you know his level and where he could
Peak
yeah uh you mentioned Vincent kaimer
he's uh I think that was six years ago
Lawrence he had that breakout time does
fly
um where he was 12 years old he won a
really strong open tournament and
yeah I think he's going to go far he's
already
2700 he's just left school so finally he
can focus fully on chess
is going to be at the top for many years
to come I mean while we're doing C in
front of us Alexandra goliatricina
another very young strong player from
Russia
I'm about to cough so maybe you can take
the word Lawrence but yeah I'll take it
their chances I do yeah well I mean look
Alexander
has been a sensation it's uh one of one
of the players that I don't know as well
I've not really got to meet her I know
her opponent very well uh Nino who has
been actually uh was uh on the bus with
her most days last year going to this
tournament because you had to get a bus
to the uh to the stadium and Nina was uh
on the same floor as me so we would we
would often get the bus
extremely talented player Nino I feel as
though she's very underrated at the
moment I feel like she could be a stable
2500 plus player
um if she gets a few more things right
does a little bit of work but she's
definitely an underdog even with the
white pieces against
is just such an incredible Talent she
got over 2600 feed a classical uh which
already is putting you in a very special
group I would say probably
definitely less than 10 female players I
would say at all time have gone over
2600 so she already belongs to a very
special group she's just very very tough
if she's good in opening she's good in
all areas she's a universal player for
me oh yeah actually not Nina is going to
have to produce something very nice
today
um but she does have the white pieces
and
she's got the experience and she often
has when when she's in form she's
another in many ways a momentum player
because I remember times again thinking
about the Isle of man's ornaments where
she played tremendous chess
um so she's more than capable very
curious to see how that goes but on
paper I would say oh you're actually in
a still a big favorite even with the
black pieces but we'll be keeping an eye
on everything
yeah
I was going to say the tournament Hall
it looked like so much movement players
running around all over the place but
still so many empty boards where are
they
why hasn't the round started and uh that
we see a close-up I think in the
foreground we see adiban uh sitting
waiting for his opponent very famous
Indian player the Beast as they call him
uh famous for various openings such as
1v3 we sell knee house sarin just walk
past there they are all looking for
their boards it's often a maze right
these tournaments Hall these tournament
Halls
often difficult to find your board
because there are so many 300
competitors and uh okay I think we will
be ready to get going in a moment
photographer lenat in the foreground too
Arbiters running around it's uh it's
often chaos until the game starts and
then it becomes very tranquil very
peaceful uh at least for the first few
moves until we do reach the end of the
opening and meanwhile some handshakes
you can see it plays just relaxing in
their different ways running through
opening lines in their head
as uh Yogi does say in the feature chat
the free day rating in that room is
unreal uh very high v-day average maybe
one of the highest I thought such a
such a tournament there's literally no
tail in this tournament there's no uh
kind of lower rated players
um it's really the elite flocking to
Kazakhstan at this time of year fighting
for those titles fighting for those huge
prize funds and here we see fedisev also
fighting uh for gold ideally I remember
in 2017 I think he got a silver medal in
either the world Rapid or the world
Blitz in Saudi Arabia he was so close I
think he just missed out on some tie
breaks uh in that event you will want to
go one better but the only way to do
that is to go through the big guys go
through the likes of Magnus Carlson and
that is easier said than done and as
usual Magnus is one of the later players
to arrive
and when he does arrive I think that
will signal at the beginning of the
roundoff also waiting for his opponent
napoleonishi
and uh yeah some huge matchups will try
to follow all of them
of course but so much action Lawrence
yeah pretty much action every round
yeah tons of action I I I love this
tournament it's one of my favorites of
the year because you get so many
interesting matchups uh you get to see
how the younger guys are doing as well
for example as Rory said volleyball
Mills in on board three uh we've got a
bunch of top Indian Uzbek players as
well up there of course so
it's great to see if we can see record
there the Kurt Cobain of chess
but gonna stick around a lot longer uh
we are seeing there well for the Savers
yet
to
uh play a move he's waiting in um very
gentlemanly fashion he could
theoretically start the clock but these
guys have got immense respect for each
other they're going to wait and there is
Magnus now arriving the clock has
started I expect 1v4 from feder Save
which has been his main weapon for years
and let's see what opening Magnus goes
with is he gonna play G6 again try
something funky I say no I say against
fair to say if you play something
actually a bit more classical
and we'll see in a moment what Magnus
decides to go with taking off the uh
badge
and
he did
he did play The King's Indian I believe
Magnus against fedesev to beat him as
black in the World Cup in uh 2021 and
okay it's not the uh it's not the king's
Indian this time it is the Boko Indian
wow Bishop B4 check
we don't normally see Magnus employ this
variation
it's very flexible black tries to get
some pieces off the boat off the board
early often black will end up slightly
cramped so why not exchange pieces first
it helps you with any space disadvantage
later and
it causes FedEx to think at this early
stage surprise Factor important here
Lawrence
hmm I I wouldn't call this a surprising
opening exactly for the save just
deciding which system to go with I'm
curious
yeah he does go for the critical
variation which is the block with the
Knight and then try and get the bishop
pair after Knight D2 castles are now
most likely A3
played and Magnus goes Bishop to E7 and
now white does have the option of
getting the big sense with E4 this is
not obligatory but
to save principal player does Play the
movie four and now Magnus most likely
will play D6 yes uh this has been played
also a fair amount uh at some point
black is going to try and get in the
move Pawn to E5 to challenge in the
center and to make sure that White's
pieces are certainly the Bishops at
least are hemmed in slightly
um
but you know white has got the center at
the moment how bad can it be do you know
much about the theory of this opening
David
um I must say no I don't know too much
here but uh
oh can you hear me Lawrence
um sorry give me one second
oops
okay I'm back sorry about that Lawrence
uh there you are sorry yeah
yeah I don't know too much about the
opening Theory here although I am
familiar with this exact position it's a
favorite of uh players such as Luke
McShane I think gattacamski has played
this before it tends to be a favorite of
players who try to avoid opening Theory
and uh Magnus of course uh he's played
everything under the sun he's played
every opening uh imaginable and uh I
think his idea is again as it has been
throughout the tournament just to take
the opponent into unknown Waters and uh
we do see in the future chat Carlson
child end game grind maybe that's the
strategy but we are far from the end
game now I think the idea is to just
give the opponent as many options as
possible but to save after a bit of
thought besides the castle uh maybe we
can show in that position Lawrence that
white could have tried to win upon but
uh it would have backfired after capture
here and black has several moves I
believe but uh yeah Knight G4 if I
remember is
um I think there are options in that
position but often if white has to play
or move such as Knight takes G4 Queen
takes D3 then black gets at least full
compensation for the sacrifice Pawn
White's Army is in disarray and white
struggles to Castle
so if we go back to the game a couple of
exchanges and Magnus drops his Knight
back so this it looks odd on the face of
things to move a development piece when
so many other pieces are asleep at home
but you do free up the F6 Square for
your Bishop
you do get ready to jump around to C5
with your knight and the other Knight is
planning to land
out on C6 so uh yeah I think Magnus well
he's definitely studied this one before
but his idea is that it will present new
problems for feder save that perhaps he
hasn't faced in the past and the more I
think about it the more I do recall
Magnus having experimented with the BOGO
Indian on the Champions chess tour in
recent months it's not his main opening
it's far from it but uh it is something
that he's had reasonable success with so
fed a safe now has to decide what to do
with his Knight on D4 that's attacked
I'm guessing he'll defend it with his
other night the night on D2 for white
very clumsy that piece locking in the
White Queen blocking in the white dark
Square Bishop so I'm expecting Knight on
D2
to F3 and uh yeah white has that moroxy
maroxy bind Pawn structure with pawns on
e4 C4 clamping down preventing any black
pawn breaks but black is happy to play
with pieces
rather than Pawns in this position it's
really interesting strategy for Magnus
it's not what you see every day and uh
you have chess winter in the future chat
leading me to it it is a maroxy bind uh
in a way this structure and still lots
of tension notice this is one thing uh
this kind of the ingredient for success
for Magnus yes he loves engine grains
but in this tournament he's been keeping
pieces on the board he's been making a
complex that's how he beat Jordan that's
how he beats uh Andrew sotorov and uh
these younger players fetishev not that
much younger a couple of years younger
than Magnus but uh yeah these younger
players
they have struggled against the strategy
so far
completely agree and and that's one of
the things he's so masterful at isn't it
he's just I don't know how but just
managing to keep the chances alive
knowing when to trade knowing when to
bail out all of these things that that
really you you get to learn from
watching Sunday like Magnus it's quite
incredible
um and we see the the move Knight 2 to
F3 as you were talking about David
protecting the Knight
um and now Magnus has got to decide is
he going to play rookie 8 Knight C5
Knight C6 A5 there are
there are a few moves here he could even
play a move like H6 and dare I say
although that looks a little bit slow to
me I'm gonna go with rookie 8. as the
move tell me that I'm wrong
I think you've got inside magnus's head
uh here at Lawrence he does love his
flexibility after all and there we go we
see his hand move out to his rook and
rookie eight you predicted it and yeah
that's why we talk about chest Styles
right and uh kind of preferences and uh
just thinking processes if you get
inside your opponent's brain if we we
know Magnus we've watched him more than
uh most people and uh yeah he does love
to stay flexible not commit not give the
opponent easy moves for example if black
had moved one of his Knights maybe white
would have had ways to swap off pieces
or attack the Black Knights uh for
example if Knight to C6 why could for
example take that or it should be three
defend the night and at least there's
one easy move for white not sure what
next
is
when I see five had come instead then B4
it gives the opponent obvious replies so
why not just improve a piece and stay
flexible I love it
um and it's also very difficult to play
against her magnus's style
absolutely it is indeed rookie 8 Bishop
V3 plays uh Magnus will have to get some
of these pieces out
at some point
uh the question is when of course uh is
he going to do that that part is not so
clear
uh just looking around the other games
as well Mercy mamajarov is
very very unusual I I kind of want to go
there somehow
um
if I may
uh let me just get that up because that
is a very unusual opening
uh and I'm trying to locate the game uh
with me
we had a four nights David
which is a very standard opening D4 and
now pretty much 90 of the time you see
the move e takes D4 Knight takes D4 and
now the move Bishop before the absolute
main line of this open Scorch four night
Scotch but instead after D4 manager of
plays what I I believe is his his kind
of his his home
or his own line Bishop B4 I vaguely
remember seeing him play this
pinning the night before taking and
motion just says okay d597 and now I'm
going to take your Pawn on E5 now
I don't know if this is right but mommy
driver spent something like
six minutes on this move why is he
thinking so hard about Knight takes E4
that's my question what is it about this
move that is bothering him
it's got to be cringey for Lawrence
we have multiple different attacks
um quenchy for it it's also a variation
uh kind of sub variation of this line as
you mentioned Bishop before is rare but
it has to be considered in this position
I'm not sure whether it's strong or not
for example Knight takes C3 uh Black
Knight is under attack after all white
could flick in either quintix B4 or even
Queen takes G7 6 G7 and it gets this is
amazing
attacking the rook in the corner
threatening Checkmate on F7 black has
all sorts of night jumps uh that black
knight can move out the way with a
discover check all black can just simply
play Rook f8 and uh ask white the
question what are you doing next here I
believe the move would be something like
A3 A3 yeah it's just crazy
um I mean the computer seems to be
favoring black now Bishop H6 would be
strong for white oh wow yeah Checkmate
um yeah and suddenly I think Checkmate
is almost Unstoppable but uh this is the
kind of chaos
mind he doesn't want to allow that and
therefore he goes away from the
principled variation of taking his Pawn
back he's allowing uh mertzin to keep
the pawn temporarily he didn't want to
go for this chaos it would be his style
I should say mama joke but it's always
scary going for such uh such a mad
position against a young player so he
plays D6 instead and this does ask a
question of Martin does he Retreat the
knight in which case black will win back
the pawn on e4 anyway what does white
continue in the same vein and play
Bishop B5 check in which case who knows
what's happening does black have to move
his King displace his kingdom lose
custom right so does he continue
sacrificing like C6 for example uh
instead blocking
with the check
goodness it takes complete access King's
side oh my God
this is an absolute mess isn't it
yeah classic Mama giraffe
absolutely we love him Lawrence it is
why we love him and we should keep her
not keep an eye on that but uh I do
believe we should go back to the Carlson
note I am keeping an eye on the other
game so we did see after rookie 8 Bishop
E3 the Knight did finally come out to C6
like so
uh it was captured and Rook to B1
getting out the way protecting the B2
pawn and on C5 okay uh just B4 and after
C takes B4
pause Now by
fed to save which is extremely unusual
why is he not
taking back
on B4 immediately here
that is a good question
maybe you can tell me David
I mean it's uh bemusing right because
taking back this Pawn with the white
Rook would leave white with two isolated
pawns the white a pawn the white C Pawn
they're currently isolated
I mean all human logic tells you uh all
kind of Chess wisdom tells you that you
should be capturing with pawns towards
the center but why pause now feather
save also look at the clock he's
significantly behind he's four minutes
down on the clock so why not play the
most logical move the most natural move
does he want something more ambitious
perhaps
there we go wow
I was about to suggest this it looks a
bit strange the queen will get hit the
queen will get kicked around potentially
later but for now she does attack this
black rook in the corner is he trying to
trap this black Lawrence and if Rook B8
what's his idea here
I said Bishop takes A7
trying to trap this Rook because it
takes a seven Bishop B7
and then Queen
Queen B5
and if C6 Queen takes people but this
the engine doesn't like it is there some
Bishop takes E4 Bishop takes C2 here
I think you're right Lawrence
giving up some material temporarily but
it's a pseudo sacrifice where you only
uh give up a little bit but you're gonna
get back more later I think you're right
Bishop takes E4 there's also ideas of
Pawn takes A3 that's gonna create a
monster pass Pawn in some variations
I don't understand why you would
calculate this when you had a very
healthy option
um so strange but it's so typically fair
to say if you know everybody and their
grandmother would play 8xp4 almost
immediately here but Queen D5 there's
something about it I don't like there is
something about it I don't like but I
can't the the the the engine bar is not
hating it
the engine bar is not hating it at least
but even still
this is
surprising stuff
I think the reason the
reason the computer might not hate it
for white is because after the BlackRock
shuffles across the B8 uh yeah it isn't
necessarily obliged to go for that
variation why doesn't you need to try
and catch the Rook just take back now
but uh we're so surprised I mean fair to
say if he's bound to uh continue making
us guess is is he going to go back to
sensible Earth chess after all of that
is he going to take this Pawn maybe
although it looks odd to allow Bishop B7
with tempo
there should be seven Queen F5
she's six questions Queen everywhere
four or something it looks totally weird
but maybe it's okay but I don't
understand why you would kind of
uh allow this really it's it's very
bizarre to me very very bizarre
that being said as Mr volcker does say
in the future chat it's a nice try
you've got to come up with something a
bit special against Magnus you can't
just play the obvious moves you you'll
never beat him that way and that's right
true I mean Magnus when we do see him
lose which is rarely uh it is because
the opponent catches him off guard takes
him out of his comfort zone and like
this doesn't look too happy with his
body language as he does play Rook B8
only safe Square for his Rook
and uh okay this is the key moment if
fedes goes back to normal chess and
captures on B4 we think he's doing well
or at least okay and uh if he continues
trying to harass this black Rook then it
will backfire on white
so okay Moment of Truth feather save
looks away I think he's fighting his
inner demons he's fighting the
temptation to play Bishop takes A7
and uh will he Embrace that chaos will
he play he surely Rook takes before is
just not possible here right
this move is just not possible Right
This is just too disgusting for Words
surely
I mean at the very least black complain
might be six and hit the White Queen I
don't really want to go for more
exchanges and allow white to re-correct
his Pawn structure
yeah
it's so ugly
exactly I like the creativity but yeah
the structure this kind of long-term
consequences of White's play
there are question marks against it and
uh fed a save
let's keep on him let's keep the camera
on him as we uh wait for this moment
will he take huge risks to try and
fluster Magnus
you just take the pawn back I think I
would just play a takes B4 Lawrence just
take that pawn yeah and and that's
what's happened
yeah but I can't help but feel with the
queen on D5 that this this just doesn't
I mean Bishop B7 Queen F5 G6 Queen F4 is
this
is this really what's going on here I
it's again this is just guessing
you know feather saves moves is is my
hardest job as a commentator because I
don't understand the benefit of doing
when he uh in this position you could
just go a before maybe he was just
concerned that Bishop B7 and this was
just very unpleasant to deal with maybe
this was the issue
yep maybe maybe like his options I guess
in the way he has played in the game he
will gain a Tempo because
Black's A7 Pawn is always up for grabs
it's always on priest and yeah you're
right Lawrence you predicted it the
White Queen has ended up on F5 I mean
small threat
yeah what else were you supposed to do
ultimately yeah it's all very
is hinting at E5 I was about to say a
small threat but uh E5 here a clearance
sacrifice trying to hit the H7 Pawn
using White's Bishop on C2 and queen
that would be met by G6 so
um maybe that's in the air maybe not
either way I have a feeling Magnus will
play G6 he loves that move in general
just loves that pawn structure uh in
front of his King the wall of Pawns on
light squares supplemented by a dark
Square Bishop but
yeah you've got to say it's weird chess
but it's not necessarily bad chess and
Bishop takes F7 as we mentioned another
uh idea that Magnus has to guard against
Magnus doesn't really want to waste a
move
kind of pushing his a pawn to A6 he
doesn't want to take a time out because
that will give white time to activate
his remaining pieces
still looks in the balance to me I've
got to say
agreed
and uh meanwhile as Magnus Ponders how
to try and punish feathersev for this
queen sortie okay he plays Knight E5 I
was going to say how about action in the
other games or Lawrence we have to go
Daniel dubov against nihal sarin all
right let's go straight there
oh my goodness
what Goodness Me
wow and I do both so dangerous isn't he
look at this Rook on each got a roaming
Rook on H4
I mean
this is incredible Queen C7 and sarin
just said I don't care I'm gonna Castle
I don't care that you've got a rook on
H4 and a bishop lining up who cares I
don't
that's like walking into a burning
building Lawrence and hustling when your
opponents of rookers on H4
wow you wouldn't you wouldn't you would
not get me castling in that position I
tell you that Bishop C3 now both Bishops
lined up
sarin said okay I've got to try to
hold it G6 now the Knight came into play
brilliant
yeah big threats on the 192 D5
and look at this the Knight runs away
from the defense of the king
and all of a sudden
it feels as though I mean if this were a
game of Julian Hodgins for example you
would just think okay Jules is going to
find a way yes there's a pin here so you
can't take on H7 yes he's trying to and
bang just like Queen H5 I mean the
pleasure in playing this move is just
immense point of course being that be
quick the queen it is a queen sacrifice
theoretically because after G6 H5 but
it's made in one and if you come back
with the Knight to F6 you can just lock
it off Bishop takes F6 same idea
if this happens you go Bishop takes H7
and that's it there's actually just no
reasonable way to continue here
right there's just no reasonable way to
continue this position
that's a once in a lifetime type of move
Lawrence and what satisfaction duboff
will have had playing it we've got to
say disappointing for me how sarin um
not his finest moment castling in that
position against a fearsome attacker
like dubov but Queen H5 move for the
tournament so far yeah
for dubov and uh Lawrence maybe we can
go to
um reports game report against Hans
Neiman looks like some big developments
in that one Hans Neiman okay with black
he won the first game today and he's
winning again hands hands winning it
looks as though let's have a think the
the bar at least is saying that this is
pretty much all she wrote
for Richard rapport's I mean B3 do you
even have to be precise here
uh perhaps not right I mean why can't I
just take this Pawn off I don't
understand because there is some back
rank
threats here
what what am I missing David
I don't think you're missing anything
Lawrence I think you can take that pawn
maybe the safest move would be such
something like Queen F7 uh just to
defend the black knight uh I think the
idea is to Checkmate white on the back
rank white knight doesn't have too many
squares to go to and uh for example if
white white snake is attacked if it
tries to retreat to E2 he does go back
to F7 uh I love this move I've got to
say and if the white knight drops back
to E2 then there's gonna be killer blows
like uh H3 for example Bishop
maybe you give a check first on F1 uh
maybe checking on F1 is actually the
most precise way to do this you mean you
mean before H3 just here yeah Queen F1
yeah sure Queen A2 H3 double pin or
crash the crunchy
that's brutal
and he's gonna that is going to be all
she wrote isn't it really to be honest
that is going to be too brutal
and I mean Neiman he's uh he struggled
yesterday we've got to say he drew
several games against players 200 300
points below him but uh he won the first
game of the day he won that well he's
about to win now and that's what you
need to do no matter how poor the start
you need to get on a streak and he is
racing up the table
yeah
that's not an easy game either now I'm
going to ask you a question which is
going to be my only sort of
controversial question to you you know
Magnus extremely well
um has Magnus told you personally if he
does Play Hands given the history
what's gonna happen
when okay we are we are going to move on
from that one ignore everything I said
yeah I think that's uh that's a topic
that uh we'll approach yes and uh it
becomes relevant if and when okay
in the meantime that's good potentially
a great win by Neiman he's about to pick
up the White Knight you've got to be
slightly careful there's a Checkmate
threat on the board Queen takes G7 uh is
a threat for white but after this very
precise move order like giving a check
forcing White's Bishop passive now the
night falls and black is a night up also
with a devastating attack incoming this
one is in its final throws now this game
G2 is the target long term for black
slice Square bishop and I think we'll
see report throwing the towel I think he
will see him resign at any moment now
there we go it's a handshake Neiman
takes a huge victory
massive massive massive Victory there
for hands
Neiman putting him in the mix
and with some of the top games still
going on of course
uh he'll be looking on but uh certainly
Hans
credit where credit's due when you beat
rapport with black it's a big result
let's go back to Carlson against uh for
to save against Carlson I should say
um
what's going on here this looks
relatively
stable I would say slightly better for
white although black has got great peace
activity
so
I don't know David what do you think who
who who do you like here
yeah
um I slightly prefer black as you
mentioned the peace activity blacks
Bishops look very potent Black's Rook is
about to enter potentially the second
rank Black's Queen on an open file that
being said white does have and if
symbolically the better Pawn structure
of Black's d-pawn is isolated maybe a
target for White's record Bishops long
term but yeah I think objectively it is
roughly level it's just about whether
the Magnus effect comes into play we've
seen it occur several times already this
tournament Magnus just eking out these
tiny advantages or just one minute
little flip from the opponent and uh he
jumps on the chance and okay the White
Queen has been forced to a passive
Square are there some pins are there
some skewers Bishop B5 here by black is
met quite nicely buy it white playing
rugby one for example
yeah yeah B1 some tactics here maybe
with rookie one it gets a bit
complicated for a moment but
um I do think the White's doing okay
okay here kind of skew it is met by a
pin if for example black plays Rook A2
in the current position then white
solves oh sorry uh going back a couple
of moves in the current position I
picked up on yeah
oh actually okay he played Queen E8
Magnus attacking the E4 Pawn I was about
to say Rook a two is met well by Queen
C4 and White's always unpinning white is
never really in any uh permanent danger
here it's always temporary these little
tactics uh but Magnus goes
okay
well uh
is that possible
I mean you're about to ask the question
who would I take I would say say both
sides have reasonable chances if there's
nothing Concrete in this exact position
but Bishop takes E4
does grab a pawn is it playable
if so it looks dodgy right
it's a bishop B6 but rookie five comes
yeah
get away
he's definitely considering Magnus he's
got seven minutes against three
so will he grab a pawn meanwhile um this
game still very tense it feels like it
should fizzle out the white e-pawn will
drop the black d-pawn will drop we
should get a very balanced end game
um there's drama all around the place
Lawrence
um yeah long way to go in this Magnus
game looks like abdusa toroff
is doing very well he's just kind of uh
tricked janapomyoshi I think on board
two and uh abdusator of if he takes a
win there again against napoleonishi
that could be dramatic I mean what a
winning streak he's on abducator off
right now wow look at this his last move
Rook A8 trapping this white Bishop if
the bishop drops back to B6 the only
safe Square then Rook takes B6 oh wow
ATX B6 Rook A1 check
what a trick skewer and goodness me win
a piece you emerge with an extra Knight
and after Bishop B6 Rook takes B6 it's
very important that any checks for
example Rook D1 check it's met by Rook
D6 and you save The Rook
he's one of his winning material Abdus
the toroff
maybe he's doing incredible stuff
it looks like it doesn't it uh I don't
see do you see a way out here I mean I'm
looking I'm staring at this position the
bishop is attacked
I would love to see I mean you had an
apology just almost swearing at himself
if you look at the video feed here uh
nepo of course got uh he he's got a bit
of uh uh history getting his Bishop
trapped as we know from the world
championship match as well and he's
literally uttering
sort of obscenities at himself you can
see they're very very disappointed in
after saturov not taking his foot off
the gas
still being very composed but
yeah the punishing
desperately unhappy with how things are
going
and rightly so
Lawrence you mentioned history repeating
yourself not only against Magnus in the
2021 world championship did he get a
bishop trapped but yesterday he got a
bishop trapped in one of the early
rounds and he managed to fight back he
managed to save that but he's going to
need an even bigger Miracle against
Abdul satoruv who isn't well known for
his Killer Instinct and for really
precise uh technique in winning
positions I was going to suggest maybe
if I could give up his Rook Rook takes
F5 give back the exchange just to get
the bishop out but okay he plays that
move he gives up his Rook for that black
knight but where is the bishop coming
out to
the bishop still can't sit on B6 that
same tactic exists and there we go uh
black has just won a rook for Knight if
we count the pawns it's level pawns as
well
it's a mopping up job it should be
winning for black if white can take the
H4 Pawn with his Bishop next move if he
can kind of get the white Rook active
somehow they're saving chances but
yeah
he's praying right now that abdusator
slips up and abusator of not letting up
the pace this is really clever Lawrence
Rook D2 it looks like this loses to a
skewer or loses some material back
Bishop E1 but then simply Rook D1 and
another pin Saves the Day White's Bishop
can go and take the black Rook on A5 but
your own Rook drops he just solves
everything with tactics it's so
impressive abduce the Tariff right now
incredible
yeah drama everywhere we've got to say
um we will go back to Magnus shortly but
maybe we can check in on Arjun eragisi
against Anish giri it looks like Gary in
huge trouble there talking of Trapped
Bishops look at Black's Bishop on H3 the
white Queen's about to swoop back to H4
and trap it
here it's also a pawn down as black with
a weak King
looking like disaster for the Dutchman
and uh hey he tries to block the white
Queen's path back to H4
how is Eric Garcia gonna put the
finishing touches to this one white king
is also not entirely safe so maybe some
counter play what do you think Lawrence
he should wrap this up well I was
thinking can you play Bishop takes D5
allowing Bishop takes G4 Queen G8 check
King H6 Queen fa check Force the king
out but I wasn't entirely sure well
maybe King G5 the bar hated that okay so
maybe the move King H5
I mean optically it looks well this king
is on H5 but white has got some problems
with the back rank
so for example
you could try F3 here but maybe this is
just all unnecessary stuff feels a bit
doesn't feel clean it doesn't feel like
the sort of thing irrigation would want
to play unless he's forced to maybe a
move like Queen D6 to come back this way
does that make any sense
I love that one keeping control it's
nice to kind of keep keep some pressure
on Black's Rook as well because if
Black's Rook didn't need to be defended
black would have ideas like Queen D2
trying to go for the back rank trying to
distract White's Rook but yeah
unfortunately Black's Rook is under Fire
Queen G3 is a monster threat I think you
found the smoothest uh path to Victory
there Lawrence and uh I Regice he has a
lot of time he has almost four minutes
of clock advantage and a pawn advantage
and he's trapping this black Bishop
yeah the only way to break this bishop
out of jail out of prison is to play a
move like H5 and that's ugly
um after Pawn takes Pawn yeah you're
simply two pawns down now White Queen is
coming back anyway to G3 as you
highlight there
looks like every guy see is going to
beat Gary
big big problems and on board one has
actually kind of gone the way I expected
uh in many ways uh fair to save Carlson
well
if you're not getting mated along the
back
doesn't look like you are and you're
going to make a draw here as Vladimir
fell to save
which I think is an okay result for for
both of them actually but after off if
he manages to convert this winning
advantage against neponishi will be
joining them
but Lawrence
um you mentioned first day of making a
draw why would fetusaev try and make a
draw he's a pawn up
white has grabbed a Pawn on H I didn't
even I didn't I didn't even I I was
looking just ah this is a draw you're
right he is a porn-up rook A1 and I
guess Rook D1 is forced and played and
you're right fedesafe is a pawn up let's
stay here this is a critical moment it
would be good always count the pieces
uh ladies and gents
um
deal feel like Max is going to make a
draw somehow because it's so typical
Magnus but
hold on takes takes in G3 and oh sorry
Queen E5 check that was clever so Magnus
believes that even with the same color
Bishops three versus two should be a
draw
but is it so easy
it's funny Lawrence um I in the summer I
filmed a chessable course with Magnus on
uh grinding out advantages we also
filmed a chapter on defending uh
difficult end games and there was one
example he showed me it was a game of
his against Maxi vashilograph and we
were talking about what you should aim
for when you were Pawn down and he said
one of the easiest end games to hold
when you were Pawn down is uh same
colored Bishops with pawns on the same
side and there we discussed four versus
three three versus two he said basically
because you have same color Bishops your
king can sit on the opposite color
complex so for example Black's King will
sit on the H7 square and white can never
break through on the light squares so I
wouldn't be surprised if at some point
uh Magnus okay now plays F5 and blocking
on the light squares he's gonna plant
his King on H7 blocking White's only
possible winning idea uh the H Pawn and
yeah there's simply going to be no
breakthrough now just the bishop check
on d8 very important check
yeah stopping White's King coming in
and there we go
yeah I think there's other ways maybe
you can sit with the King on F7 even
just because White's King is trapped in
front of its own past Pawn but there we
go King H7 block on the on the light
squares and no way through and yeah it
was really fascinating to me listening
to Magnus there describe exactly what
he's aiming for when he's already in a
disadvantage and there we go it's
another case of that uh unfortunately
White's Bishop can't Journey too far
away from its F Pawn because it will be
tied down to its defense later
I think this one is headed towards the
draw no progress to be made
for example if white tries Bishop F2
maybe we can just drive One Direction
too yeah if Magnus just Waits it should
be E7 for example uh Bishop H4 and I
think black can simply Play Bishop D6
with the idea that King King G5 is
always with a check
and white has to go back
and if Bishop G5
then I think black can continue waiting
just Bishop C7 for example and
the only way to go forward is to go back
white will have to bring the king the
whole way around but I don't think
you're ever going to make progress there
you probably will do this I mean there's
no reason why
he won't try this it will end in a draw
I'm pretty sure but
um
he he has no there's no reason why he
wouldn't give this a try at least
psychologically it's quite nice having a
position against Magnus knowing you
can't lose not many people get that uh
get that joy in life uh so for the save
we'll play on a little bit
and uh yeah this is a really poignant uh
comment from devian Meister in the uh
feature chat fedes
all these players they're so underrated
uh they're so dangerous on their day
they can beat anyone and uh they're
proving it today to the Front Runners
abdusatorov still the favorite against
the ponyeshi in that battle had to say I
mean well trying to find some progress
against Magnus but still the white king
is cut off it's caught in a box on the
edge of the board
and uh likely we will see a draw
uh look at Magnus as well kind of
looking anywhere apart from the board
he's Restless he wants to get this game
done he wants the handshake
and a draw with black not the worst
result for him he'll still share the
lead
well not at all and
uh
he will share the lead now I think we
should stay then with napomnishi against
Abdul satorov
kanyan Magic
something
from this position a
very tough position indeed
um
his body language says no Lawrence he
was shaking his head yet again there we
see fiddling with a piece
top place in the world are great at
twiddling those pieces uh Boris gelfand
notable I think he would be the world
champion at uh filling with those pieces
but hey Black's King is caught in the
center maybe yeah crossing the crossfire
in some variations there we go a check
but it does look like Black's F Pawn is
going to decide this game
Flex F1 will like to cost white a bishop
or Rook most likely and there we go a
result feathersev gives up his winning
chances he could have played on for
longer but he does admit that white
couldn't break through and we saw Magnus
react there really nice to see the
players analyze with each other Magnus
maybe missed something just by judging
by the opening of his mouth and a bit of
laughter
yeah I think a balanced game in general
draw a fair result
agreed
so is abdisaturov going to join the
leaders he's got to be precise we know
how tricky uh
you know uh Napoli can be very
resourceful
let's see
yeah does black just push the porn
Lawrence does black just give up his B
Pawn white can go and take it but it
will cost a couple of moves it's uh it's
not easy in Practical terms do you keep
your pawns maybe at the cost of a bit of
time do you just Bank everything on your
passport
uh naughty back likes to I mean he
prefers in general going for switching
uh yeah he gives a check he doesn't want
to take too much risk you mentioned this
earlier he likes to keep control
and uh how do you keep control in this
position not 100 easy
six
or just B6 I think he pushes his Pawn I
think it's B6 yeah I I was gonna say
that looks like the natural move to me
just to
um just to keep the pawn
and now it's about marching that F Pawn
down the board
if you can start rolling this guy it's
coming there's not much you can do
yeah Black's King will be safe on any
light Square essentially a really nice
hiding place for the king if the checks
continue the black king will March down
for example E2 maybe F1 and uh no more
tracks we'll spell the end
for an apology okay he's going for
counter play this is what the top
players are so good at finding ideas to
trouble the opponent King A4 coming King
B5 coming as uh as was said in the
future chat there by only Weston yeah
you can see Napoli actually holding this
it's possible
maybe giving up the white Bishop for
Black's f porn later but only after
creating some counter play with White
Queen side Pawns
what would you say are the percentage
chances of saving this one
um
slim Slim
ten percent one in ten maybe no maybe
that's a bit too slim maybe 20 something
like this
yeah that's still a chance though that's
still something to play for you have to
go King A4 yeah I feel you have to go
King A4 of course
yeah create Council Place there we go
yeah in B5 coming white will create a
past Pawn of his own don't rule out in a
Punisher yet
I've made that mistake many times in my
career rooting out the punishi and he
comes back and he's got great Killer
Instinct as well and uh okay Rook F1
yep feel so difficult the clock
situation as pointed out by the higher
space uh in the future chat it's also
terminal not in the Publisher's favor
so quick so confident for such a young
player
he's just amazing he he always impresses
me he's so mature Beyond his ears it's
quite incredible actually
to have won this already last year to
have won the Olympiad to get to what
it's it's it's truly spectacular
and okay no problem she's going to put
up a fight here it's it's still
a little awkward
yeah
yeah when I played in the world rapid
and Blitz last year
um I finished a game I think I had lost
that game and I came out in some uh
interviewer tried to grab me and they
were like oh Mr Abdul satorov well done
on your win so that was probably the
highlight of my career being uh confused
for this fantastic player this fantastic
youngster meanwhile Napoleon is he
setting some traps Rook D2 track is
coming yeah exactly Rook D2 check he's
so true
but then again is it such a big deal
maybe it is
maybe this is not what you want at all
not totally clear to me
yeah I mean there's still questions to
answer as black ideally I mean maybe a
move such as rookie one check just to uh
Force the white king away so that the
black king could grab the B3 pawn and
then just move the Rook behind or
something like this yeah although the
Rooks are on the same diagonal now
you've got to be slightly oh you've got
to be careful yeah it's a sort of sort
of exactly you can flood you could
really walk into isn't it haha yeah
unfortunately white can't use the C3
Square this is exactly what a doosatora
has gone for as well so uh we're doing a
good job with predictions
and Napoleon actually has to try some
checks here he has to make the black
king sit on an awkward square but I
don't see how you can
how you can trick the opponent Rook D2
check played can black not safely too
let's keep let's keep up with the
gainers
yeah let's keep up with the game
like has won a pawn now exchange and a
pawn up White's Rook is hit so there's
no time for Bishop C3
yeah it looks like great technique yet
again after this story of his tournament
one loss to Magnus but the rest just
perfect chess Flawless chess
um meanwhile a lot of results coming in
a lot of drawers around the top
uh we saw Eric icy play earlier he did
win against Anish Geary
so Nakamura he Nakamura Drew again will
again later goodness
struggling Nakamura really five draws
now from seven games
wow yeah you don't win this tournament
by making draws that's for sure
and this game has been important
yeah Roxy Rooks Rook D2 King C1 now what
what swindling opportunities exist here
I'm very curious
I believe
just Rook B1
I love that move
that's a great move
all row component games are now winning
for black because Black's Rook is behind
the last Pawn that S Pawn is going to be
a killer so Rook B1 black could even be
threatening to take White's Bishop in
some variations and uh then just slowly
Match the black king across to E1 and
That's All She Wrote Rook B1 now yeah
that's really nice
yeah Rook F1 just the black king runs
away on the light squares travels away
to safety
okay fantastic stuff
final moments yeah I mean just we've got
to press up this guitar off every time I
see him he gets better and better
and uh what a year it's been you
mentioned earlier Lawrence the chess.com
Player of the Year Awards he got my vote
just for me
what an achievement
no question at all
yeah it looks like a movie yeah
love it absolutely love this move
brilliant move
um should point out just having a look
at the women's section as well Abdul
Malik did beat uh Gary frullina that
means that her charge she's now won the
last five in a row tanjongji only Drew
with Elena Daniella
um but see it's really Drew against
goliachkin as well which is a very
decent result indeed
um and
we also have gruninas still playing
looks like she's in big trouble though
against Bella hunting really
so we'll take a look at that big result
there actually because stenyuk losing
with the white pieces against gong
that's a massive result for gong beating
uh castinia with black uh after
Christian such a great event last year
um
Tanya
we I have to interrupt we do see a
handshake uh Abdus has taken the win the
premiere resigns after a difficult game
we saw the blunder the bishop getting
trapped and that was decisive
uh what a game and huge for the
tournament standings I've used the tour
of joins the lead yet again
yeah just uh just a phenomenal player
isn't he just
to be this young and this talented it's
it's quite exceptional uh and joins the
leaders as you said uh he is up there
uh should we have a look at some of the
immersion did draw against
mamajarov
by the way in that uh crazy looking game
great result from uh dubov we've already
seen has beaten nihal sarin Arjun we
already saw has beaten uh
Anish giri
so Arjun also irrigation keeping pace
for sure with the guys Duda beat Mata
rosian you already mentioned Nakamura
not being able to beat sevchenko MBL
also playing his countrymen and good
friend Sebastian Marseille unable to win
that particular game with black and
grishek also not being able to beat
predka so there are all of these really
solid decent Grand Masters that you're
just not able to beat a lot of the time
and that's the reality
um for a lot of these players they are
just very very strong
and Lawrence there are still a few games
going on yeah Boards of the open section
maybe we can jump into one of them
um Jordan van Forrest right now is
trying to beat timogarev it's Rook
versus knight the chances are very slim
um this end game is quite an elementary
draw
and timoggrave known as the blindfold
King I think he once played 48 games
blindfolded while riding a exercise bike
um he's gonna know how to draw this one
right very well yeah educated player
very classical
um he's gonna hold this one against
Jordan I don't think Jordan will try it
for too much longer essentially you used
to have to give to give checks anytime
the kings are opposite each other and uh
you gain a bit of time to run away with
your own King on the defending side and
this one should be a draw
there's also on board four you Yang Yi
against Vincent kaimer we mentioned
Vincent uh just before the round started
how mature he is now he's 18 he's
focusing fully on chess he's just
finished school
um he's destined for the top great coach
in Peter lekko he's trying to grind this
one out
um this is going to be a long long
battle you can play 100 moves here as
black but should probably be a draw hard
to create a past pawn and uh what do you
think here any winning chances at all
I think so
um even though it's three versus two and
objectively I think it should be a draw
it's one of those ones where in Blitz I
think it's quite difficult to defend
with white because of the two weaknesses
you have to get this King active maybe
you want to go
I don't know exactly the way you want to
go here but something like
well if I can somehow manufacture
getting my king active here with black
but the more I look at it the more
difficult I see we're just going to stay
with it for the moment
because I think it's quite interesting
to stay with
yeah
um
there are ideas of making progress
Black's F Pawn could push forward
creating a nice hiding place for the
black king behind it on F5 you've got to
be careful which order you push your
black pawns forward in you don't want to
allow too many Pawn exchanges unless you
create a password
um yeah I mean it just looks like a
difficult game in Practical terms as you
say uh yeah and you Yankee though very
fast I played them many times in Rapid
classical
it's very hard to beat him rookie eight
good move he's going to start checking
from behind
you could also consider pushing Black's
E Pawn forward uh Vincent does go for
this now Black's King has created a path
for itself through to the exactly Square
Lex King will try and hide behind its
own pawns the question then is what next
which is also a difficult one to answer
yuengi cutting across that plan stopping
the black king moving into the center of
the board
yeah I mean this one I wouldn't be
surprised if it hits the 100 move Mark
we're already at move 71 uh whoops sorry
looking at the wrong game we're already
uh deep into this game anyway and yeah
Vincent he's gonna try it there will be
ideas along the second rank of uh if
black gets there Rook a two pushing the
pawn to E3 later
still some pitfalls to avoid
yeah again this is the type of position
that's maybe in Practical terms 50 of
the time you win 50 50 of the time it
will be a draw but you never stop trying
as black especially as we mentioned wins
are such a high currency here
um in this tournament you need them in
order to have any chance of fighting for
medals you have to take any half chance
you get and this is a half chance at
best for Vincent but he'll try until
there's no more uh there are no more
plans for black
yes he absolutely needs to play this
position on until the end because
there's no
there's no additional benefit in making
a draw here
or agreeing to a draw even if it is a
draw I'm not even sure like if I go King
E5 now what does he want to do King G I
didn't even get this move what what's
the idea if I go King E5
I think he's just going to continue
waiting with this Rook I think he ran
out of waiting ideas
um he's going to allow the black king to
F4 most likely where it looks nice and
pretty but it does get in the way of
Black's pawns right he's basically
saying it doesn't do anything
yeah Vincent does put his King on F4 I
believe hiding from the checks and now
you young he's just gonna wait he's just
gonna move his Rook to the side he's
gonna bring it back most likely at some
point and
still far far from a winning plan for
Vincent but yeah yuyangi is not going to
be enjoying this this is pure suffering
and uh it's just about knuckling down
the top players are good at this however
they're good at suffering if they see
light at the end of the tunnel if they
can eventually get that Half Point
or K8
could be here for hours Lawrence okay
well we're gonna keep an eye on on that
one
um and what we're going to do is we're
going to go slightly down the list here
to board number 50.
uh where we've got some cameras as well
which is fantastic
and that is the game aravind against
ilgen I believe and we have this
position here
this is just a draw uh
I mean this is a drawing in every sense
of the world here because of course
um even if the poem were gone it would
be a draw so I don't quite know what
aravind is doing this is actually a
non-interesting position the bishop
stays on this diagonal and
it can be agreed to draw so
we could keep an eye on this although as
I say not a particularly interesting
position from a purely chess perspective
now this is not the first time Lawrence
that we've seen aravind play on a dead
drawn position if we saw one of those
yesterday as well
our event I mean he's battling he's
hoping that eventually he can check away
the black king the white king can
advance gobble up the black porn and
like you say Rook versus Bishop is a
dead draw anyway but at least there's
some traps to avoid in that one uh
unfortunately
for white the black Bishop does keep a
steady eye on this long diagonal and uh
yeah I've played uh bilgun the player
with black oh right okay
from Mongolia and uh yeah he I think he
beat me a few years back in Gibraltar
after also he was suffering the entire
game suffering similarating into this
one and but there we go finally a
handshake white gives up his Rook for
the porn num checkmating material left
and uh finally a peace treaty signed
so it might be back to board four in
that case not many games remaining in
this round one almost an empty playing
hole as we see there
exactly
Ward six oh rather Ball Four uh
he's making progress Lawrence the black
king has advanced the black pawns are
moving forward could Vince and kymer
grind this one out the black king does
have somewhere to hide as well normally
the idea to draw this is to give checks
from the side
Rook A3 check is met by the black king
continuing its journey into E2 and
another check is met by Rook ditu
suddenly black is winning
against Hawaii
ah you can't afford to trade rucks ever
so there's a clear path through
Vincent yeah how many problems this does
look difficult for Vincent no question
about it sorry uh for you young you Rook
A2 played but the bar shoots down
is it just E3 is is it as simple as just
going E3
the bar says no
unless you're 100 sure it's better to
keep flexibility maybe Rook C5 just
giving the king some Shield uh some
shelter the black Rook now can block any
checks
yeah I think that's kind of endgame 101
just don't commit unless you're 100 sure
E3 maybe was strong but
um why allow that as we go through the
early moves of the game Lawrence oh
what's going on here we go to it's open
let's get back to the current let's go
back to the current position yep
Rook A3 check blade
and a block
now the black king is getting ready to
enter
whites Rook goes after the black G Pawn
but that g Pawn isn't really relevant
I think the black king can continue its
journey in
maybe you give a check with the black F
Pawn as well
this feels like it's balancing on the
edge for white now Black's pawns are so
close to promotion Rook C2 threatening
E3 uh I think is what Vincent has chosen
there we go that F Pawn is pinned how
can white save today how can I saved the
game I don't think he can anymore
any Rook check is met by the black king
coming into E2
an even better Square for the king
Lawrence
you mentioned that this was tough in
Practical terms he went down to a couple
of seconds there I think he's just
failed to prevent all of Black's plans
from coming together all at once
and now very straightforward it seems uh
after the white Rook moves up the board
surely black can just play either E3 or
F3 here
uh maybe E3 is the best way to start and
uh
yeah if the port is captured now
yeah E3 looks killer F3 check and you
run through and force a new Queen
and that really is All She Wrote there's
there's nothing really much more to
discuss
uh
agreed that is that is game set and
match so
and yeah and 4k1 F3 yeah
killing the game there what a win and
he's a rare exception of a youngster
who's so talented at endgames because
he's had this great chess education
under the tutor literature of peterlekho
yep important win on board four with
black Vincent Comer arising through the
ranks
quite incredible isn't it uh Vincent
also keeping Pace with the leaders
massive massive win for Vincent with the
black pieces beating you Yang Yi and
what that means is after round seven we
have Magnus Carlson Vladimir fedes and
now nordia Roth the reigning rapid
champion
all on six out of seven
and in uh joint fifth on five and a half
Vincent came as we've just seen with
that wonderful result beating you Yang
Yi Arjun irrigation with a great win
against Anish giri and Daniel dubov with
that miniature against nihal sarin they
are all
just half the point behind and then of
course we have a big bunch of players uh
just uh uh there on uh five out of seven
and um yes
oh sorry I was about to say this might
be a good time for a break as the
players uh refresh themselves as we wait
for the parents to come up it's been a
really dramatic first couple of rounds
uh of the day so join us again in a few
minutes see you soon
life is full of exciting events but it
is our first impressions that we
remember best your first diploma
your first job in a big company
edible emotions from the first date the
first expensive things you bought when
you got your first paycheck and your
first Investments with freedom broker
Freedom broker look at your favorite
brands from A New Perspective
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
everybody and welcome back to coverage
of the world rapid and glitch
championships here on chess.com day two
of the world rapid championships things
are getting interesting and tight at the
top we're going to go over the results
of the previous round in just a moment
before we go there though
you can see a live shot of the camera
hole I beg your button of the playing
hole the camera of the playing hole
there we go uh lots of space lots of
people
um commenting on just how good the
conditions are over in Kazakhstan almati
um this is uh a place that I've never
been uh looks like a fantastic
playing haul though
and players are enjoying their
experience we will of course uh take you
through the major events of today so far
before we do that though a quick message
do make sure that you check out the
official chess.com Discord server it has
been revamped it has a fresh new look
lots of new features and plenty more go
to
go.chess.com
Discord and make sure to connect your
chess.com account to earn unique Flair
use exclamation mark Discord in the chat
for more information
all right David uh we saw in that last
round
uh we well actually results kind of went
as as I thought they would to a certain
extent
um Magnus unable to be photo served with
black and some important wins for the
youngsters
yeah you're completely right Lawrence uh
feather save more than holding his own
against Carlson had Carlton on the Rope
slightly it did result in a draw
eventually and other than that the main
story is the rise of those youngsters as
you mentioned we see the top 10 of the
leaderboard in front of us right now
abdusatorov still a teenager still only
18 here now now has joined the lead
remember still the reigning world rapid
Champion arjunari guysi also important
Daniel duboff maybe not a youngster but
uh still young hungry and very dangerous
player playing maybe the move of the day
Queen H5 against Nihao sarin there in a
very important Victory Vincent kaimer
Jordan vanfurist vladislava TMF and look
at 10th Place volodar mertzin someone
you pegged Lawrence as uh potentially a
surprise package a dark horse off the
tournament he's still up there only one
point behind the leaders in joint
seventh place and uh here we see the
rest of the top 20.
still no Alexander grishop some Giants
of the game instead we have surprise
packages for example kuparate in 11th
place here
and a lot of players tied on Five Points
Hans Neiman remember with a very
important win with black against Richard
report for the first time he's making
his mark on this event and uh yeah as we
see some players needing to play catch
up Niha sarin anajiri yuyangi all after
tough defeats in the past round
absolutely and uh we'll say that uh well
we can uh we can see uh
uh Carlson versus on top in the open
section in the women's section
we had uh an important round as well
tanjong ji not able to beat Alina uh
Daniella meaning
that uh it allowed some of the other top
players to catch up namely Abdul Malik
The Local Hero jansaya beating Leia
garifrulina meaning that she's won five
on the bounce after a tough first round
loss
all of a sudden jansaya is in the lead
as is
with a massive win
against Valentina gunina and I fear now
for Valentino I told you yeah I think
earlier today David I believe Valentina
is a momentum player she's just lost two
in a row
she's the sort that can win
eight in a row and then lose five in a
row or something along those lines so
I'm a little bit fearful for Valentina I
hope she managed to stabilize also a
massive result in that last round for
the uh
uh the the Singaporean player gong
who beat Alexandra castenia with the
black pieces which is never an easy task
uh
oh sorry carry on tell me I was just
going to say Tanya with a massive win as
well beating zagnitzel with the black
pieces massive result for her
and uh meanwhile we will check in on the
standings the uh pairings of the women's
section in a moment but the parents for
the open section have just been released
a huge match yet again on board one look
at this Magnus Carson against Daniel
duboff duboff with an upflute Magnus is
one of the leaders uh of course one of
the joint leaders but he's fixed on
board one uh due to Norwegian television
um one of uh rights there uh so Magnus
Carlson playing yet another one of his
seconds we saw him start the day against
the Jordan van for East someone he's
worked with in the past now Daniel dubov
another close friend can he take him
down another former world record
Champion remember on board two it's
Abdul satorf against fedes uh two joint
leaders both there very uncompromising
they will be going all out to beat each
other to put themselves in Prime
position as we head towards the last
rounds of the day Vincent kaimer and
Eric icy on board three off to Great
starts of the day of course with some
great wins there and a huge pack on Five
Points just towards the bottom of the
top 10 boards we do see Hikaru Nakamura
he still has a chance it's not too late
but he needs to go on that streak he
needs to rack up the wins we are now
beyond the halfway mark it's 13 Rounds
this is now round eight so Nakamura time
is running out for him he's one and a
half points behind the lead
this is his chance
absolutely uh
it is and uh
wow uh still tons of Chess to be played
what a what a match up though Carlson
uh against dubov on board one massive
massive massive uh match up dubov cable
of beating Magnus Again part of the
Magnus Carlson team they know each other
extremely well on his day do both with
white or black capable of beating
anybody but you know he's got a he's got
an interesting pairing here because
Magnus will push and the satorov also
I think this is a great spot for him
White against fair to save even though
feather save has been good so far he can
be a little bit erratic sometimes I
quite like abdisator off here with the
white pieces and Kmart against irigosi
um uh well maybe Arjun fancies this
actually with black thinking this is
actually an interesting spot to try and
get back and then of course a bunch of
players on five as you mentioned so
really curious how the top three boards
pan out
in the uh women's section yeah okay tell
me David sorry Lawrence uh speaking of
some of those names maybe we can analyze
some of the games uh before we get into
the women's pairings I think there's uh
one of the games there went very long so
we're still waiting uh on those parents
in the women's section but maybe we can
analyze some of the games off the top
players we saw uh kind of snapshots we
saw highlights uh from those top few
boards but how did those top players win
for example uh Eric I see how did he
finish it off against Anisha giri uh we
saw he had a very promising position
look at this black king caught in no
man's land on F5 we left it around here
a bit earlier we said why does it pawn
up that black Bishop is trapped
but uh let's see the final stages he did
indeed yeah it actually it actually did
he he did go down the line that I
thought he inserted F3 first and then
gave this check gave this check
and then this check here
and all of a sudden I see why
uh probably actually after Queen f8
black had to play King H5 but maybe the
position was already
toast because white can just take on F6
probably doesn't matter around here so
Queen G5 so King G5 F4 check and now
it's just over if King H4 Queen comes to
H6
um if the King goes to H5 the bishop can
come to
F3 and then the Rook can come to D5
winning a queen
so yeah the position is just with this
King already in the middle of the board
it's over and actually after King F5
Queen H6 black resigned because White's
got a cute little E4 Checkmate uh idea
that is pretty much Unstoppable or
you're losing the bishop with Queen sex
H3 Checkmate two different checkmates
brutal loss for for Anish
um
very very tough tough pill to swallow
there
I Regice he seems to have anisha's
number he's beating him several times
throughout the meltwater Champions chest
tour this season and uh yeah Arjun as is
being said there in the feature chat by
Corey Lou Arjun is a beast Arjun has had
one of the breakout years of 2022 and he
wants to end it on a high uh I mean just
one of the best of the young Indian
generation that's rising up now and yeah
especially good at rapid and Blitz chess
taking his chances when they come so
tough defeat for Anish giri uh a great
win for argenteric icy maybe we can
check out some of the other winners we
saw dubov's stunning Queen H5 blow
earlier maybe just we can recap
Queen H5 a killer look at those two
white Bishops
wanna go all the way back yeah I think
we'll we'll go very quickly to the
beginning
um while we wait for the next round to
start just because it was a such a short
game it was a queen's game it accepted
this is all fairly standard queen E2 B5
Bishop D3 all of this has been seen But
after C takes D4 this were Doom of with
his opening preparation comes in uh and
all often pauses such uh such uh
interest with his new ideas A4 I mean
almost everybody here would either play
the move Rook D1 or take back on D4
dubov decides to go A4 he gets his Rook
active and he swings his Rook into the
center and all of a sudden The Rook
comes over to the king side and it was
around here where siren played Bishop B7
Knight C4 Queen C7 the bishop develop
with Bishop D2 and now sorry I mean this
move here Castle's asking for trouble I
I just don't understand how you can
Castle there with all of the white
pieces lined up then because both of his
Bishops lined up to boot and all of a
sudden
you're in big trouble here as
uh as black with all of those pieces
that Firepower against your king and
after G6 another piece launching in now
all of a sudden taking on H7 is the
threat and after 95 sarin was banking on
this pin but look at this beautiful
finishing move Queen to H5
um
the uh the threat is of course taking on
H7 and you can't take the queen as a
result of Bishop takes H7 Checkmate and
actually Queen H5 just ends the game
immediately there is no
um cure because Knight F6 you just
played Bishop takes F6
and the threat remains on H7 and that's
it there's it's just completely over
there's no way to avoid mate it's
probably made in two or three moves so a
lovely miniature
beautiful stuff reminiscent of the 19th
century the romantic era in chess Queen
sacrifices Galore checkmates Galore but
uh on that very uh impressive note let's
move to the women's standings we do have
the leaderboard up right now uh we do
see at the top there's four players in
joint first tanzongi Alina danielian
zansaya abdumalik a home favorite and
Bella tennis really so they are in first
place but look at the chasing pack
there's some huge names still including
another local favorite sultanbeck sign
up
and uh you mentioned some of the others
Leia garofalina Elizabeth pate and gong
maybe the surprise of the tournament so
far she took down one of the top women's
players in the world as black she took
down castenuk so uh yeah this
leaderboard it's very tight at the top
just as it was in the open section still
all to play for remember the women's
tournament is 11 rounds not 13. so uh
they're heading into round seven now
let's check out those pairings and
things are getting critical uh these are
the top 10 boards
and the four leaders are pitted against
each other Lawrence yep come to
Nashville against tanjong Ji uh and
daniellen who's having a great
tournament White against Abdul Malik uh
close though you can see we've got five
Boards of players on four and a half
that's ten players on four and a half
snapping at the heels some old and young
talented and experienced players look
we've got guy now representing The
Talented strong young Youth and how
about Angela stefanova former women's
world champion experienced head she's
gonna make a run for it you've got Nina
and Elizabeth PES as you said German
number one for years now experience
playing a younger opponent in Alina
bival and so on
so some very interesting parents there
big Clash on board eight as well uh
Lawrence Tanya against humpy canaro
clash of the Indian Superstars
um so yeah plenty of action that we will
keep an eye on a bit later
absolutely indeed and we can see now
Daniel dubov getting ready for his game
the biggest test of his tournament so
far it's always the biggest test of
anybody's tournament black against
Magnus Carlson how will he fare he's
always uh you know very chilled very
laid back kind of guy
um doesn't take things too seriously
um also it seems
um and uh of course
well what I mean by that is he doesn't
get overly stressed about the situation
he he believes in this tournament
he knows it's a very important
Tournament of course he is former was it
World rapid award let's I think it was
wrote one yep yeah not so long ago what
was it about five six years ago now I
think he won 2018 I believe so only four
years ago only four years ago yep
very talented very creative
and it will be very very interesting to
see how Magnus decides to play this
particular game
and one thing we should also mention
about duboff he's from a very historic
chess family I think his grandfather was
a very strong player and now uh in light
of recent developments this year he has
spent a lot of time in Kazakhstan I
believe he's been living there for uh
quite a few months he's been based there
for a while so this must feel like home
territory for him that must have been
inspiring him no jet lag of course
compared to some of the other players
who've been traveling from the other
side of the world from the American
players have started a bit slower
because maybe adapting to that huge time
difference has been a factor but Daniel
duboff no he's looking very relaxed as
you say looking confident playing some
great chess Queen H5 what a move and
black against Magnus it's not going to
be easy Magnus won't give him the type
of positions that he thrives in uh
without a fight but he is capable he has
beaten Magnus several times before in
Rapid chess there was a case in the
Champions chess tour of uh du buff I
think he beat Magnus three or four times
in the course of two days so if anyone
could do it do both can and uh here we
see yeah something like that yes yes
yeah Lexi Serrano with the white pieces
against uh yankov Judah
also up there in the standing student
needs to fight back he lost a very
difficult game earlier today and Magnus
has arrived Lawrence predictions
yeah this is a really tough one to
predict actually
um
I'm gonna go with a draw I know that's
not exactly the most fun of predictions
but
um I think Daniel is
is
creative enough and uh Magnus isn't
having
I think that last game
required a lot of energy from Magnus
but we'll see it's not completely clear
to me
um it's a really really tough one to
to go for and he's sticking with his
B3 opening David which is really
surprising me he's played this a bunch
of times already
and duboff goes for
a sideline with uh bishop b290 and G6
and Magnus continuing to play in his
kind of english-y nimso Larsen
and izovich Larson way I mean it's it's
very curious just getting a position
yeah at least he's been consistent
Magnus he's staying loyal to the
openings that have brought him success
so far in the tournament but it is a
double-edged sword the more you repeat
an opening the better prepared your
opponents will be in future and uh yeah
these two as you mentioned or if they've
worked together now for what is it four
or five years they know everything about
each other last time I was hanging out
with Magnus he actually got texts from
dubov they're that good friends uh but
of course they want to kill each other
over the board they both want to take
this very important point and uh yeah B3
won't have come as a surprise you
mentioned as you mentioned to dubov
Magnus has played that move several
times already this tournament and uh
quick replies by black white opening the
Center Lawrence what do you think of
this this Pawn structure looks nice for
white uh having a clamp on the center
but black is quite far ahead in
development already black is now castled
white needs to catch up Mike needs to
get his King to safety white needs to do
something about his Queen side Knight
I'm not that big a fan I must say of
White's chances is White's position
right now I don't know about you well
maybe you can just take on C6 take on G7
and play Knight C3 and just develop like
this for example if I play like this
I take here
and then I play Knight C3 and queen D2
how bad is life
um true and do what takes back with the
D Pawn how interesting
I was about to suggest that this is
always an option in this type of Pawn
structure not only are you speeding up
accelerating your development now the
black Bishop can come into the game but
also you have opened up the central line
which black now has control over the
open defile long term of course white is
winning any King opponent games because
white has the better Pawn structure
white has four versus three on the king
side black on the other side that pawn
majority is not impressive but
um yeah this is reminiscent of the
Berlin end game this is reminiscent of
the scotch game often you get this type
of Pawn structure as black and not too
much to worry about I feel
however style wise surely it's got a
favorite Magnus that dubov can't
Checkmate him can't attack him no more
Queens on the board
that tends to be the antidote against
very aggressive players if you can get
if you can get the coins off
and Magnus well known for his end games
so yeah pros and cons I still believe
black is completely fine black is very
active black will it be able to throw
his a port down the board later to cause
some disturbances Black's Bishop can sit
happily on E6 Black's Knight maybe has a
root round somewhere a bit later on but
can do both whip up some activity he's
not the kind of guy who wants to sit
there in a long grindy end game
uh Lawrence yeah interesting start to
this one it's this kind of sped up I
didn't expect this opening Choice from
either side I've got to say but uh
sticking with your prediction of a draw
yeah
um I you know this is you know Magnus is
in risk-free territory here though so
you've got to be a bit careful here with
you we'll do both
is A5
um a typical kind of move putting the
pawn on adult Square gaining a little
bit of space
uh
uh I'm curious to see yeah Magnus just
going to play very classically Bishop E2
yeah it's interesting what the plans
will be for either side I think Magnus
wants to get his H1 Rook into the game
as quickly as possible as we mentioned
it exchanges benefit white long term
because of the superior structure so
magnus's plan is maybe clearer than
blacks that's the one thing I will say
it's not 100 clear where black puts his
Knight I mentioned it could reroute to
better squares but if for example you
push the black pawn to C5 to try and get
the Knight to C6 you do lose squares
yourself
so it should be six first from duboff
can he ever break with A4 it's unclear
whether that's a threat
uh yeah White's Knight is sitting nice
and pretty actually on the C3 Square
maybe the most valuable piece right now
for the MVP just holding everything
together
also how does Magnus connect his Rooks
if he castles the black Rook can come
into D2 and that is something that needs
to be evaluated very carefully
and uh yeah I mean I've lost too many of
these to Magnus to be optimistic about
Black's chances but I still feel
objectively in the balance
all right let's move on to the you Yang
Yi game very quickly uh playing against
Frederica
uh we have a very interesting opening
there
where
we have a Catalan
main line and here the move Knight C3
which is becoming more popular for years
either the queen to city or queen to A4
recapturing this Pawn was the call to
play but instead we see white trying to
get the big Center and H4 by pricker in
early age four looking to gain space on
the king side pushing that Knight into
D5 and now using the newly uh supported
G5 squared Knight G5
h69h3 and this position here is uh very
very interesting uh
thoughts on this one David
yeah it's fascinating like you say it's
so balanced at this early stage white
has almost gone all in what has
committed significant resources into uh
getting this kind of wedge in the center
white is down upon now the Knight is
attacked you have to decide whether to
trade off black tonight on that outpost
on D5 in the center however on the plus
side remember it's rapid chess in Rapid
is so much easier to attack than defend
white has a ready-made attack White's
Queen is coming out to G4 white tonight
is going to relocate via F4 over to H5
there's gonna be all sorts of sacrifices
uh on the H6 Square in the air that
black H6 Pawn is what we call a hook uh
White's going to use that hook to break
open the shelter around Black's King and
yeah Queen G4 is uh almost ready to be
played
yeah I mean it just looks so natural for
white whereas black you have to see
counter play quickly and
before move I mentioned the white can
take on D5 I would be tempted to be
honest normally you don't want to trade
off pieces when you are material down
Knight E4 is a very natural move as you
mentioned Lawrence but Knight F4 here
uh you are attacking Black's Pawn
edifice on D5 and you will gain the
bishop here it's just about this
position the evaluation exactly after
Knight takes C6 is you highlight that
concretely do you win the pawn back
you're hitting E6 you're hitting H6
I don't see how black can hold
everything together is there a concrete
problem Bishop H3 is also available if
you want to kind of hammer down on the
E6 uh E6 weakness
I'm not sure if this variation is forced
but it looked that way and if so you
yangi might be in trouble at this early
stage yeah interesting opening Lawrence
the Catalan is one of the most trendy
openings uh I think it may be the
opening of 2022 everyone's been playing
it with white with black so many new
ideas discovered in this opening and
clearly even the top players in the
world you Yang Yi I think the Chinese
number two he's struggling here as black
already white has two Pleasant options
Knight E4 equally logical
um yeah I think normally I'm a
materialist I love the pawns I I call
myself an accountant sometimes I just
want to collect all the poems and grind
it out within the end game but here I
would take the initiative
uh take whites attack any day over
Black's position
couldn't agree more
I think this is a very very dangerous
position we'll keep an eye on that uh as
we are of course with other games
nothing major yet to report on as far as
I can tell
from the other top games
that I'm keeping an eye on everything of
course
for you guys I mean we've checked in on
some of the leaders we've checked in on
Magnus Carlson of course key Clash there
against the above maybe we can see how
the other leaders are doing
um I know nothing too dramatic but just
to get a flavor of what's going on on
their board so to update against Federal
save
still early days in this game it started
as a Queen's Gambit declined and it has
opened up slightly almost symmetrical
Pawn structure but blacks Queen now
landing on a bit of an odd Square on B8
and it does feel like white needs
something before like an unravel swap
off pieces like has some ideas of
attacking potentially with the black
queen on this diagonal towards the H2
Pawn the Knight might land on G4 later
but
how happy will he be feeling Felice was
just staring him down a moment ago I
love that when the top players are just
uh glare at each other try to get under
each other's skin Rook D1 centralizing
The Rook
who would you take here Lawrence it does
feel like there's a lot of potential for
either side
I think I'd take white here to be fair
um
I think that
uh just
the disconnect between
the black Rooks at the moment and the
fact that my pieces are ever so slightly
more active but it's a really tough one
to say I'm not entirely sure
I would have to have a real think about
it I I it's it's really close
um
I'm just trying to think what kind of
plans I might have here as black
because if I go 95
cam black can white just take on F6
that's my
concern even this I'm not sure is that
bad for black
but yeah
that's the Eternal dilemma right the the
pawn structure weaknesses against the
dynamism of Black's Bishop pair is
Black's King really a Target I like
Knight E5 if you can play it yeah but
you also have to calculate so you also
have to factor in white dropping back
the bishop to F4 elaboration with some
pins and
yeah there's a lot on the cards it was
interesting to see fair to save as well
uh just before we uh jumped into the
game properly he was taking a wander
around that normally is a mark of
confidence in a player especially during
rapid tests to get up from the board to
stand up stretch the legs check out
other buds but it's also a psychological
ploy
shows the opponent that you're feeling
confident but of course it can backfire
if you lose focus for a moment stepping
away from the board just interesting uh
kind of mannerisms there from farissev
as he doesn't go for Knight E5 and maybe
thinking that was too committal instead
he puts some pressure on White's Central
Pawn indirectly by playing Bishop B4 he
wants to chop off that Knight on C3 and
white E4 Pawn might well be uh
vulnerable so
okay very calm move just when it looked
like white was creating some threats
uh can white
somehow whip up some activity here I
don't see it instantly it's not an
intuitive position where there's an
immediate attack for white for example
if white plays the most natural move in
the position I think it would backfire
pushing the pawn forward to E5 uh maybe
we can show this Loris uh if E5 happens
you have to consider what happens after
Bishop takes F3 removing the defender of
that white E Pawn and I don't think
white can get away with this
just drops next move and if you can't
push your Pawn forward
uh that we see a double attack from the
Knight yeah if you can't play E5
how do you defend that pawn first of all
how do you create a threat
suddenly I'm preferring black I love
this last move I didn't it wasn't on my
radar yeah this should be four is very
good so what do we do here do you have
to go Knight A2 as white now
to uh to effectively attack the pawn oh
sorry I beg your pardon attack the
bishop and then force a repetition could
we get that kind of repetition Knight A2
Bishop C5 Knight C3 Bishop B4 in a
classical game you could certainly see
that right
yeah um that would be a Pity an
anti-climax an early draw between these
two great warriors but
yeah I was also not nordeback's style to
try and bail out it is possible however
um I guess fedesev also would have
something to say about that variation
for example if the white knight drops
back harassing that Bishop then the
black Bishop could choose a different
Square
um D6 possibly
uh for the black Bishop
yeah it's interesting if white has
nothing better than offering a
repetition of moose then it shows the
opening has gone severely wrong
um so maybe let's check back in on this
one uh a bit later um
Ponders this really difficult decision
um which other games catch your right
Lawrence the developments in the game
between Magnus and dubov let's go back
there game of the round for sure
and wow E4 the last move by Magnus he's
trying to force as many pawns as many
pieces off the board as possible
and uh if you can achieve it remember he
will have the advantage black has some
hints of counter play
A4 always has to be considered black
trying to undermine White's Queen side
I'm not sure I would want to take this
white Pawn in the center I've got to say
if Knights come off
it should still be fine for black but
we're edging towards a really unpleasant
end game
okay let's say everything comes off
black king comes forward to F6
and
still looks solid but Magnus can stop
pushing with G4 for example start
throwing some pawns down the board
yeah it's A4 can be met with B4 perhaps
right now
maybe maybe black is able to fix her
fix a weakness maybe some yeah or some
Rook d8 Rook T2
uh Rook D2 it's um it's not so not so
easy
um yeah it's not one-way traffic while
the Rooks remain on the board if the
Rooks come off then it's okay who can
press
we might we might even get this
uh fe4 magna's not taking back on e4
immediately just in case
there is another move he might want to
insert G4 here first no but root 64 King
F7
and now let's see what Magnus does in
this position to improve his
his uh
his position I'm very curious to see
this is where you can learn from a top
player even in a rapid format he will
have a really good feel for how best to
ah
to push in this position here
so let's see
yeah it's all about plans or it's not
even Grand plans it's just micro plans
of two or three moves at a time Han for
example white start pushing his G Pawn
as we showed a moment ago he is after
all uh slightly better on the king side
on the right half of the board where he
has this
um yeah poor majority three versus two
is that the way to massage the advantage
or is it just too difficult to push
those pawns long term do you prioritize
activating your King instead
um do you maybe relocate the white Rook
which is kind of uh yeah it's
neutralized at the moment by Black's
Bishop blocking the e-file White's
Bishop as well doesn't really have a
logical uh active Square to sit on it's
really not straightforward for white
black meanwhile it's solid black has
plans like pushing to A4 like you say
yeah this could well be a long grind but
do both looking calm looking Shield I
would Bank on him holding this one
right now he he may very well do but
some breaking news uh that we've
received Eric Hanson
the Canadian Grandmaster has withdrawn
from the world rapid today after
developing some aggressive flu-like
symptoms
overnight he says he'll see how he's
feeling in 48 hours before he makes a
decision on the blitz tournament very
frustrating wow which is
um obviously firstly we we wish Eric all
the best we hope he gets well soon
um if there is an outbreak of Corona as
we've seen uh cases creep up certainly
in that a region in that side of the
world while that could have massive
implications for the tournament I guess
Eric is going to do tests and the like
but he was mingling with pretty much
everyone recently let's hope it's just a
flu and in any case we wish Eric all the
best
hope he gets better soon
that's Such a Pity uh for example last
year in the world rapper and Blitz
Hikaru had to withdraw due to catching
covid and plenty of other players were
affected as well
um of course Eric has played the likes
of Magnus so
um yeah it's uh such a shame uh best
wishes go out to Eric and all those
around him
let's hope he recovers quickly in time
for the blitz let's hope it's nothing
too serious but uh yeah let's get back
to the chess Lawrence meanwhile Magnus
has played a very committal move long
term I mean if if this were an opening
or a middle game I would say this is
ugly pushing the pawn to A4 stopping
Black from advancing yes but look at why
it's pawns now on the light squares
Prime targets for the black Bishop
I guess because it is an end game Magnus
is banking on the fact that black can
never break through to that white B3
Pawn a huge backward Pawn there and uh
he's saying okay I've locked down one
side of the board now we're going to
switch our attentions to the king side
and that's where the battle will be
fought but
I've got I've got to feel skeptical I've
played so many Berlin end games where
this backfires on white long term uh
Magnus of course he's better at judging
these things than anyone else but uh
yeah that's certainly a sign that he's
not happy to just play for a draw he's
not happy to just sit tight hold the
status quo he really wants to uh
frustrate dubov here and White's next
moves will be king E3 will be G4 pushing
pawns forward and
how does duboff take advantage
feels like there should be well I I I'm
looking at this position and I feel like
there might be a few ideas for example
what about the move we're up to a six
does this move make any sense the point
being that you want to put the Rook on
B6 let's say y plays G4 a move like Rook
B6 and let's say now white plays Rook to
E3 just to defend I was wondering can
you now go Rook B4 and try and play B5
looks a little audacious to me to play
like this and there are almost certainly
better ways for black to to play for
white play but it's an idea at least and
it certainly an idea that will cross
Daniel's mind how would you play well
Rook V8 of course classic white cannot
allow Rook D2 here of that I'm sure
I expect to move King E1 or King E3 to
be played I guess King E3 is correct
yeah King E3 is the move you would want
to play just to cut the Black Brook off
from ever entering White's camp but
there are it's the direct tactical ideas
uh if King E3 for example black can play
Bishop F5 uh in that position and lack
is coming behind now with this bishop to
try to get to C2 after Rook D4 I could
give a check for example uh on E8 and
you do have to calculate stuff like
Bishop C2 I don't think it works right
now but you would also have actually
Lawrence in this position White's Rook
is almost trapped after C5
you have to be a bit careful
Rook D5 and I just survived
and Magnus is just surviving
because he has gone for King E3 King E1
you mentioned the alternative White's
king is not so active there so Magnus
playing the maximalist approach yet
again but
yeah it's uh certainly a three result
game this end game now maybe uh
maybe after Bishop F5 if he wants to go
rookie five
now this is this is certainly a move but
let's say black said I actually I want
to defend does Magnus want to play C5 is
that
is that an idea to allow this bishop to
finally join the actual in Bishop C4 I'm
not sure how beneficial this is for
Magnus
certainly an auction
yeah to E6 maybe yeah this is just
saying
if you want to play Bishop C4 it's just
a rook end game and that should end in a
draw for black
yeah I mean there's lots of questions to
answer Magnus answers one of them he
plays Rook D4 in the current position
I think we should keep Rooks on the
board if we are Daniel dubov uh as we
mentioned a rook exchange and it's all
about whether white can convert it's not
even a question of winning the game
anymore is black if the Rooks disappear
it's simply the three versus two on the
king side that's uh
all the action will lie with so Rook D4
I think black will give a check and go
for that variation we mentioned any
other Games catching your eye this one
is going to be a long ride
yes it is
um
in the women's tournament we see some uh
some really intense battles some drama
maybe on board three it looks like
goliachkin is about to win or has a
winning Advantage uh against the
underdog gong from Singapore
uh the other games on the top Boards of
the women's section do look quite
balanced so we'll check back in if
there's some drama there
okay we have
oh this is interesting
um
is this the right game no I'm just
getting up the right game we are looking
at Bella against San Juan Ji
mm-hmm
what a bishop 187 look at that piece
yeah
very very poor Bishop would
yeah and Incredibly the the bar is not
giving this as massively winning for
white which is shocking to me because my
night lands on e4
and why is this not plus two for white
yeah nominal
I'm struggling to understand as well
maybe black has some counter-attack
against a slightly uh open white king
queen C7 is the starting point here for
tanzong yi the opening we've got to say
in human terms has gone wrong for black
what is Black's plan how are you ever
going to
escape with that Bishop out of its tomb
there over on H7
yeah I guess long term black has to play
King h8 Pawn to F6 Bishop back to G8 but
that will take three Tempe to reroute
the bishop and even then it sits on a
poor diagonal so yeah you're right
Lawrence it does feel like white with
some accuracy it should be able to whip
up some initiative before black is ready
and the Knight comes out I guess black
has to go for a Night Exchange why
tonight was too strong it looks like a
statue there in the center of the board
SO trading off that Knight will
alleviate some of the pressure but uh
still looking very good for Bella how
about on board two
some of the other leaders the local
favorite sansaya Abdul Malik he
mentioned
looks like let's have a look
roughly balanced position in that one
uh Alina danielian I think has been
maybe uh one of the best players of the
tournament so far I'm most impressive at
least on the board she is in the joint
need but she could have had more points
she was beating castanoke yesterday
agreeing a draw in a advantageous
position she has just jumped forward
with her Knight level pawns level pieces
here
the bar seems to be indicating white has
a significant advantage
at first I thought it was balanced but
the more I look at it the more I think
White's piece activity could be decisive
Black's King as well you should hesitate
putting pawns so far uh forward in front
of your own King and White's Queen could
land on H5 at some point white could
lever open the position with F3 a bit
later on yeah the black E4 Pawn very
loose as well Lawrence thoughts on this
position looks horrible for black
doesn't it Loose Pawn on e4 pieces
aren't really working together
um and Alina daniellan she's she's she's
really surprising me because don't get
me wrong her quality is uh is undeniable
she's been around for many years now
she's proven herself at the top level
but to to keep up and and do well
against the guns like she's doing in the
quicker formats
um being outrated heavily in a lot of
these games for example in the last
round against San ju now against John
say after Malik it's just very
impressive and it does go to show that
form is temporary in class is permanent
she's got plenty of it and jensiah's
position is just dodgy it's just dubious
um
Bishop C4 pitting this Knight
I guess now if black tries F4 you can
just take
a take five yeah this is the the classic
antidote
and
half of Black's pieces are on pre so
jansaya now has to be actually a little
bit careful she's really gone for it
this round uh so she's put the King on
H7
now F4 might be a threat in some
universe so you have to be a bit more
careful now as black uh sorry it's white
and maybe you should play Queen B3 here
just to pressurize this night ask black
a few questions if the Knight comes to
Essex this is still a threat
you might have to go F3 here
you might have to go maybe
that's not such a bad thing for white
maybe that's part of the plan anyway
just to open up the f file for White's
Rook that's the only piece that isn't
really playing that isn't participating
right now lacks kind of structure is
creaking it's overextended why not open
up lines so I love this uh this line of
play Lawrence also if the Black Knight
had gone the other way uh you played
Knight F6 in that variation I just want
to point out one small thing but if the
Knight has gone to B6 instead after
Queen to B3 then there are ideas like uh
Knight V6 Bishop G8 check for example
gaining a bit of time I'm not sure
whether it actually achieves much but it
just looks nice and flashy just jumping
in
to hit that black king in the corner
yeah
pH and now maybe you can even just come
up here right attack this Knight exactly
just gaining some time just kicking
blacks pieces around that night's
actually almost trapped Lawrence you're
right it is very unpleasant
Queen B3 has been played
Queen B3 has been played Knight F6
yeah and we're expecting F3 with an
advantage for white
and uh meanwhile should we check back in
on the open section
oh wow very flashy
yeah oh we're deep in the end game with
Magnus and dubov are we about to see a
peaceful draw in this game ship F5
played by dubov
requesting calculation so for example if
the Bishops do disappear we said all
King and Pauline games are winning for
white but maybe dubuff has found the
exception
and uh he's looking very can't do both
twiddling his bishop or twiddling that
piece in his hand uh he's ahead on the
clock Magnus not looking too
enthusiastic
yeah let's uh do some analysis Lawrence
if Bishop takes Bishop yes black have a
fortress
I think so because white would love to
be able to get in entering with the King
these two squares are blocked if you're
playing YouTube black side here is to go
King G6 and I'm pretty sure
can he even go for example
uh
maybe age five or eight
yeah
five but H6 could work
oh yeah age five I'm gonna get zucked
yeah you're out that's quite instructive
let's show that because after H5 King G3
let's say King H7 you can go King H4
King G6 but I'm not actually h3c6
black is just in time without seats
but it looks like a draw I also have
another move right to spare so black
does actually have 10p
um so H5 or H6 as David said if you take
it you try and move your king over uh
you're not going to get very far I'm
just gonna go back and forth between H6
and G6 you can't make any progress and
if you protect your Pawn with H4 now
black can go H5
and this is a stone cold draw because
yes you've got the protective passport
on so what I just keep an eye on it
there is never a breakthrough here for
white so I think Bishop F5 is quite
easily
um
sort of well well done there by duboff
Bishop D1 King G7 H4 played and now I
wonder if H5 get exactly played by
duboff and
this position is
very very difficult for magnets to win
the problem is of course is that if he
doesn't take on percentage goes back
here we already know that this ending is
a draw
and if he takes ambassant
King's executes now the bishop has to
remain on this diagonal else King H5
King 6h4 happens so let's say the bishop
comes I don't know to a square like F3
and if I just pass here with black
Lawrence it is a draw they have agreed
to uh half the point here uh yeah just
nothing to be done as you mentioned the
word Fortress I do both held the
Fortress and Magnus had no way through
Fair results after a very cagey game kg
Affair in that one
yep absolutely and I'm pretty happy once
again with uh we've been able to guess
is I I I I didn't think do wolf would
lose somehow I I don't know why I
thought that but
I felt like Magnus has had a tough game
the previous round had to do a lot of
calculating and maybe took a bit of
steam out of him he's just losing a
little bit of steam still of course up
there with this draw now all eyes are on
boards two and three where Kmart and
after satorov are both playing with
white let's go to Cayman because as far
as I can tell big big problems for Eric
AC David in this position here looks
gross
yeah huge problems uh just doing a quick
count it is level material at least
temporarily but look at Black's
structure Black's E7 Pawn is isolated
like A6 Pawn is isolated all of white
spots are connected so even if this gets
to an end game which I think everybody
is praying for right now uh then there
will still be long-term problems but
short term it's all about the looseness
of black that Knight on C6 undefended
doesn't really have any safe squares to
go to Black's King is quite open don't
be surprised later if White's King steps
forward a white Rook swings over to the
H file and there might be trouble there
and uh also yeah the White Queen is
aiming to pick up
so much material I'm still wondering
what the knockout blow will be for
example if Black's one of the two black
Brooks sits on the sixth rack F6 or Rook
D6 just to kick away the White Queen
uh I guess the White Queen just Retreats
she can step back to any Square uh yeah
as one of the ones you mentioned
Lawrence G4 H3 and Knight E4 is coming
next nearly no matter what and that's
gonna come with power uh I love where
you've put the White Queen actually
opposite the black king there will be
some Knight G5 checks as you mentioned
later on Knight E4 is going to hit the
black Rook the white uh the white Rook
on the C file is going to open up
everything is just wrong with Black's
position and Eric I see therefore seeks
Solace he tries to defend this one in an
end game he offers the Queens uh to come
off a queen trade
still as we mentioned ugly for black but
uh at least it would postpone uh the
worst and okay let's go back to the
current position Lawrence I think the
Queens have left the board Vincent is
known for loving end games he is as we
mentioned earlier that rare exception uh
of youngsters who do favor those slower
strategic positions where he can take
his time out maneuver the opponent and
after the black queen okay has dropped
back to D6 I think he took that Queen
off and Eric icy back in the tank
thinking and I'm expecting the pawn to
recaptureate if black Rook if the black
Rook takes then Knight E4 looks mightily
Troublesome uh this looks like a
disaster for black rookie 6 Knight C5
and I can do a dance maybe there's still
no knockout blow after Rook D6 it's
hanging together by a thread right now
it's like uh
uh he's walking a tight rope now Eric
icy but if he takes with the pawn in the
current position if he takes back on D6
with the pawn equally disastrous uh okay
he has actually gone for this variation
wow so let's stick with the position
rookie six
he's he's really praying to all the
chess Gods now her regising but uh
nothing Falls
I don't even see a way for white to win
the A6 Pawn maybe we can show this
Knight C5 uh getting the White Knight
out of Dodge Knight C5 Rook D6 if you
take on A6 in that position then Knight
takes D4 it's a counter attack
hitting that White Knight on A6 so this
is what every guys is banking on not to
go down upon
did Vincent miss that black could get
away with this uh when he went for the
queen trade I'm not sure if he missed it
I think he just thought that this
position is just so good for white
regardless but he's he has to be precise
not sorry you could go Knight B7 what
about Knight B7 ah just rookie six again
I know rookie 65 sorry
yeah so
yeah
also D5
so Knight B7 and if Rook D7 now worst
cases I can take take and take and
well it's a pawn
should be enough
forever I mean remember Vincent won uh
an end game with three versus two a pure
Rook end game in the last round against
you Yang Yi is reminiscent of that uh
are we I think we're heading in this
direction we are headed toward this end
game four versus three in terms of Pawns
all of White's pawns connected great
winning chances but okay this is the
best position every guy sees seen since
we joined the game he survived at least
he knows now he can knuckle down and try
to defend for the next 50 moves
it's not going to be easy White's going
to play King G2 why it's going to
improve his Bishop uh to a better
diagonal Eric I see now trying to get
his Rook to the second rank interesting
idea
um White's Rook could always drop back
and defend that second rank on Via A2
yeah this one we'll check back in on
later but it's very much a two result
game Eric I see fighting for his life uh
can only hope to draw that best
alrighty let's go elsewhere let's see
Federal save now photo save such a
tricky customer
the machine seems to prefer black here
and hold on a second he's just won an
exchange
what is this it takes D5 and queen D6
it's an exchange
wow crazy to Rook G6 Knight H4
will have to be played
yes but Lord even if white wins back the
material what white is down a pawn black
will have an extra pawn and it's not
just any opponent it's the past C Pawn
is it enough Rook D4 as you highlight
there is coming we could be headed
towards a queen end game where the extra
Pawn might be decisive Black's Queen is
not a happy blockader but she will try
to gobble up that white d-pawn a bit
later
Max King is super safe Black's pole
structure is compromised around his King
but this is the ideal defensive setup
actually for black and you don't need to
push Sports you don't need a harmonious
pull structure around your king in a
queen end game all you need is to avoid
checks so
feder save I think a big favorite to
convert this
what do you think Lawrence
Save the Day
I'm not sure about this one this looks
really bad for episode of like Rook D4
here
I struggled to see
exactly how you save
like do you want to just take
oh [ __ ]
ugly uh Lawrence what about e takes D4
giving yourself two connected passports
yeah
and now the point is Queen E6 is not the
same as we can just take and go King G8
and we oops
not there King G8 uh come towards the
pawn and win
I think Rook D4 is kind of mandatory
here no
yeah I mean it's his idea to go active
with the white Rook somehow instead it
feels like any Queen end game is just
gonna be straightforward win for black
uh so Rook B1 for example black called
take on D5 maybe with a rook now Queen
takes A6 would be possible for white but
if root takes rookie Rook B6 I thought
yeah and Rook D1 there's no yeah white
king could just hide safely
but no
and queen C2
okay interesting
interesting don't like I don't like this
ton of events for further save because
now he's kind of Frozen his own pieces
like Rook is stuck defending the sea
porn Black's Queen is stuck blockading
whites past d-pawn
and yeah where's the black king actually
going it feels like fedes
I don't want to say and I've lost his
Advantage spoilers Advantage but
he's at least made it a lot more
difficult for himself white will happily
play G3 H4 and just sit wait yeah I
really dislike this thing it's such a
impulsive decision to play C4 here by
photosho you know just Rook D4 was just
screaming to be played got absolutely no
idea why you went against that move
such a logical move
sometimes you've got to keep things
simple I mean also it's like we've said
throughout yesterday and today you got
you've got to choose one plan and stick
to it it's rapid chess you can't be
inconsistent yes you want to stay
flexible but uh it sounds like it feels
like you found a winning plan for the
say of Rook B4 Rook D4 or at least a
strong plan uh yet he went away from it
and now like the pawn structure I
mentioned on the king side it's ruined
now and the White Queen is happily
sitting on an outpost in the center if
black plays C3 the White Queen drops
back to F3 with a check picking up that
c pawn and we just see
position repeat itself almost
white will happily wait as we mentioned
forever Black's King going back where it
came from no progress in sight and
I think we might see a draw these two
will still be in the lead after magnus's
result they'll still be in joint first
place but disappointment perhaps for
feathersev who had a big advantage
and uh 100 Health drama elsewhere
Lawrence where else can we look uh this
might go on for a while as FedEx tries
to squeeze any remaining chances out
looks like oh draw on board four draws
on board six
um any action fencing climate still
pressing away how about me
Neiman magsudlo uh that suddenly becomes
a very relevant game and the bar is
telling you everything you need to know
Hans Neiman uh with a good position up
an exchange not easy though magsudu a
tricky customer
uh
uh what do you think about this position
David is this just actually a bit
unclear
yes
yeah it looks good for white purely
because you're the exchange up and you
have the plus B Pawn I guess but uh in
human terms I mean the bishop hair so
dangerous white king not entirely safe
either
um yeah I like Neiman's last move I
really like it just retreating calmly
with the queen queen people also like
what he's yeah what he's just done there
exactly trying to get the Queens off at
all costs if the B Pawn is captured
white takes on H5 and uh yeah I think
that will be fatal for black uh actually
the black king I was talking about the
Viking but the black king on the light
squares
it doesn't feel comfortable at all
blacks lost some of the uh some of the
Integrity of his Pawn structure by
advancing that black point to default I
don't like the black Pawn on D4 because
it blocks in his dark Squad Bishop
that's dark Square Bishop now rendered
quite irrelevant
and uh yeah meanwhile check out this
image we have in front of us three very
young players uh analyzing a game I'm
not sure which game maybe one of them is
playing in the tournament maybe they're
watching some of the live games uh maybe
they're analyzing that Magnus against
dubov endgame by the way cute scenes and
hopefully this tournament in Kazakhstan
does inspire feature Generations
Lawrence this was us one day all that
time ago right
yeah I mean uh it feels like a long time
ago now David I'll be honest mate it's
been it's been a few years uh but it's
it's nice to see an old chess set out
right uh in the crowd not on the phone
or tablet or something uh a bit old
school does bring back nice memories of
uh viewing chess from the crowds
okay Queenie two queen B1 Lindsay I hope
they don't drop that bud maybe one
as mentioned and
oh Hans repeating the position is he
just going to do that once or is he
going to bail out with the draw uh this
is the second time we've seen this
position now after Queen B2 attacking
the F2 Point uh I can't defend that pawn
on F2 with his King
Neiman is material up he'll be reluctant
to go for a draw uh those youngsters
getting very excited about whatever game
and they're analyzing I don't know if
it's this one but uh okay critical
moment for Hans Neiman in his tournament
he will want more than a draw if he's to
make a mark at the top of the standings
what do you think Lawrence is he going
to bail out we need to repeat the
position for a third time
what's wrong with King G1 that's my
question
computer hates it
isn't even afraid of D3 followed by
Bishop D4 potentially
starting a counter-attack against the
weakness on F2
very impossibly
very very risk involved yeah right yeah
agreed
yeah and it looks like we're gonna get a
repetition here
yeah if I'm not mistaken this is the
third time now after Queen B1 that we
have seen this position
and okay the clocks are still running we
do often see scenarios
of where players don't claim the three
uh threefold record yes sorry Lars I
want fair to save did make a draw sorry
just to interrupt so a critical game
there uh Abdul sotura for the serve has
ended in a draw
all draws so far at the top Carlson dubo
abusator of draw Serana Duda draw
mamijara petrosium drug array of draw
Nakamura let's go and check in with
Hikaru because Hikaru
also as far as I can tell not beating
the Young merzin
this is a I mean it looks dangerously
black but it never quite is because
the king is
decently protected
um
oh Hikaru playing for tricks he's
playing for checkmate uh this all these
drawers have opened the door to players
such as Hikaru to catch up but I don't
see it where's the Checkmate if black
just takes that white Pawn on H5
white wants to okay he's starting to
find out
why wants to give a check on F7 you
can't check on A8 because then the black
king runs away via G7 so you have to
check on F7
what is Hikaru planning the black king
is gonna run you have to go to E8 only
Square Bishop G6 potentially but can
black just play Rook H6 attack the
bishop pin the bishop
I don't see a knockout I don't see a
killer blow for white no
discover checks Galore you can move your
Rook anyway anywhere in its track but
you have to defend your Bishop
I think Hikaru might be headed towards a
draw I don't think he can milk this any
further push for any advantage
um it takes H5 on the board
maybe a definition at the end there
well it could be if encourage resist if
he carry draws this that'll be four
draws in a row it'll only be on five out
of eight
way behind the scenes
Vincent kymer has just beaten Eric icy
as we see in the picture in front of us
we have Justina handshake Vincent
winning yet another end game one Pawn up
it was spookily eerily similar to his
previous round against you Yang Yi
Vincent the young German advancing
through the ranks thanks to great end
game technique yet again a fantastic
display
and it's nice to see the players uh
discussing afterwards eragisi hungry to
learn not taking that defeat to uh to
strongly he will be back
and uh meanwhile we are looking at the
hikara game still
yeah we're still on the Hikaru Game King
F5 play but I don't think there's much
really going on there
um
I think a draw is is huge favorable
about massive win for Vincent gamer who
joins the leaders joins for the save
joins Abdu settle joins Carlson on six
and a half
uh sure yeah tell me oh sorry I say
check out this view we do see Hikaru via
camera this is like Inception we're
seeing uh through a camera Hikaru on a
camera against Merton in the closing
stages of this game look at the body
language look at Hikaru how
disappointed he is and we will see the
handshake any moment the Rooks are off
the board neither side has enough
material and it is a draw amazing result
for young volodar merzin but yet more
disappointment for one of the favorites
Hikaru Nakamura that is his sixth draw
out of eight games
he is running out of time running out of
chances he needs to pretty much win the
rest of his games and hope that his
Rivals drop some points disappointment
for the American
massive disappointment white pieces
against a younger guy yes he's an
up-and-coming Grandmaster yes he's very
very strong but you are Hikaru nakamuri
is supposed to win that game uh if
you're going to stay in touch with the
leaders so a massive massive result
there for merzin and that really is
we're very close to the end of the round
there are a few games going uh we are
going to take a quick break now uh just
to let you guys know also that in the
women's section as a result of what
happened in that last round there is now
no less than eight players sharing the
lead in the women's section absolutely
packed at the top we'll go through all
the action from this round and the final
round of today coming up in just a few
minutes stay with us
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
life is full of exciting events but it
is our first impressions that we
remember best your first diploma
[Applause]
your first job in a big company
Unforgettable emotions from the first
date the first expensive things you
bought when you got your first paycheck
and your first Investments with freedom
broker Freedom broker look at your
favorite brands from A New Perspective
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
.com's coverage of the feed 8 World
rapid and Blitz championships day two of
Rapid we've got one round to go we've uh
had a very eventful first few rounds
still some games remaining in the open
section and one of them well there's a
guy I've uh had the pleasure of looking
at in the face quite often recently
those of you may know that Aman and I
had a chess boxing event in La uh where
Amman got the victory a bit premature
possibly when they counted me out but it
is what it is playing now black against
srinat naranian and it looks as though a
man who's a pawn down
trying to hold on looks like he is going
to hold on to me feels like a very
difficult position to win with white
with the pawns locked also the other
point being that after King E5 Knight F4
uh hitting this H3 pawn and if you go H4
a knight G6 check uh wins the pawn back
so I don't see a wave of srinat to
actually win this position but then
again the computer's going nuts so there
probably is a way David
am I missing something obvious here
um I don't think you're missing anything
obvious uh Lawrence I just want to say
as well there's one special spectator in
the crowd for Amman and uh there we go
it's chess Queen
Alexandra castenovic she's in amman's
corner
he tries to look for that knockout punch
I'd I don't know but oh you're making it
up now okay okay okay
you win
um but yeah I'm sure you'll be happy to
see that there won't be a knockout blow
in this one uh at least not on a man's
part he is very much the one fighting
for his life
and uh yeah srinath Narayanan of course
part of the India uh Olympia team very
strong very determined great speed chess
player but
I don't see any chances I don't see any
further resources for white unless you
can somehow trap this White Knight on
this Black Knight sorry on the edge of
the board so he has retreated his bishop
and is this a trap Lawrence Knight takes
H3 Bishop E3
I mean it feels like it should still be
fine for black but you don't want to
risk it getting your knight caught on
the edge of the board right I'm on
retreat no I I think a man is just gonna
well again 96 and King F6 precisely play
like this but now
yeah sure not trying his best to find a
way through but
doesn't seem easy at all
um got to be careful like 97 would be a
big blunder because now Bishop d8 would
exist and you can get a winning King
opponent
so you've got to be careful
so you went to show some show some good
footwork here for a man you know just to
dodge that sir touch that blue were you
impressed with his uh okay chest side
apart were you impressed with his skills
out there in LA Lawrence
well I was just taken I mean you know
I've been practicing for a number of
months and he basically just came out
swinging and he just took me by surprise
I thought we were going to ease into the
boxing uh feel each other out and he
just came out swinging from the off and
he spun me and he caught me quite early
um and I was already disoriented I could
never get uh uh my stance correct I
could never get my defense up and then
he caught me with a couple of very
strong punches and uh you know knocked
me down I managed to get up but I just
didn't regain balance properly and uh
they heard on the side of caution uh the
referees so the stoppage you know you
could debate was potentially a little
bit early but fair play to Amman I mean
I I didn't show my best but I will be
back
um fighting again uh don't worry about
that uh with a lot more practice a lot
more sparring
um in some future events
oh glad to hear that Lawrence what
doesn't kill you makes you stronger and
uh yeah chess boxing might be the future
looks like it was a very popular event
out there
big crowds online at least it was huge I
mean it was it was crazy it was
10 000 people in the stadium more or
less
uh and
uh you know uh
[Music]
um
I think in the region of 500 000 people
watching simultaneously online it was it
was just massive and you know I'm very
passionate about about Chess boxing and
I think it's got a very interesting
future so fingers crossed uh we get some
more big events
and thanks everybody for railing and
watching
yeah but no rematch with Iman I heard uh
that he doesn't want to fight you again
no he's not interested
he's he wants to do his chest stuff
which is fair enough uh whereas you know
for me I belong to a chess boxing gym
and I was very good friends with the
creator of Chess boxing and he passed
away unfortunately a few couple of years
ago now and I I really feel like it's
something that I should continue with
um so I will uh
we'll see when the next event is for
yeah glad to hear it and uh meanwhile
this game it still feels very much like
a draw Mariana and trying every trick in
the book uh to trap this Black Knight to
catch it on a poor circuit but black
snide feels like it should have enough
squares Knights are pretty decent at uh
kind of dancing around and avoiding
getting trapped uh if you are careful
about things Amanda giving way with the
black king I'm not so keen on that one I
don't think there's a direct punishment
if White's King shuffles across towards
that black pawn then Knight F4 is going
to come in uh for example King F5 Knight
F4 as you pointed out this trick earlier
laurenson
Saves the Day H4 926 check yet again and
I think he's calculated it all I think
he's still within the drawing Realms but
Mariana and Kenny find one final trick
to trip up the Canadian
I think black and continue waiting here
with his King with his Knight Knight f8
for example
hey has been played
and
yeah I just don't see any way forward
Black's King will happily sit on G6
defending the pawn Black's night then as
long as it's on a decent circuit we'll
be able to find safe squares
this could be a long long game holding
up the rest of the round uh we are
itching to get started with the final
game of the of the day in the open
section I believe the women's section
has however finished for the day you
mentioned eight leaders
on those a bit later
but uh yeah this game still on that
mariga round the white Bishop standing
opposite the Black Knight this is
typical normally in order to dominate an
opponent tonight with your Bishop you
want to place it just as white is doing
here two squares in between control all
the squares the Knight can jump to or at
least the forward squares but Knights
can Retreat too
yeah I don't see any progress being made
here Lawrence fair play to Iman
digging deep
holding on suffering but uh doing it
gracefully
and a draw is in sight I wonder when the
50 move rule will kick into play because
I don't think nariana is ever going to
offer the draw it's not not going to
give up his winning attempts anytime
soon
yeah absolutely I I it will be a draw I
think
you know Amman has has demonstrated now
can he even go Knight F4
yeah I think he's calculated well
because after H4 by white which I guess
is nariana's idea that can just take
that can take that pawn and a man is
doing this he's going straight for the
draw now this black pawn will distract
the white bishop and black is just in
time one tempo in time to remove the
white Pawn from the board here finally
we get the handshake and a draw
well played a man good draw
held there
uh I think we still are not finished
for the round I think image is about to
beat shankland who's having a torrid
tournament he'll be on 50 way below what
he would be looking for and I think that
will be the last game
for we see round
yeah we see an almost empty playing Hall
some fans sticking around just sitting
there uh enjoying the atmosphere which
is nice to see but uh yeah I think
you're right Lawrence we will be waiting
for those pairings we're waiting for
those final results to trickle in and uh
the last round of the day coming up it's
gonna be a big one as they jockey four
position ready for the final day of the
world record championship
indeed and what we are going to do is we
are going to take a very short break
while we get those pairings for what
will be the final round of today don't
go anywhere it's going to be a big round
are we going to get a standalone leader
going into the final day
we'll soon find out see you in a few
minutes
your subscription makes shows like this
possible which is why our twitch
subscribers will never see ads on
chess.com
connectyourchess.com account and Twitch
account at go.chess.com connect accounts
and bang boom voila you're done 100 AD
free Bliss forevermore whether you're
following our events on site or on
stream type the command connect in the
chat and thank you for helping bring
these shows to life
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
welcome back everybody this is
chess.com's coverage of the feed a world
rapid championships and the blitz
championships taking place in almatic
Kazakhstan it is day two of the rapid
championships we've got one more round
left in the open section the women's
section has finished though for today
David uh it is extremely tight at the
top over there too let's take a look at
the leaderboard uh going into the final
day and look at that run us through
what's going on there
yeah some huge uh games ahead because we
have eight players tied for first in the
women's section and uh those eight
players as we can see in front of us
they are headed by tanzongi and Lina
danielian Alina bivol Nino batsies
home favorite from Kazakhstan Alexandra
Bella Cortana and finally uh SRI Savita
from India and they are chased by a huge
pack as well so anything is possible
it's going to be a real sprint to the
Finishing Line uh in the women's section
it's going to be a race essentially who
can rack up the wins who can go on a
winning streak and here we see the
parents for the next round with all of
those eight leaders facing off against
each other on the top four boards uh we
see tanzong Yi against Alina bivol uh
goyaczkin against Lena daniellian that
is a huge pairing Danny Elian clearly
the informed player of the tournament
but goyachikina one of the highest rated
and uh you know that that's yes really
against Abdul Malik Savita against
Cortana shrilli and uh the chasing pack
behind them Lawrence it's going to be
crazy we might even see Mass tie breaks
tomorrow playoffs for the title if it
continues to be this close at the top
well given that it is this close and
this bunched with only uh three rounds
to go is it three let me think
uh might be it is three yes it is three
to go uh
that the likelihood of uh of a playoff
is is very very high we've got a whole
bunch of people there on five and a half
um it's gonna take a lot to get some
separation from the field
so we could be in for a very exciting
finish
in the women's section in the open
section Magnus Carlson abdulsator of
FedEx in Kemah all leading so far with
one round left today uh followed by
dubov and Cooper radzi having an amazing
tournament Giga cuparaza from Georgia
massively massively over performing
uh in sixth place at the moment
and then a bunch of more household names
in uh the following positions Eric AC
Duda artimi of Gary uh Yu Yang Yi is in
there Yan homneshi
Fabiano caruana
uh Thomas
a massive group of players
on five and a half
we will see how things go
with those guys but for the moment a
nice bit of separation
at the top Carlson came up to set her
off
and
we also have feathers save now the
pairings are up
is this a gift or is this
a
potential banana skin Magnus Carlsen
playing Black against Giga kooparazzi
who he will outrate by around 400 points
David do you think Magnus is happy at
that pairing
I mean he can't be too unhappy with that
one facing an underdog which is always
tricky as you mentioned it's actually
easier to slip up easier to
underestimate your opponents if you uh
if they are so much lower rated but
Magnus is Magnus he's very professional
he's black so it won't be easy he will
still still go 100 he will still go all
out at his opponent uh for cooperate
it's the chance of a lifetime playing
board one at such a late stage of the
tournament against the world's best
player and uh he's got nothing to lose
he can throw the kitchen sink at Magnus
he can continue playing taking risks as
he has done so far in the tournament and
it's paid off Giga cooperate did just
beat Jordan van Forrest in 19 moves as
black in the last round so he's on fire
form of his life why not uh go at the
world champion and uh we should mention
the other Paris fedes against kaimer two
Droid leaders there another joint leader
Abdul sotorov as black taking on Daniel
dubov and uh there's a whole bunch of
players ready to pounce if there are
Slip UPS uh at the top of the table
those include young Kristoff Duda
playing against Dimitri and draken who
got off to a slow start in the
tournament Eric icy up against fascia
lagrav who's also been playing catch up
and
some huge names as you mentioned there
Lawrence Carolina
jarov Neiman they're all rising to the
top now they do say the cream always
Rises to the top and we are seeing after
kind of mixed starts by these uh these
Giants of the game they were all up
there now they all have their chance as
we enter the critical rounds tomorrow is
going to be so tense but they need to
get in position they need to end today
on a high to give themselves confidence
and uh the winners of this final round
of the day they'll sleep better they
will be ready tomorrow when the time
comes we see the players entering the
tournament Hall meanwhile Anish giri in
the foreground there he's slipped down
the table slightly since his Stellar
start to the event but not out of it yet
uh yeah I just can't wait to see these
matchups I'm also looking at Daniel
dubov against Abdul satorov just as
alternative cerebral says that in the
feature chat that is going to be an
incredible battle both of those two
players are maximalists they big risks
when they play and uh better save as
well just marching into the camera I had
a band walking past he got off to a
really poor start I think he had half
out of his first four games That's How
Strong this field is and uh yeah
Lawrence predictions
as we enter a critical round for the day
I have to say that I'm I'm not uh hugely
uh
uh bullish on kuparazzi
it's really hard playing Magnus on top
board when he feels like he's got a
chance
when you know he's the better player
yeah sure cooperati has had an awesome
tournament beating van Forrest he's
beaten svana and David Anton and Ganguly
but Magnus is a different quantity
altogether I think this is a very very
tough spot for Cooper radzi a great spot
for Magnus Carlson
um I think feather save came out can go
anyway as well it really depends on how
ambitious FedEx wants to be and dubov
abdusaderov again another one where
things can go completely crazy depending
on how outrageous Daniel wants to be so
I've got no strong opinion on anything
except Magnus Carlson is a slam dunk
victory in this particular game and
um he may very well be alone at the top
uh come tomorrow
yep uh Magnus down floated to cooperate
big pairing that we do see in front of
us feather save and coma ready to start
their game in the background on the
right there we do see andrekin having a
chat with Daniel dubov having a last
minute chuckle as they get in the right
right mindset for their games and here
we see board one giga kuparadze he is
famous for being a speed specialist his
opening repertoire is so well-rounded
and uh he's phenomenally strong I've
played him many times on chess.com
played him in person at the world rapper
championship before he's not to be
underestimated he's ready he'll do his
usual thing he'll play super fast to put
pressure on the clock with one E4 he
always plays that opening always goes
for the Spanish very predictable Magnus
arriving slightly late as usual maybe
doing some last minute preparations
uh he knows this is huge if Magnus takes
a win as a black as well getting another
black game out of the way and he knows
he goes into tomorrow's games he will
start with white most likely and uh in
that race to the Finish he will have a
slight lead so
crucial crucial round coming up uh
cooperate from Georgia
Kingfish looking determined at the board
and uh yeah yes already Lawrence I think
uh we'll see the first move in just a
matter of moments
we may very well do I am sticking by
my prediction that this is going to be a
tough tough game for Cooper radzi
um yeah he looks chilled he looks
you know relaxed but as I say Magnus
Carlson just finds ways
very very curious to see how this one
does play out though
um moves are not in yet waiting for
players to get settled
and very shortly
we will see these games
all kick off
now we see Magnus and janaponishi enter
the playing Hall there some of the last
to do so it was nice to see cooperate
let some of the tension out just by
having a chuckle I think that was at the
announcement uh from the Arbiters and
there we go handshake and the clocks
have started cooperate opens with 184 he
is so predictable in the openings I've
prepared against him a few years ago and
he never ever deviates uh he plays the
same stuff every single time almost and
what will Magnus choose which opening
he's played everything as we mentioned
any name that has an opening Magnus has
played it at some point or another
throughout his career I'm not sure what
to predict maybe a Kara Khan maybe a
French defense I don't think Magnus will
play one E5 his normal move in solid uh
when he's in a solid mood okay he goes
for the French
and cooperate quickly bringing his
Knight out
it looks like a tarash variation of the
French defense
very very solid stuff
go on Lawrence yeah cd494 yeah I I do
have some experience here
uh in this position here I think Magnus
as well has some experience on the tour
uh there was some recent update I
believe it was in Anish giri's uh course
on this particular opening
um where some new ideas for black in
this interesting structure have have
taken place I'm very curious what
kubernetes will do Bishop D6 Queen E2
all fairly standard stuff
um and now is it the movie E5 that was
the
uh the new idea by Gary I think it might
have been
yeah just I think
yeah you're right Lawrence the move E5
also the move Queen C7 is traditionally
uh one of the strongest and then if
white plays Knight F3 then Black Blocks
the center uh with E5 just preventing
white from advancing forward and
um I know white can play moves such as
C4 in this position and or even taking
on D5 and then C4 it's
very flexible for both sides Magnus
pausing now maybe smelling a wrap
because white has played instantly up to
this point for sure cooperate has
studied this before as I mentioned he
knows his openings inside out uh he
could play blindfold the first 20 moves
Cooper I'd say because uh he knows
exactly what he'll do against every
single opening but uh Magnus will want
us to cause a surprise at some point
that value of the first shock the first
opening uh not necessarily novelty but
the first opening surprise and that is
extremely high when your opponent is
predictable
so uh yeah I think Magnus wants to get a
surprise in whether that's maybe not
playing a standard move like Queen C7
whether it's playing E5 whether it's
developing a knight to E7 whatever it is
Magnus will try and get his opponent out
of book
and there we go Knight E7 is provocative
it allows that pawn push you mentioned
to Lawrence pushing forward with the
white epon but black will happily step
back and argue that
now the center is closed
he doesn't have to worry too much about
the tension he can just push forward the
Black Sea Pawn for example uh what has
cooperate chosen
early B3
surprising unusual
it does allow them with Bishop E5 yes
Hit The Rook on A1 forces white to lose
a Tempo and the black Bishop can plant
itself on C3 for example
as far as I know you shouldn't be
allowing this type of thing for white
but
okay I'm not as big an expert as these
two
in this opening
I've dabbled in it myself but never with
great results I must admit a bit of a
strange one I do think Magnus will try
to cut across White's plants here
because if white gets a bishop on B2 it
will look very strong from that post
um also what if you go Knight G6 here
with black which is another typical idea
because now the F4 square is
very very weak
um yeah good point Lawrence
um the white Bishop the white dark web
should normally does that square but not
if it's about sophian Chateau itself on
B2
yeah and I moved 903 you can still go
Knight F4
but you can even do you can even start
to get creative maybe some Queen A5
chicks suddenly exists Queen F6 is also
on the radar
it should be four check exists yeah
there's a bunch of very tempting options
here for black
and yeah 96 the more I look at it the
more I like it
um it does feel like kuparate I will
mention he plays instantly no matter
what whether he's winning losing drawing
uh he's very instinctive player he
trusts his calculation
um so I think B3 is kind of the product
of uh kind of
freestyling essentially I don't think
it's opening preparation but Magnus does
have those
those tricks obviously Knight G6 looks
very very pleasant for black
Central Point
yep
no I uh
I certainly I I'm not a fan of Peter
I've never really ever seen it in this
opening as well and I I am worried about
these dark squares so I think I think
Magnus would be quite happy
and he does play Knight G6
and
Cooper radzi G3 just trying to limit the
Knight like this but this looks
I don't know that
it looks strange
yeah what if I Castle now
try and get some Central space with E5
now maybe even F5
in some positions starts to exist and
I'm just not I'm just not buying this
for white
yeah no matter where you put the king
now as white you will potentially get
attacked and Magnus is reacted very
quickly after G3 he decided the Black
Knight has no future on G6 so why not
plant it in the center he's going after
the bishop pair Magnus I think this is
again the maximalist approach he wants
the pawn Center but only after grabbing
the pair of Bishops and kubernete in
trademark style Place instantly very
disconcerting when I first played him
kooparez I think he'd gained five
minutes on the clock and I had like
10 seconds left and it was like move 40
um he was up at 25 minutes I was down at
10 seconds it was I mean uh yeah giving
me a heart attack almost but uh yeah
Bishop P2 Magnus looks like he's about
to chop off that Bishop with his Knight
which he does yep he's got the bishop
pair that's step one
and now how does he neutralize the
pressure of the white B2 Bishop is
exerting on the long diagonal
not instantly obvious does black Castle
no like play that E5 move that you
mentioned maybe at the cost of a pawn
just trying to break free the castles
first
and looks like C4
have you ever done this have you ever
tried uh knowing every move instantly
Lawrence because I struggle even when I
tell myself I have to
I mean maybe he just thinks that this is
going to give him a greater chance
against Magnus as well but
certainly not impressed with the opening
[Music]
um yeah
as mentioned in the future chat here by
wash your cup it does look like a good
start to the game uh for Magnus
I mean we can't say it's been a great
success but there's still a lot of
tension despite lacking the bishop Power
white does have nice central control
when white finally does Castle bring the
Rooks to the center it still looks like
a playable position I'm not saying that
black is the advantage I'm not saying
it's decided anytime soon but maybe not
the challenge in the opening that Magnus
is used to facing from some of his
younger kind of Rivals at the top there
and Bishop C8 is that really just been
played I believe that has been played
Bishop C8
this one is a little bit strange
to my eyes he wants to put the bishop on
A6 clearly that's his idea uh to cause
the queen some grief and obviously I am
trying to suede white from castling but
uh
white just castles anyway
and says I don't really care
interests feels like maybe
sorry go on Lawrence
and I was going to say sometimes he
might want to put the bishop on B7 as
well uh if that diamond level gets
opened up what were you going to say
David yes I was gonna say it feels like
uh cooperate his kind of baited Magnus
into speeding up and playing quickly and
Bishop C8 to me just looks
counterproductive Not only was uh it's a
kind of undeveloping move just putting
the bishop back on its starting square
but even if it lands on B7 it will be
blocked if it lands on E6 it will be
blocked it feels like it's given white a
free turn so
if I were Magnus I would maybe slow down
not get tricked into pre-moving as I
think someone was calling it there in
the featured chat and you don't need to
play bullet you could you could just
take your time uh in this very tense
middle game and okay Bishop B7 you're
right you called it uh Lawrence that
Bishop has potential doesn't look great
right now but great potential if the
Center opens up and it's back to
kuberante this is now the planning phase
where you maneuver you put your pieces
on good squares and that often takes
bear Masters the longest uh planning is
definitely not something you can do
intuitively it's something you have to
kind of break down step by step it's a
process calculation is intuitive for
these top GMS but
um I expect to take the first real thing
of the game
and uh there we see oh look at that the
young fans with their uh binoculars
watching the games from afar fantastic
which I've seen in a long time
very very nice so inspiring very very
cute
meanwhile a trick a tactic by cuparazzi
he doesn't pause he sets up
C5 what do you think of that one
Lawrence
nice trick you don't want to take that
pawn off that's for sure because Queen
C3 would be a nasty uh double attack so
you can't take it so you have to move
the bishop probably to C7 maybe E7 I
mean there is an argument to put the
bishop 187 and he does that
um and now I guess he just wants to take
and here Magnus
probably is going to take with the E
Pawn the problem we're taking with the c
Pawn is this the guy suddenly becomes a
protected parser
B4 but A5 and we can't go A3 because of
which way six or can we and then B5
maybe this is still playable things are
getting a little out of control though
can we show there's a trick there
Lawrence after that variation you showed
um okay white played Rook ac1 very
logical but uh if B4 A5
A3 I think you can play Bishop A6
because after B5 you can take on B5
and uh skewer the White Queen
with Rook B8 you win the bishop next
move fantastic and uh I'm also being
told that was a nice tactic if Magnus
had been greedy and taken on C5
uh so we didn't see this variation uh
we'll catch up with the current game but
Queen C3 isn't the most direct uh way to
get an advantage because Queen F6 Saves
the Day for black uh you meet a double
attack with another Well a nice
defensive resource there uh the bishop
on B2 is undefended if white grabs
Black's Bishop but Bishop takes G7 first
would have been uh really strong in that
variation after Bishop takes C5
and uh King takes G7 Queen C3 check
uh Black's King just two open on the
dark squares and white has a big
advantage
so let's catch up let's catch up with
the game
talking about ketchup here not catch up
let's catch up with the game the Queens
are off the board
interesting decision by Magnus he didn't
want the tension anymore
yeah but this is no longer really that
great because you go Knight D6 here as
Cooper rad so every day of the week
and the
excuse me for the coughing today guys as
you can still hear getting over my
sickness
um
the resulting obviously colored Bishop
games are just dead equal right because
after Bishop takes d66 you can
throw in Rook takes D5
and this is this is just just to draw
surely
I mean white white is very active
yeah I mean all three results possible
there but uh you wouldn't bet against
white meanwhile Cooperative didn't go
for this I think he missed a trick
you're right Lawrence could have thrown
that Knight into D6 it would have been a
real spanner in the works for magnus's
game plan uh going for a drawing end
game even if wipes down upon getting
that opposite color Bishop scenario
instead he traded Rooks but look how
active Black's Rook is now black has The
Simple Plan of playing F6 blunting
White's Bishops diagonal and then King
F7 bring the black uh King towards the
center Rook C4 interesting I was going
to say Black's other plan was to plant
the bishop on A6 activating black light
Square Bishop but now that's less
attractive potentially because of Rook
A4
although some calculation needs to be
done in that variation
Rook A4 is coming and uh yeah I love
that I love that comment in the featured
chat this is just a draw surely uh says
everyone who's lost to Magnus on move
100 and uh yeah Magnus always seems to
get the point to get the win
when uh when it goes down to a long game
but look at the clock times as well
Cooper heads they still with 14 minutes
left
I mean if there was a bulletball
championship I think he'd be one of the
favorites to win it just the speed at
which he plays
Rook C4 interesting move Rook A4 next
and uh what do you think Lawrence shall
we stick with this one as it enters the
new phase or should we take a look at
some of the other big boards yeah let's
let's look at some yeah absolutely uh we
should absolutely do that
so uh
who should we look at
um
board 2 looks very balanced uh very very
balanced yep hard to imagine anything
too exciting going on here better save
with a small space Advantage so you'd
probably pick white but black Ultra
solid and uh yeah finishing development
at last
um this is board two board three a big
clash between Daniel duboff and Abdul
sator of maybe we can check in there
at Lawrence onboard three yeah
and uh this is the current position
wow big Pawn on D6 for duboff
on one hand it is yeah on one hand it is
a big phone on the other hand it's not
that secure just yet so I mean I can
always put my Rook on d8
um
I can attack it three times I can even
try and remove this knight from C4
I don't know like it doesn't feel to me
like a massive deal just yet Rook D1 is
standard
yeah
it doesn't feel like a massive deal to
me
um that said I would still take quite
but intuitively I would say it feels
like
the pawn isn't actually going anywhere
yeah it feels like it should be a
holdable position for black defensible
um the nightmare scenario is that you
get trapped in an end game where Black's
Queen is forced to sit as a Defender
Queens are just simply the worst
blockadas uh in chess Queens
they are destined to be strong pieces
attacking pieces threatening stuff you
don't want them sitting guarding mere
pawns so Black's Queen needs to activate
herself at some point but yeah it's just
about whether white can build up look at
the poses there between the two players
dubov calm but focused abducatorov
throwing all his energy into this game
he knows that if he gets rid of that
white d-pawn it should be a draw so can
He surround it somehow can he some point
trade off those Knights potentially
White Knight has fantastic potential to
kick away that black queen
you know I've got to slightly disagree
Lawrence I think white has great chances
here okay but but interesting it's not
it's not direct it's not immediate
um it is a long uh it's gonna be a long
battle surrounding that deep one
and um yeah how about other games okay
then this one later
yes let's do that uh I think
well I've had an Arjun
on board five
catching a ride super interesting
position after King hm looks tough at
mvl now this looks like one of those
positions where a timely F5 Break by
Wyatt might just seal the deal
the black king extremely open the white
King on the other hand very very safe
on B1 what is to stop white just
playing F5 at the right moment
yeah it looks like the young members of
the audience are confused as well about
uh this position look at that pawn
structure I had to do a quick counter
quick Double Take it is level pawns all
eight pawns for both sides still on the
board but you're right Lawrence E5 at
the right moment should spell disaster
for black and what I'm wondering whether
Eric icy can build up even more for that
pawn push whether he
improves the White Queen first maybe
tries to double up the two white Rooks
on the junior file first but that would
give black time to start pushing on the
opposite flank pushing the black B Pawn
maybe
um so yeah why not now it feels like
you've got to seize the moment F5 it's
looking very good for every guy see
and uh flashing the graph he's fought
his way up the table after a bit of a
slow start but uh yeah he he will want
to keep his momentum if he loses this
game actually anyone in the chasing pack
on around five and a half if they lose
this game
they might be out of running out of the
running for the gold medals still in
contention for good prizes of course
very generous prizes on offer here in
Kazakhstan but yeah it's a crucial round
for everyone I shiligruff I think we
should see F5 here I think eragasi
should go for it it feels like a moment
and uh yeah actually grew up on the back
foot
massively on the back foot here you can
also include maybe Queen E2
just to then when you go F5 for example
let's say black plays B5 and you've got
F5 if black ever decides to do something
silly like take everything suddenly you
can take and actually deliver a
checkmate
so maybe including we need two is useful
I'm not entirely sure
makes a lot of sense and Lawrence can we
go to uh the game yes Hans Neiman
because we've just seen a incredible
tactic in that game it looks like Hans
Neiman might be ending his day on a loss
uh if we go back a few moves uh just
five six moves here
um white
okay after a trade of pieces white is
winning a pawn but at this position
after Rook f8 Rook takes A6
ignoring the attack against the White
Queen
I mean the incredible full board Vision
there and uh we see that if the White
Queen is captured then white gets two
Rooks for the queen and two extra Pawns
simple winning end game and uh Neiman
didn't want to defend this one it looks
like instead he's gone into a hopeless
hurricane game two pawns down
yeah yeah amazing uh amazing tactical
Vision a matter of technique doubt
should be quite straightforward I feel
uh to mop up you've got two extra pawns
yes they're doubled the B pawns the G
pawns but Black's position is full of
holes full of weaknesses
big result for You Yankee big big result
potentially for you indeed and getting
uh flashes that Magnus Carlsen
is suddenly tons better
we should go there and this is the
position
now Magnus
uh G5 starting to exert pressure the
point being I guess that you can't allow
uh the Bishops to get too active
something like this because before you
know it you could get mated
uh very very embarrassing even something
like this is going to be mate
after Bishop G4 check
and you get mated to Magnus managing to
get these Bishops out of what's really
impressed me about this game and about
Magnus is is actually the the opening
choice
the opening choice is is phenomenal the
French defense this particular line keep
the two Bishops you manage to get that
that pawn structure that unbalanced Pawn
structure I love it G5 Rook A1 played by
cooperatsu
and no chance Magnus will swap these
Rooks off now he's gonna keep the Rooks
on surely as he said he wants to go for
checkmate why not Rook C2 just attack
exact white Bishop gain time keep the
Rooks on the board and then continue
with the plans to open up the position
we should also mention that Magnus is a
pawn up at least temporarily yes the
black A5 Pawn is going to drop but uh
it's four versus three on the king side
active Bishops
Bishop d4s you say Lawrence it just
feels like you need a little bit of
finesse to get Black's dark Square
Bishop into the game
I don't see it immediately I've got to
say you can just take on F4 here
basically and then go like three yeah
what's the video
I think you just do it slow and steady
Rook G2 check is coming worse comes to
worse you plant your Bishop on D5 uh as
black and you say okay I've got a beast
in the center of the board and you're
never getting past my Bishop pair I
think you predicted the future you
should buy some rotary tickets Lawrence
uh he's taking everything he's gonna
play I did I didn't win
uh maybe next year and
um
yeah it's looking fantastic for black
that white knight yes it's going porn
hunting but it's on a poor circuit it's
going to take ages to get back in the
game
and I don't think there were only
counter-attacks against the black king
is that the one thing Magnus is uh
trying to avoid for example after Bishop
F3 Rook takes A5 whites Rook could try
and sneak behind with some checks
Black's King should just be able to walk
out into the open the uh Magnus just
trying to be accurate and as has been
pointed out by a few people in the uh in
the feature chat
yeah Cooper I'd say no longer blitzing
but he's played quite quick still with
10 minutes on the clock against magnus's
six
and uh yeah it feels like some of the
players are impatient to get today done
because some really surprising results
uh I'll tell me ever won as black in 17
moves against one of the stars of the
tournament all the Don mertzin uh we saw
Mama jorov take a seven move draw
against Manuel petrozian
tiredness is kicking in Lords fatigue is
setting in for some of these players
absolutely I mean and this is again
where Magnus kind of differentiates
himself right where it's the final
stretch where he manages to keep that
energy up keep the momentum going keep
the high level in the intensity go some
of the other guys just can't do it it's
exhausting playing this kind of
tournament and uh
with all the pressure on top as well
very very tough indeed a Magnus does
indeed play for sure three in this one I
mean Cooper I'd say is just not saving
this position not in this lifetime fully
expect a win here by Carlson and
given the state of the other games at
the moment would not be surprised if he
does actually go into the final day uh
as the top scorer
yeah solid day for Carson solid day for
Carson nothing spectacular but you don't
need that necessarily it's definitely an
art form of grinding out these wins when
you're not playing your best I also
noticed a really nice uh trick here
Lawrence I meant I mentioned a few
moments ago Rook takes A5 trying to
counter attack for white and black can
just play Bishop H4 shut the door on the
white king create that meeting that Rook
C1 is coming with Checkmate and White's
forced back onto the defensive and now
you can just start picking up pawns at
will yeah Richie two rotates H2
game over pretty much that white king is
trapped
athlete utterly helpless here
yeah it looks like
Giga has started to realize the
kind of uh yeah the severity of his yeah
troubles he's really slowed down spent
what two three minutes on this one move
that for him that is an ocean of time
and eventually he has I think just
captured this Pawn on A5 with his Knight
yeah black and just playing Bishop D5
assert full dominance full control
Bishop H4 still on Tap Root G2 check
tempting
everything looks good for black
yeah yeah I just take a position is
hopeless
we can go elsewhere if you would like
yeah and uh there is a round actually in
the women's section uh they are playing
their final round of the day uh tomorrow
will be three games uh today they're
playing their fourth game of the day and
um remember there were eight leaders in
the women's section I'm just looking at
those top four boards right now between
those eight leaders
all of them look pretty balanced
Lawrence yeah like
nobody really wants to give ground take
too many risks in that women's section
um maybe we check over there a bit later
when the action begins
and uh Nice Shot there of all the flags
of the competing countries
what are we zooming in on
Spectators and uh yeah meanwhile Magnus
has grabbed that white H2 Pawn the white
king is in Mortal Danger
I can't see this one lasting too much
longer I've got to say
yeah before played by Cooper radza but
this is more of a inertia kind of move
I think Magnus now
will probably put the bishop on D5
consolidate that Bishop
um
you also completely cut the Knight out
from action so Bishop T5 is a very
intuitive move
then the bishop is going to come to H4
probably come to G3
Target this Pawn
let's see absolutely no hope here for
Giga cooperatza in my opinion yeah
that's a very classy move Lawrence
Bishop D5 and don't forget Black's H
Pawn Alex H Pawn is going to race down
the board it's still it's not the
seventh rank but uh it's only four or
five moves away from promotion and
yeah body language Magnus looks very
focused but he knows he's in control
maybe the only thing to calculate here
is what happens if for example white
plays uh after Bishop G5 uh White plays
B5 tries to break through with the c
Pawn but it's going nowhere you just
take that pawn and after C6 you can I
mean you can take uh you can choose
anything here Rook C2 at the very very
minimum uh to keep an eye on that white
Pawn
yeah this one is
winning
um it's a matter of time Bishop D5 I'm
surprised we haven't seen Carlson play
it it's a very carson-esque type of move
uh just locking White Knight out on the
side of the board but I think he's just
enjoying his position uh he's got still
almost four minutes
and he is winning meanwhile I'm looking
around as well Lawrence and every other
board is still balanced so maybe if we
can stick here until Magnus delivers uh
the killer blow
he has just played Bishop D5 as we see
on the live board
white is almost paralyzed almost no
moves here yeah White's Rook is a Target
on the first rank
yeah I
unfortunately four Giga Tournament of
his life one of the best uh performers
so far
he's created some huge upsets but
his run ends here in this game
[Music]
and uh meanwhile we maybe we can check
over on board two just to see if there's
uh anything dramatic going on
let's do that
dramatic is not quite the word if you're
talking about the federacy of
Kmart okay far from
one can hope that these guys very very
solid especially Vincent not often a
huge risk take-up with the black pieces
would be happy I think with a draw today
um finishing off a very very solid day
and it looks like you might get it I see
no issues with Vincent's position
whatsoever here I guess you don't either
yeah I completely agree I don't see
anything wrong with Black's position
very solid if anyone has to be careful
it might be white because the A4 Pawn is
a clear Target and
um there we go we see the two players
very focused feather save the one thing
that's made be held him back in previous
uh kind of elite events is the fact that
he forgets occasionally to pull the
reverse gear and uh to kind of pull the
brakes just knuckle down take a draw uh
but is this the moment could we see a
handshake now because after the white
Rook
uh kind of line up the discovered attack
against the black king king E8 has been
played Vincent looks ready to end this
game I'm expecting Rook C1 from White
and repetition of the position C1 Rook
B1 just no matter where the black king
goes keeping an eye on the open files
uh for the Rooks so let's see if fed is
safe bails out with the draw here I
think he will and then maybe we can
check out board three Daniel dubov uh
let's keep an eye on Magnus as well just
in case
to be done
okay
that looks risky on the face of things
Knight b69 C4 exists
it might be six maybe there are some
tricks White's night will take on E6 for
example there and black snipe is hanging
on B6
even Rook takes A4 there I'm not sure
how
how bad it is uh things are getting
a little bit out of hand but is this so
bad for
I mean at least light will be a pawn up
white will be a point up right after
treating the Rooks and taking on G7
yes that's true this is something
Vincent doesn't want
uh so okay maybe Knight D6 maybe King
back to D7
I don't think black has too much to
worry about still white has no threats
shall we yes
yeah
um
Daniel dubov against Abdus
I think he might have been right
Lawrence and this game
should be in the balance I do think
black's Queen side pawns are enough of a
distraction uh they will at some point
deflect away White's pieces and the
white d-pawn
should drop off in that process I think
without the knights there's no real way
to make progress Black's King is also
coming
I would choose white still I've got to
say but uh if there's a draw of
Tenacious Defender should be able to
hold this one
and he thoughts yeah I I don't really
see I've just a tour of in any serious
danger here whatsoever
uh it feels like this is going to end
peacefully one way or another
I don't see abdulsator of taking immense
risk either I think you can just
basically jostle here you could even
just move the king back
um King F7 for example just literally
move the king and
see no way to really make progress for
either player
yeah yeah just feels like a draw
yeah maybe on that note let's follow the
end of uh cooperate against Carlson
because Magnus has just played a huge
move giving up his extra pawn and uh
look at this black F Pawn race through
now can white hold the blockade white is
playing without the Knight
can he blockade on the dark squares
though
see cooperate giving a check still
blitzing he's got seven minutes almost
against magnus's two how do we finish
off as black
velvet velvet Canyon thinks Magnus is
doing this on purpose I don't know if he
means winning the game or uh just ending
the day on a high okay Rook C1
Bishop D2 Rook C2 oops
Rook C2 King E1 and F2 check
is one y ouch
yeah that wins because you either win
the piece or the
all the or you make a queen so Rook C1 I
see nothing here
what if Bishop G4 putting the white
Bishop back on a square at least it can
cover the F Pawn
um I agree ugly for white Bishop pass
super strong for black especially before
played
Rook C2 check where's the killer blow
I don't see it just in this variation
key three
wow King E3 I thought he was going to
hide back on F1
now surely the F Pawn has a way to sneak
through
Rook F4 check if the black pawn moves if
F2 Rooker four track saves the day just
in time
still looks pretty scary for white with
the King out in the open but holdable
maybe well Magnus just will Magnus just
play a subtle move like King E8 just
getting away from that check
that feels like a magnificent type of
move
it does yes
I mean I'm not sure it's the best one
the most direct one but it now does set
up the threat of F2 because uh record 4
is always met by Bishop G5 okay Magnus
didn't go for anything so subtle he
played H5 first
black has two pawns uh two past pawns so
why not push them both
yep Rook F4 check
yeah
linking D3
okay
sorry no I'm saying it's still not over
but with this Knight isolated out the
game
uh just Rook C1 and marching the H Pawn
should be enough even if this Knight
comes back I think you can just ignore
it Knight D6 chip and put the key onto
yourself and say so what
I'll dance on the light squares you
can't touch me
uh that was quite an assortment of
pieces there on the defile that was a
nice variation yeah but uh okay he
chooses for actually two I liked your
Rook C1 just because it stopped Knight
C4 but maybe Knight C4 isn't such a uh
such an issue
uh I like that from elementative
cerebral as well in the future chat like
this giving Thai mods one minute now
against six and a half that's the only
potential hazard in magnus's position
should be enough though not not with not
with 10 seconds per move
um bonus that's that's way too much
B5 okay Cooper ads are trying
something
c6b5
feels like desperation yeah C6
but now
Bishop G5 Rook D to check
before check at the end Oh that's oh no
sorry I was hallucinating I thought I
could go Bishop G5 Rook D2 and B4 mate
but my Bishop
would have Departed
um okay what's the professional
way here
I'm seeing some I'm seeing some tricks
for example of black plays Bishop d8
which looks tempting just to stop the
pawn just to take away the White Knight
then after Bishop d8 maybe bishop C5 for
white Lawrence what do you think of that
black king trapped give me okay a second
as I've just got to readjust something
here
um
just one second but he went Rook G4
you know virtually for you talked about
professional approach that is a very
professional just getting the roots on
board
forces the rules of the book Rook F5
runs into Bishop E4 check
yeah
and if white pushes with C7 then I think
the black king can safely stop that pawn
uh it looks comes across
you go no further and
yeah
him over like there's too many points
now nice technique 39 seconds though
should be enough for Carlson Cooperative
giving him a scare but yeah
unfortunately two Bishops too strong
and uh
in general yes tell me David I was gonna
say I if I play Magnus I will never ever
give him a long-term Advantage like the
pawn structure Bishop pair because I
know long term it will decide the game
there have been some results in the
meantime I'll just quickly update your
do Bob address was a draw that game we
looked at Duda and draken draw in a
ponyarchy Serana draw tomaszewsky Grisha
draw petrozian manager of draw Hans
Neiman did in fact lose
to you Yang Yi we we looked at that
briefly that good spot and followed our
mosin's good run has come to an end he
loses with white to uh Timmy of uh his
only loss uh of the tournament so far
that will be a nasty one to take home uh
tonight but uh it is what it is
um let's go to Arjun surely
people can stay here uh oh just okay for
a little bit uh I think we might be
about to see a result okay Magnus just
putting the finishing touches to this
game and then as you mentioned uh Arjun
beating ashila Graf caruana also looks
like he's doing well and winning
uh it's just the time scramble or it's
Magnus down under 20 seconds
looks a bit nervous it looks a bit
Twitchy yeah dealing with pieces
it got it got less less easy right
suddenly
um I think it's still pretty easy you
match the B Pawn forward distract the
white king
and that should be that uh cooperate
with five minutes
I think you'll resign white simply has
nowhere to go with his pawns they're
both blockaded black spawns steal the
deal
and yeah
37 seconds now for Magnus more than
enough look at him he's ready to end the
day
and Cooper and say just looking for one
final trick
I don't think you're in time
unfortunately to run the white king
towards the black king side pawns
because Black's b-pawn too fast
and uh yeah one tempo too slow for white
and that's what it comes down to Magnus
has calculated this out we see the
evaluation bar confirming the fact that
black is winning
white cannot stop the pawn coming to G3
long term costing away his Bishop
final throws Lawrence do you think we'll
see a handshake now
I think we'll see it in
just about any second yes
Magnus is ready
look at that body language
no problems whatsoever
look at this uh Lawrence he's staring
down the camera staring into all of our
souls here at home and uh Magnus he's
seen everything there is to see on the
board he didn't even need to look
now we go B4 coming
B3 is coming E2 is coming B1 Queen is
coming and
White's King is overstretched
I think this is the moment we will see
cooperate
give up
what a game it's been nice instructive
when actually long term like you said
opening Choice two Bishops
stretching playing on both sides of the
board
I'm gonna shaking his head yeah
totally agree
Bishop D4
but now B3 seems to be where
B3 is 100 winning
King E3
now how about the move Bishop B6 here is
that yeah calculate that one uh you've
got to calculate that Lawrence maybe we
can quickly show on the board uh yeah it
should be six uh
would have been met by a capture and uh
it would have been a race I'm not sure
you want to enter a race after B2 oh
yeah white section you're doing well
here yeah it was a queen yeah I missed
that
yeah but uh let's catch up with the game
position white is trying to set up a
blockade but
it won't last for long surely just King
D5
Magnus about to put his King into the
center
and everything collapses
yeah yeah
there we go white Bishop can't hold both
the F and B Pawns
that can just actually start snatching
the white Pawns
exactly
[Music]
um
and yeah not much to say about this
position unfortunately for the Georgian
Grand Master and I think of course the
most shocks by the end of the tournament
he's still in the mix of course Cooper
I'd say but Magnus taking the lead in
the tournament and then we have to
handshake the result confirmed Magnus
takes an important win
massive win for Magnus Carlson he has
really just been on it since round one
he moves to seven and a half out of nine
he will most likely be the sole leader
because the game between Felice and
Kamar does look very difficult to see
being decisive I mean this just looks
like a draw
um whichever way you want to cook it
so that will that will mean that Carlson
goes into the final date as a just a
straight leader similar enough out of
nine
and maybe now as this game pieces out
towards the draw Lawrence maybe we can
go to that game Eric I see it against
vashilograph because let's go for the
pawn structure
called pawns for white uh drunken pawns
as we call them on the C file those
white rook and Knight on F6 I mean both
of those two pieces just entrenched look
at what white is doing look he's
invading this isn't this is an army
invading the opposition territory
um black is utterly Frozen
yeah this is
[Music]
this is power play this is domination
um you don't often see MBL without any
Dynamic play or opportunity this is one
of those rare occasions
um
yeah just look at the focus
I was about to say I'd be tempted to
start moving the king yeah just uh bring
it up the board plan it on C4 planet on
somewhere F3
um wait Black is Black is stuck like you
said dominated uh black can't move black
doesn't want to take the Rook on D6 with
this bishop because that would just
improve the white Pawn structure uh just
to show this maybe C takes D6 and
even without white tonight I think
you're winning here uh Black's roots are
just powerless against the massive pawns
uh likewise you don't really want to
take the White Knight because then you
part with your Bishop what Black's King
is stuck in a meeting that
um okay the king is coming white still
needs a break through a plan to finish
this one off
I'm not sure where Eric guys he's
running with his King let's catch up
with the game position Maybe
and uh
yeah it just feels like a matter of time
before the Breakthrough does happen can
Maxine vasilograph try and get one piece
active at least he's trying to get his
Queen across now Rook B1 at least a
black Rook can start to enter
um this is one of those scenarios uh I
love this great book by Dave smerden
about the uh ultimate chess swindler and
the type of position when you've had so
much control for so long it's easy to
Take Your Eye Off the ball for one move
and let it all show
still not out of it Magnus here watching
board two uh we see on the camera just
uh intrigued to see how his Rivals get
on
oh wow it takes H4
Maxim is he fighting back
97 Bishop takes H4 hold on a second
well probably not you can take and go
Rook B6 here find it very difficult to
believe that
you hold this position
as black
yeah find it almost impossible to
believe in fact
yeah the black queen completely locked
out of any open files she has to
choose a awkward square like h8 if she
wants to stay on the board
but uh yeah it takes too long to get
active there
I'm keeping an eye on board too but it
looks like uh that game that Magnus was
watching is about to be agreed drawn and
uh yeah Magnus will be the sole leader
after two of three days after nine of 13
Rounds Queen h8 played by vashilograph
Y how does he break through rugby seven
yeah you go after the F7 horn now
Queen A7 is probably good enough
Black's Only Hope Lawrence is to play H4
and queen H5 maybe at some point at
least to try and start checking the
white king but I think it's too slow uh
it still takes you three or four moves
Queen A8 actually does it doesn't it
that's that's well
in Ocean he wants to give one check on
H5 Queen 68 Queen H5 King F2
no more checks then there's a queen F6
checked
yeah this is also
good enough
Queen H5 King E3 and MBL does indeed
resign massive win for Eric AC
means that he is still up there a point
behind Magnus
with four rounds to go still possible in
fact
majority of our games are over let's
have a quick look at the women's section
tanjong ji with a massive win
uh against
uh
Alina bevel
massive win for her
means that she
maintains her lead well you actually
finally beating Elena daniellen moves
aren't coming through there uh here they
are now uh but in 30 moves just looks
like a typical
boyajukina grind but something went
wrong very soon for daniellin oh she she
let this she let Bishop takes B7 that
looks like looks like around here she's
actually holding equal material
um the two Bishops are better than the
two knights but this Brook H7 was a big
mistake allowing Bishop takes p7 the
point being Knight takes three seven
runs into Rook C7 check and you lose the
Rook so after Bishop takes uh
we go back to the game
uh if we go to yes Rook H7 she tries to
hang on with this but now after takes
takes she actually lost a piece that was
a very quick Collapse by Elena daniellen
but very welcome uh for koyagekina and
that means that tanjonji
and SRI Savita the 2300 rated Indian
player are all on six and a half out of
eight with a whole bunch of players on
six but yes
another top Kazakh player who has just
won four on the bounce
so Dinara
very much in the mix there too
yeah and Lawrence we we just saw a
handshake in one of the uh final
remaining games of the women's section
another game going on here uh in the
background I think that's maltzelskaya
against uh atusa uh he now plays for the
us but meanwhile there is a game on
board 5 of the women's section still
ongoing uh really tense Rook end game
it's a pawn race I'm wondering if we
could switch that between humpy glass
and uh and uh shovel over from Russia
uh that one humpy Canary has been
winning the whole game but suddenly it's
in the balance and uh suddenly like
maybe has some chances the bar disagrees
still thinks white is winning
black porn can promote but white will
slide across with rook hhx and win that
black queen on H1
maybe the idea is that you
oh do you still give a check on h8
you can also play F5 right because you
block the file and this isn't actually a
threat because of rookie J
very very nice Lawrence I think that
might be the only directly winning move
and
it's been played F5 yeah okay Jake check
is coming and the white pawns will be
too strong if white can sacrifice her
Rook for that black H Pawn
exactly yeah something like between your
tree Rook h8 exactly King G2 and simply
uh E7 is probably good enough
um
yeah something like this you can go F6
point being you can always sacrifice oh
she goes King G4 she tries this but she
gets into a hopeless uh position
um after
uh yeah you can do this uh King E7 and
we're gonna get a classic Lucena which
hampi canaro has known
since she was in short pants uh
yeah and then it's one of the
it's one of the first things we learn
right as a chess player yeah the first
10 games we learn uh especially Rook
endings but this could be also uh really
really important for the stunting
standings uh hampi will only be half a
point off the lead I believe uh after
winning this game and she is one of the
most experienced players in the field
she could still stick a claim on the
last day in that last three round
Sprints tomorrow uh Rook F2 really
classy move there cutting off that black
king cutting off the opponent's king is
just strong in any end game pretty much
and uh yeah the black king can never
rejoin the battle to stop the white E
Pawn so final few moves of this game I
wouldn't be surprised to see shovel over
resign now Paulina
no chance white is playing E7 and that
pawn costs like her Rook and Lawrence
what a dramatic day so many decisive
games in the final round of the women's
section we had eight leaders
three one with the white pieces so we'll
have three leaders going into tomorrow
and uh here we see in front of us I
think this is Alexander donchenko
um up against a player is that Dennis
lazovic
um let me check
um let's try and find this game
so this is indeed uh Alexander Don
shenko
uh with the yeah correct
actually Magnus was talking to me about
lazovic as well as being a super Talent
from Belarus
and bonchenko in big trouble here is
white
uh needs to find some
some resource and it looks like he might
have found a resource here
H4
maybe white can now eliminate the
remaining black pawns anyone who's
watched title Tuesday who's played title
Tuesday before will be familiar with
Dennis lazovic uh who's playing the
black pieces he's crushed me many a time
super quick very tactically alert I
think he's won title Tuesday at least
once or twice which is no easy feat with
uh plays like Hikaru playing and uh Hey
the black king attacks the white Rook
Bishop E7 wow it's really loose for
white but maybe it's good enough
uh the black pawns are kind of stuck to
each other like string just as soon as
one Falls the other one will fall even
at the cost of White's bishop and now
yeah I think we will see rook and Knight
versus Rook a long grind uh should be a
drop because Don checo has found a way
to give up his Bishop for the remaining
black Pawns
could be here a while Lawrence watching
this oh goodness yeah well we might be
we might be we might not be that will
depend on our lovely producer if he
wants to make us suffer this rookin
Knight versus rook and uh
hmm
ing
gonna draw this with his eyes closed you
would expect uh we'll watch it a little
bit
okay this Rooker Knight versus Rook it
is one of those end games that again
most grand Masters do know they have
practiced or they have faced it in their
practical play at some point in their
career and unlike Rooker Bishop versus
Rook the drawing method is quite
straightforward you usually want to just
give checks from afar pin the Black
Knight whenever possible and uh the
problem is Black's King and Knight are
bound to each other as soon as the black
king tries to escape any possible pins
any possible checks the white king runs
the opposite direction and uh yeah
there's just no real weight to Checkmate
unless you're given a helping hand by
your opponent that being said we have
seen luminaries of the game such as Judy
Polgar lose this ending to Kasparov
years ago and uh it is possible to go
astray meanwhile a bit surprising that
donchenko has allowed his King to be
caught on the edge of the board it's not
the end of the world far from it uh
black will now give her a check with the
Rook that we see Dennis lazovic Force
the white king to the edge of the board
but this is not terminal Black's king is
too far away from the white king to
close any mating Nets
and yeah you can see on both players
body language lasovic as black resigned
to the fact that he was winning earlier
now it should be a draw donchenko
relieved knows he's close to a draw but
still needs to be accurate he needs to
be careful and uh yeah
sorry Rook F7 would run into Knight G5
check just as a you know you can still
blunder so
gotta be careful
yeah I think the easiest is to what uh
is to run the white king
as far away as possible from the black
king so I would start advancing the
white king up the board as long as
that's safe
um oh he did Retreat his Rook but not
the square that was losing as you
pointed out Lawrence he Retreats it uh
to the safer Square on F5 5 and Max
Black's Kings gotta come back now you
need to combine The Rook the king and
the Knight together in order to have any
chance of trapping the opponent's
monarch
so there we go that King comes back
but still still very difficult for black
the king is cut off just as we saw in
the humpy game Black's King cannot cross
the f file and finally we see donchenko
improve his King's position advancing
away from the black king
yeah this is one that I remember my
first coach playing against him and he
would mate me every time until I
realized how to defend that's white but
still not easy and it's uh pretty much
the most dangerous version of this
endgame that you'll ever see
and he hold it on drinker
great question well we'll soon find out
uh we're not going to follow this until
the end this could go on for quite some
time what we're going to do is we're
going to take a quick look at the
playing Hall as things empty out you can
see most games have finished for today
tomorrow we've got the final day of the
rapid tournament we start at the same
time
uh we will take you through of course
all the action four rounds
and if there is a playoff required of
course we will be there for that as well
given how Bunch things are in the
women's section I will say there's a
very high chance for playoff there in
the open section well it all depends on
one man doesn't it Magnus Carlson
currently leading outright I did think
he had a good chance of leading out
right with a day to go
he is on seven and a half out of nine
um just a very very solid performance by
Magnus winning when he had to
um and
you know it's now on the rest of the
field to show something else Magnus is
just going to win this tournament who
can stop him we'll have to find out
tomorrow
um David uh just very quickly your
impressions of today
yeah
um firstly impressed by Magnus he's not
been at his best we should clarify but
he's ground out those results he's
survived difficult positions and he took
his chances when they came I'm really
loving following some of these young
players Vincent Keim is really impressed
today Abdul sotorov as always impressing
and uh also today's been special for
some of the quick victories we saw many
of the top Grandmasters in the world
lose in less than 20 moves especially
Daniel Dubose Queen H5 move that uh that
blow that destroyed nihau Cyrus defenses
I recommend everyone who's just joined
us recently to go back and check that
one out uh the move of the tournament so
far and of course in the women's section
it's so close it's uh you have to toss
the coin in order to pick a favorite
there and I can't wait tomorrow as you
mentioned Lawrence if we do see tie
breaks playoffs it's going to be extra
dramatic so uh yeah it's uh lived up to
expectations so far this tournament I'm
hoping that continues tomorrow
indeed uh we sure hope it does and we
want to thank everybody of course for
watching today we're going to be back
same time same same place tomorrow
before I go though make sure with the
new year around the corner to get ready
for the 2023 daily championship starting
on January 1st 5 000 in cash prizes are
up for grabs this year don't miss your
chance to improve your daily chest
prayers if you like playing daily chess
make sure you drop uh exclamation mark
daily terms in the chat for more
information on that specific tournament
that's gonna be it from us tomorrow is
D-Day for the rapid tournament is Magnus
Carlson gonna Coast his way to another
title or not we'll soon see in the
women's section up for grabs anything
can happen I still think there are a few
twists and turns left though make sure
you join us same time same place
tomorrow from me and from Grandma's to
David Howe to Cheerio for today stay
healthy stay safe see you tomorrow
bye-bye
life is full of exciting events but it
is our first impressions that we
remember best your first diploma
[Applause]
your first job in a big company
Unforgettable emotions from the first
date the first expensive things you
bought when you got your first paycheck
and your first Investments with freedom
broker Freedom broker look at your
favorite brands from A New Perspective
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign